We're all streaming now.
You were gonna say it.
You were about to say it.
You were so close.
Oh shit, wait, what was I gonna say?
Fuck.
You know.
You know exactly what you're gonna say.
You know that you're fucking right.
Wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, hold on.
What the?
Wait, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold on, we weren't ready.
We didn't even...
What the fuck?
They just started asking us?
Please ask us when we are...
If we are...
We are...
Are...
Before starting.
Yeah, I'm like, what?
Okay, we're banning Groot.
We banned Groot first because he wasted Protect on Namor.
Wait, are we playing?
Is this it?
Wait, the other team's not ready either.
Who started it then?
We were not...
They were not ready either?
Okay, ban Groot.
It was the caster.
I think it was the caster that...
Yeah, it was the one.
Wait, should we not do real bans then?
Or what's going on?
No, we're doing real bans.
This is like our bad line.
We're playing?
Okay.
Yeah, because like, the thing is, they always protect DPS.
So if they protect Namor, they wasted their...
Okay, they didn't protect Namor.
But I'm just trying to see if they'll waste their Protection on that.
Protect Mag.
Yeah, we protect Mag here always.
And then now who we ban here?
Namor or Deluna?
I don't know.
We ban Luna here.
Okay.
They play Bucky too, right?
Yeah.
I think he's more important.
But their Eternity player doesn't play Bucky.
Is this 2 out of 3?
Yeah, best out of 3.
They researched.
That's fine.
They did the research.
Look at them.
Finally.
Oh my god.
Alright, so we can either run the normal 2-2-2 comp.
Or we can do a mix-up of the 3-support Bucky.
Let's try 3-support Bucky first.
Because we're attacking first, so we can easily swap.
Alright.
If it doesn't work, we'll just run triple or Shoto swap-swap support.
Yeah.
And I can do... I don't know, Hella or something.
We'll see.
Ooh, Adam's duty.
Let's go.
Also, to my chat.
Yeah, my team's Celestial now.
We did some late-night grinding.
We did some...
Yeah, we did some late-night grinding where we got the rest of our team to Celestial.
Coney may have carried my ass.
Yeah, Coney.
Coney was the MVP.
Gomez jumped off the cliff and then Coney went in and stole the MVP.
I was told to in my battle.
It was his choice.
Yeah, it was his choice.
He chose to jump off.
Oh, let's see how you guys play.
Oh, they're on their penny?
Interesting.
That's interesting.
Cool.
They have Bucky.
Coney's low, breaking the mine.
Yeah, I'll push Hella soon.
Hella's dead.
Hella should die.
Nice, let's push in.
I'm gonna Soulbond us.
I'm Soulbonding us so we can push in.
Push up, push up.
I'm healing.
No Soulbond.
No more Soulbond.
Bucky grabbed.
I'm fine.
He's one.
What the?
Shouldn't she die?
Penny, penny, penny, penny, penny one.
Loki up top.
Invis?
Yeah.
Good job.
Nice.
We don't need that thing.
I do, but you guys got it.
Someone's invisible, someone's invisible.
I hear him, I hear him.
Someone's invisible.
I think they backed out.
I think it was Loki.
Yeah, I hear someone up here.
That's fine.
Mag.
Maybe the Loki.
I think you heard Loki's Invis.
Yeah, it's probably Loki.
Oh, there was nobody there.
Okay.
Oh, he shifted.
Loki shifted.
I have no ammo.
Bucky on the left.
That's spot.
Yeah, it's Loki out of position here.
Nice, nice.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna...
I'm Soulbonding.
Push up, push up if you want.
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
Alright, that's...
Behind us.
I can counter this.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, they ulted too.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, that's double.
That's both their support ults.
Yeah, they both, they used both their support.
We still have ours.
I'm Agumoto-ing.
I'm gonna shift up and drop in back.
Okay.
Oh, they ulted.
I'm rezzing, I'm rezzing.
That's huge, that's huge.
Nice, good, good.
Nice.
Push up, push up, push up.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Yeah, we're pushing out here.
You guys are fine, you guys are fine.
I'll push cart.
One support push up with them.
One of them push up with them.
I'll push cart.
Burn this, burn this, burn this, burn this, burn this.
Oh my god.
She's gone.
She's fucking gone.
We were on top of that.
Holy shit.
I hope he's swapping off Hella because that was not inspirational.
Whoa.
Goddamn.
Oh my god, he's committing to the Hella pick after that.
I'd be a little embarrassed and swap off.
And be like, guys, I was just changing ults.
That's a whole ult he just like used up.
Nice.
They have Mag ult by the way.
I'm saving my Soul Bond for it.
Trying to shield you?
Alright.
Okay, of course, let's go for that.
Yeah, that's like his worst.
Yeah, that's good for us.
I have ult soon too.
Nice.
Hella's on top, or was.
Okay, okay.
I'm saving Soul Bond for Mag ult.
Push up.
Good shit.
Keep pushing up.
We have three picks.
There's no reason to play.
I have ult now.
We can get active here.
Push up, push up, push up.
At him, at him.
Can't finish it.
Strange, strange one, strange one.
Got it, got it.
I got you, I got you.
I'm with you, I'm with you.
I'll push up with you.
Did you almost fall down?
Low keyed him here?
Yeah, low keyed.
Where'd he go?
He's invis.
He's so sneaky.
We got door.
They still have Mag ult.
They might be close to our Strange ult here.
Or wait.
I'm low, I'm low.
He is, cause I am.
Go back quick.
Boink.
Missed.
Just chill for a second.
Yeah, I'm not there.
To our left, there is.
There's Adam to our left.
There's four Soul Bond.
Okay, I'm back, I'm back.
Adam to the left again.
We're behind door.
Strange has ult.
He's probably gonna pop it soon.
I'm on, I'm on.
Let's push, let's play it a little.
Up here, up here, up here.
I'm Soul Bonding, I'm Soul Bonding.
I don't have Soul Bond after this.
Got the reset, got the reset.
Strange 1, Strange 1, Strange 1.
Yeah, yeah, I'm with you.
He's Soul Bonding, he's Soul Bonding.
I can ult this if we have enough.
We're even, we're even right now.
We're up, we're up, we're up.
Okay, popping it.
I'm with you, Doki, I'm with you.
I am trying to keep everybody up right now.
I'm keeping you guys alive.
We're up, we're up, we're up, we're up.
Yeah, we're up, we're up.
I'm Soul Bonding you.
I don't mind.
I'm gonna try and see if I can get the kill.
All these fucking Loki clones.
Look at Thor, behind us, look at Thor.
Alright, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Strange 1, Strange 2 left, Strange 2 left, Strange 2 left.
We need like a pick here.
I'm getting shot at, I'm getting shot at.
I'm getting rid of the clones for us.
Alright, look at Thor, look at Thor.
Thor 1, Thor 1, Thor 1, good pick.
Strange 1.
I lost my, I lost my HUD.
What the fuck was that?
That's weird.
But I couldn't see my ult.
Look at the Embers, we're here.
I missed.
I can't see anybody.
Good to know, I'm 1.
Yeah.
Alright, let's go.
I think we might need to swap some.
I don't know if we swap some or we just get ults or something.
I have a portal, I have a portal.
Yeah, let's just portal.
Portal behind them.
Okay.
Portal behind.
Yeah, because we need to get the supports.
The supports are just healing them.
Alright, I'm going to TP.
Get back, Gabe.
Alright, I'm just going to go behind them, right?
Yep, get behind.
We'll do the thing where you put Emo and then I'll...
Okay, you take Emo.
You want me to ult?
No, I'm going to ult.
I'm going to take your ult first.
Okay.
I have the ult.
I got stun, I got stun, I got stun.
I'm still bot, I'm still bot, I'm still bot, I'm still bot.
Don't worry.
I'm trapping in there.
I don't know what that was.
Yeah, we need ult, we need invis ult.
Oh my god, I got pushed away.
Ela's behind us.
I can't...
I'm going back, I'm going back now.
I'm going to rez here.
Oh, they're all over us.
Oh, you guys are so far.
Fuck, that was my bad.
I didn't realize you guys were actually there, there.
I'm going to swap off then.
I think we need more.
Yeah.
Their invis is good, man.
She's fucking me up.
I didn't realize you guys were all the way there.
They were portaling.
I don't know what this is.
But we're here, though.
Behind us?
I shifted.
I'm trying to drop us in the pit.
Hold on Thor, hold on Thor.
No one more?
Oh wait, Thor's caught off.
Sunny, I...
I'm low.
Hold in there, Ela.
I see, I see.
Nice, nice.
Oh, we're fine.
Maybe?
I'm giving up, I'm giving up.
Oh my god.
I blinded the Thor.
Oh, the Thor's behind us here.
I didn't think I was that low.
Thor one.
Did she end?
Nice, nice, nice.
We have...
It's just you healing.
They're gonna buy, they're gonna buy.
Nice, nice, nice.
We only have Shuriken.
You only have Shuriken.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna back up a bit.
I hit.
I'm gonna die.
Oh my god.
That last point was so fucking hard to push into.
We need like a...
I think we just have to use all the ults we can there.
When we used the portal, I tried to ult, but I got stunned.
But I think we should have had Lime ult after that immediately.
Yeah, I didn't know if I should drop mine or if you were able to drop yours.
No, I was not.
Yeah, I got stunned.
For this, do you want more heals or do you want to keep with Adam?
So...
For now, we should keep the Adam.
We shouldn't have a problem with holding Ziphon.
But...
I think if it does get worse, I can swap off and then I can go Hella.
And then Shadow can go Bucky.
Yeah, yeah.
Or I can go Wolverine.
I think that last point, we should have swapped there because it wasn't working.
We were just trying to brute force.
Do either one.
Yeah, we should be proactive with our swaps there if something's not working.
Yeah.
It's fine, let's hold this.
Two!
Stay strong!
They did a little research on the cones.
I mean, to be fair, Coney never swapped off the thing the entire time.
I played a couple of mech games, I think.
No, you were on the thing the entire tournament.
Oh, wait, I wasn't?
Yeah.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one!
We can always swap if you want, Mag, and I can Strange if need be.
They're going to portal up here.
Because you're a little bit more practiced recently, you know?
They're portaling.
Oh, is it inside?
Top.
Yeah.
Strange, oh, no, they healed him.
So we're on the backline?
I got you.
Yeah, Thor's back here.
Come on, Thor.
Four, one.
They're low up there.
In the back.
Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor!
Nice!
Got it.
Still pulling.
Adam here.
Adam is by himself, Adam by himself, Adam by himself, focus on Adam, focus on Adam!
I'm low up here.
Yeah.
They're low up there.
You can clean them up, you can clean them up.
Oh, I got...
This Hela pulled up for me the whole time, I just needed my time.
Yeah, I tried, sorry.
I still bonded us because I'm getting picked by the Hela, too.
Like, everybody's just everywhere.
They're all just surrounding us.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm gonna go down here.
Do we stay with this comp or is it just...
No, we can swap it up.
Yeah, just swap off, yeah.
Do I even try?
I don't know.
No, don't do it.
That's fine.
A little bit of delay, I guess.
I go Hela.
Hela.
Alright, Hela here.
Let me get the buck.
Okay, I'll swap to...
I'll swap to...
I guess I'll swap to Cloak after this for the heals.
Hela?
I'm still bonding to keep Coney alive.
Hela top, Hela top, Hela top.
Yeah, just know we don't have as many heals.
We might have to get another heal in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm going to Cloak after.
I just need to die.
Is that Thor behind us?
Thor, yeah.
That's fine.
You're giving them a lot of space though.
I'm pulling him.
Nice.
I have ult here.
We need to start bucking now.
Just in, just in, I have ult.
Just in, just in.
We don't...
He's got ult.
I have ult behind, I have ult here.
Just in, just in.
Don't...
Don't use any defensive ults.
Yeah.
Alright, good shit.
There is an Adam behind.
On me, on me.
Actually, there's a strange on me.
Right here.
Oh, he's running.
He's off, he's off, he's off.
I'm going to look for a rez.
Just keep inting and then I'll try and get a rez for us.
And then, all at the moment we rez.
On top, on top, on top.
They're trying to do a drop.
They're trying to do a drop down.
Look behind, look behind, look behind.
Ah, the fucking roof.
I tried, I tried ulting but I immediately got Thor ulted as I rezzed.
That's fine.
Yeah, I'm rezzed.
That's fine, I'm going to jump off.
We have one fight here.
I could TP in, hold on.
I actually kept my ult, he killed me before it went off.
I'll save TP.
Can we touch?
Yeah, we can't touch here.
No, we can't touch that.
Alright, this is the last point.
Last point.
Play it back.
On top, on top, Thor's behind us.
He's going to try to flank, he's trying to flank right now.
Tanks, tanks, tanks, tanks.
Don't give him space, tanks, tanks.
Don't give him space.
We just need one person, one to two people.
Strange.
I'm low, I'm low, I'm low.
There's a Hela up top, Hela up top.
Hela one.
Yeah, she's low, she's low.
She's dead.
Yeah, I blinded them, I blinded them.
Nice,
nice, nice.
That's big, that's big.
Fuck that guy.
Help, help, help.
Cony, Cony, Cony, Cony, Cony.
Yep.
Good shit.
That's fine.
Right here.
I blinded them, I blinded all of them, I blinded all of them.
Dora here, low.
I got him.
Good shit.
Oh my god, I missed my ult in there.
It went off, but that's fine.
I don't know.
Okay, Lime, you ult first.
Double invisible.
Lime, you ult first, okay?
Okay.
Good.
I'm going to go up top.
And if you're stunned, like, shout it out and then I'll ult.
Because I'm playing back.
Dora's going for a flank again.
If you get stunned, I will, okay, Lime?
Dora behind us, Dora behind us.
He's low, he's low, he's low.
He's low, he's very low.
I stunned him, I, I...
Uh, I...
Oh, you didn't get stunned, that was my bad.
I thought you got stunned there.
No, I'm sorry.
That was my bad.
We stacked ults, we stacked ults.
Yeah.
Atom almost down.
Got it.
There's a Thor, Thor behind us.
Thor, Thor's behind us, yeah, yeah.
We don't have support ults here, so they're going to have, uh, they have Hela and, uh, Thor ult after.
Nice, good kill, good kill.
I just popped shield for no reason.
I accidentally hit F, sorry.
Uh, we don't have any ults here, but they're going to have, they're going to have Hela and Thor ult.
Yeah.
I'm going to try to combo that shit, watch out.
If we can survive one fight, we'll be able to...
It sounds like Hela.
Shit.
Oh, are you fucking kidding me?
It fucking glitched, what the fuck?
What happened?
We're giving them too much favor, we're giving them too much favor.
It showed that I was on the fucking platform and it dropped me off.
I'm trying to kill it, I'm trying to kill it.
There's no way.
Okay, it's dead, it's dead, it's dead.
Oh my god.
Oh, I got sniped by the fucking Hela.
Oh no.
I got sniped too.
Post ult, post ult.
We have...
Don't tell me you'll lose the fucking point of that.
Oh no.
Are you fucking kidding me?
No fucking shot, dude.
What?
Okay, well...
Can we touch or no?
We can, I think we can.
We have to go, we have to go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
You got it?
Okay.
Coming back.
We have Lion Maul.
They're portal, they portal blocked, they portal blocked.
Nah, I can get out.
He didn't do it right.
I'm trying to get you guys.
Oh my god, bro.
Hella one.
Hella dead.
I have a Thor on me, but I'm just trying to get as close as I can.
Big kill, big kill.
Oh my god.
You can probably kill that.
See my...
Oh, there's a Hela behind, there's a Hela behind us.
No!
Fuck.
I should have popped it before.
Shit.
Yeah.
Are you fucking kidding me?
What do we do against this team?
I already know what to do.
We had a lot of mistakes with like...
Man, I'm so sad.
I don't know what happened there.
We were holding that well.
I don't know what happened.
Gomez jumped off.
Yeah, I know.
I thought I had more space to move, so I went backwards.
I think we definitely need to be more proactive with our swaps.
We were brute-forcing things again, which was our problem in the beginning of the games.
We kept brute-forcing...
We kept brute-forcing characters that we should not be brute-forcing.
Like, we stayed on Bucky for way too long there when we were obviously not going to progress in the first point.
Yeah.
Alright.
I don't even know what bandwagon we should do.
I think I already got it.
I'm ready to start up.
I can tell you guys about it.
I don't know.
Yeah, just be R.
Just R for it.
Also, it didn't help that they just started the game without asking us.
Oh, yeah.
One second.
Do you want to protect this game?
What do you think?
I'm down.
You probably have more experience on Strange because you were learning it.
So you probably play it better than I do right now.
So there's also a world where I can just Mag and you can Strange?
Mm-mm.
Okay.
Yeah, either or.
I'll take Strange duty.
If you're more comfortable on the other end.
The fuck?
Why did they just leave?
I just haven't played Strange in a while.
Or should we swap in Jay of their target band in Coney?
If we swap in Jay, they might try and target Ben.
No, we just save the thing.
Okay.
Save the thing.
Coney pops off.
And if they have the first band thing, then I have Star-Lord.
And then we do triple team up.
That's pretty strong too.
Or we can do Bucky Star-Lord.
Good also.
Nice.
And we got to go to their new lobby.
Okay.
Yeah, just join off me.
Alright, where are you?
Where are you?
There you are.
It says friends only.
Oh no, I only play.
Just join off me.
Yeah.
Okay.
Unlucky.
Oh, crap.
We have an imposter in our team.
There we go.
Dude.
So what are we doing differently this time around?
I think we're going to try and keep the thing.
So we're just going to keep the thing.
They want you to move into our team, Gomez.
Oh, yeah, I'm here.
I'm here.
We are alright, right?
We are ready, right?
I'm ready.
Yeah, okay.
I'm good.
I'm the readies.
Yo, Hella is also just doing whatever the fuck she wants.
Like no one's like walking up to her.
Yeah, I was trying to stop her like in the back, like whenever she goes around back.
But then like, I think that last moment when Gomez died, she just got free reign because I couldn't hold her myself.
Yeah, like none of us are, none of us are challenging her.
Like, and their Hella is their best player.
So at the moment we shut down their Hella, like the team collapses.
Okay.
I think we gave a little too much space too.
Yeah, and that's why I was like, push up, keep pushing up.
Because like every time we said there's someone behind us, an entire team runs to that person.
Yeah, the tanks, the tanks can stay.
Yeah, the tanks stay.
Like when we say someone's behind us, we're just telling the DPS to walk around.
Yeah.
Really quick, do we want, do we want Jay for this or am I staying?
You're staying.
Okay.
So this time we're just going to protect the thing.
Because I thought they would, oh, they're probably going to ban your mag anyway.
Yeah, yeah.
Or they'll ban Star, no they're doing Starlord first ban.
No, for second ban.
Oh yes, yeah.
They're going to, they're going to first ban my Starlord.
Obviously then.
As long as we have, at least if we have the thing, we have a strong core frontline.
Then we still, then we can do whatever the hell we want.
I don't think we ban Luna, just so we can have the Namor option in.
Because I don't think, I think we can force them on the 2-2.
Okay.
I think, I think Shoto's, Shoto's Namor is better.
Right, right Shoto?
Yes, yes.
So, who are we banning first then?
Uh, just keep the same ban line.
Just use...
Get Groot out here.
Get Groot out.
We don't like that thing.
We don't like Groot.
We're going to protect the thing.
They're going to protect Hala, then we protect the thing.
Then we just pull out the, we pull out the fucking Namor if we have to.
They're probably going to ban, they're probably going to ban Magneto.
And I think the best, I think, through how they were playing.
Yeah, and they played really well.
They kind of rely on the Invis.
You want to ban the Invis?
Because they pocket the Hala.
Yeah, the Invis was fucking me up when I was trained.
Get Invis out.
What am I playing then?
You'll be playing...
Atom?
Atom, yeah.
Okay, we'll do Atom Luna then.
If they ban, let's say ban Luna.
They want to pocket their Hala, which is annoying.
So something like this?
Or I could do Loki, I guess, right?
Yeah, either one.
Loki or Namor?
Yeah, you can do either one.
So now you have the option to swap between the two.
Let's start with Namor first.
Yeah, I agree.
Oh, attack again?
Help her be scanned a lot.
Yeah, we are.
I also think the Suu might have been fucking you up because you were strange and you didn't have the invulnerability, the displacement immunity.
That's something I have to worry about, usually.
So Hala shouldn't have that much free roam anymore?
Yeah, because if I have squids, it should be fine.
But he might play Namor too, right?
Yeah, he's a Namor main, so...
And at the moment, I think Bucky is better than Hala, so I can just play the Hala or the Bucky.
They're way better.
Oh, do you hear that?
He whoops my back.
It's a habit, that's all.
It's a nervous button mash.
I understand it.
Hala one.
Hala dead.
I'm gonna die though.
This is a good trade though.
Yeah, we're pushing it.
Does Hala get revived off that or is that just... No.
No, no, no.
It's only Hala that can revive others.
Okay, okay, okay.
Thor on me.
I froze Thor.
Don't ult her in front of him.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll keep forward.
Thor half.
I'm gonna try to go around them.
Hala on the left.
Hala one.
Hala still one.
Oh, she's low.
Got her.
Damn!
I don't know.
Their Hala is just trying to get plays because all they can do is get picked and then their team collapse on us.
Yeah, I'm pushing up right now.
I'm pushing up right now.
Oh, this big guy is big.
Adam low.
I'm on them.
I'm with you.
Thor on me.
Turn around.
Someone turn around.
Thor one.
Got Thor.
Got it.
Oh my god, I got destroyed by... Dude, their Adam just...
Adam.
Adam one.
Adam low.
Nice, nice.
Good job.
101.
We're up one.
We won't take space.
We're up two.
Oh my god!
Come on, push up.
No way!
Those are nasty shots.
I'll push up.
No, get over here.
Get your ass here, Hella.
Hold on.
I'm looking.
I'm looking, dude.
They have all their ults.
They haven't used anything.
So, they have Punisher on.
Oh, they did.
Punisher.
That's fine.
We get this spot.
This is like a free point.
I have Whale.
Save your Whale for me.
Save your Whale with my ult.
Nope.
I'm just laying down.
Punisher down.
Nice kill.
They're low.
They're all low.
We should push up.
Push up with that.
You're up two.
Strange half.
Oh, I got Strange.
I got Strange.
She's running.
Back up a little bit.
Don't play so frontline.
Frozen.
Good shit.
Oh, they wasted their ults.
Dude, that's so good.
That's so good.
I might just snowball with an ult.
I'll push up.
Coming with you.
He destroyed by us.
Unlucky.
No, no, no.
No rez.
Don't rez.
We don't need that.
I have Claw Bolt, but I'm waiting.
I'm reloading.
He's looking for us.
Okay, nevermind.
Strange has one.
We're up one.
Okay, we're even.
We're even.
You guys need to watch out.
You guys need to walk up.
We're down one.
Heal Jull.
I need heal.
Heal me.
Heal me up.
Yeah, nice thing.
Heal Jull.
Push.
Push this.
There's no reason not to.
Lime, just push the cart.
Push the cart, Lime.
Yep.
Good shit.
I don't know what to do.
Who's messaging you?
My niece.
Hold on.
They're pushing.
They're pushing Gomez.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Strange on top.
He's going to look for auto-moto on top.
Behind us.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm hit.
That's fine.
You're fine.
Nice.
Push up.
Okay.
Rez this.
Lime, rez this.
Yeah.
Get all of us in here.
I'm going to look for a pull.
It's fine.
I got rez.
Hold their namor.
I got no heals.
I'm on.
Holding this.
We're down.
Nice.
Oh, I got the... Bro, I zipped him.
I zipped him.
Nice.
Pump this guy.
I saw it.
Nice.
Good chase.
God.
Good.
We got a lot of time.
Yeah.
See?
Look at that.
Easy.
It's so easy now.
Look at that.
That was super duper easy.
Real good rally.
Really good.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
Yeah, you guys better keep banning my Star Lord.
Let me play the more broken character.
Well, like, times three.
I fucking hate this character.
I think they might start off with Namor here.
Now that...
That's fine.
Yeah.
I'm surprised they didn't have Namor off the rip to, like, deal with, you know...
I think they... I mean, it worked last game for them.
Like, their current... the last lineup.
So they're like, oh, this is the lineup that will disrupt them.
Okay, my niece is still messaging me.
They did what we did.
They were trying to brute force.
Yeah, yeah.
That's why, like, I'm saying we have to be proactive with swaps.
Coney, she's five.
The way you were presenting it, I thought, like, some horrible aversion.
Yeah, I was like, my niece is messaging me.
Like, I'm at work.
She's stuck under the cupboard or something.
Like, her house is collapsed on her.
No, she messaged me here and there and she gets mad if I switch back.
What's your favorite spots for Namor here?
I don't know.
You can hold in the top right room.
You can flank onto that bridge right there.
But that's only if you have opportunities to.
You can play on this side, too.
I think that's a little bit too close.
I'm just holding them back.
This door's low.
Yeah, nice.
Good job.
Strange jumped up.
They jumped up.
Strange jumped up here.
I've got no heals left.
It's fine.
I'm keeping everybody up as much as I can.
I'm dropping down.
Yeah, me too.
Alright, so you're supposed to drop down.
Oh, I got helled.
So they're doing secure now.
Oh, gosh.
We can't see you.
I know.
I'm forced to go.
I'm forced to go and he's body blocking me.
We either die or back up.
You guys can die.
Just die.
Yeah, just die.
Just die again.
Die so we get another touch.
Nice.
Just watch out for the hella.
Do we want TP or no?
Uh, no.
No, no, no.
We all make it.
Just wait until all of us are here.
I'll put it on Kona.
I'm putting a snowflake on Kona.
We have time to rush.
I think we can IE.
Uh, Shoto got picked.
I got picked so far.
They lost one, too.
It's fine.
They're rezzing.
Oh, the Namoor.
Namoor's behind us.
Namoor's here, right?
Namoor's here.
I'm waiting.
I have Claw waiting.
There's a Namoor.
That's one.
Namoor one.
We're swirled.
Oh, no, we don't.
Only rez.
Yeah, only rez.
You might have to use it.
I'm down.
No, don't use it.
Oh, don't use it.
Oh, wait, actually, use this, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God, I see you.
Use it.
Oh, they got point.
They got point.
At least we're all here.
Except for Kona.
Oh, yeah, by the way, I think we swap the Adam just for defense since we need to use it for sustain.
Yeah, okay.
They have triple support.
Yeah.
You want Mantis?
No, no, no.
Or Cloak and Dagger.
Cloak or Dagger.
Either one.
Thorbine!
I don't have freeze.
Oh, we're giving a lot of space.
Yeah, yeah, we gotta push up.
We gotta push up a bit.
I'm back.
Strange Job I.
Yeah, Strange Job I.
We're giving a lot of space again.
Yeah, we're gonna have to.
Help for Kona.
Help Kona.
Kona's by himself.
Oh, my God.
It's alright, Kona.
You can back up.
We can give space, Kona.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
They're just looking for me in here.
Okay, fine.
That's okay.
You're still alive.
Nice.
Good heal.
Oh, my God.
When I die, I'll switch.
I'm ulting this.
Oh, I'm dead.
Hello, one.
Three, two, one.
Switching.
Nice.
They used support.
He's one.
Nice.
Fuck me.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm trying to get on.
I'm on it, but yeah.
No.
It's tough.
I know.
Alright.
Play around corners.
Don't do anything rushed.
We just hold space.
We don't have to go for plays.
Okay.
I'm being chased by Thor.
Never mind.
The hell is fueling it right now?
We just play around where his vision is.
Poke him out.
We don't have to do anything.
We just ult rotate.
Also, someone's top right.
It's okay if I do Mantis.
I'm more comfortable on him.
Our heals will be lacking.
Oh, yeah.
We can't.
We have to have sustainability.
Bro, this Thor keeps trying to push onto me.
Yeah.
Drop down again.
Heal me.
I'm trying.
Thank you.
I need heals here.
I need heals.
We lost.
Yeah.
We lost both supports.
We have no supports.
I'm coming back right now and I'll have ult soon.
I have ult here.
We can burn that.
I'm burning that.
I'm using this for Coney.
They killed both of us.
Yeah, they killed both of us shooting at them.
I'm putting up a TP on the right side.
Is that even worth it?
Or do I just walk?
I can just walk.
Walk.
Two.
One.
Dude, this hell is fucking hard.
Fucking me up, man.
Yeah, I can't even stay alive.
I didn't even ult.
I tried to ult, but...
Fuck.
I don't know if we should stay Bucky here.
It's fun doing it here.
What do you want me on, though?
I don't know.
I just...
Bro, Hella has too much space.
We can go Hella.
We can do it back, but...
Bucky's better.
Hella's just getting a pick, and then they snowball us.
I don't play Hella, though.
I fucking hate Hella.
Like, the Hella literally is...
The Hella Neymar flanks us, and we have nothing to do about it.
Do you want a cheese?
Do you want a cheese a little bit?
So, you can hold in the inside room with this comp.
Please run a triple support, Relyne.
Okay.
I'll tell you guys what to do.
I'll tell you guys.
Oh, do you want me back?
Do you want me back on Cloak and Dagger?
Because we're on defense.
Uh, no, no.
We have Loki.
No, I'm on Loki now.
Wait, okay, we'll do Luna.
I keep this, right?
We'll stay Luna here.
We need triple support.
We hold in the inside room for the entirety, okay?
I'm gonna show you which room.
Give a brief exclamation.
So, we're gonna hold in this room, okay?
Okay.
If they try to take off angles on the side, we call it out.
Like, if someone's trying to go around, or if someone's above.
They will take a lot of angles on us, but with our comp, we can hold inside for a very long time.
Do not go past this corner, okay?
Don't leave this door.
Got it.
Yeah.
Well, still to do it to contest, because you can.
Just try not to...
I hear you.
Yeah.
Usually we have this with Magneto, but they banned it, so...
Oh, hold them.
Hold them in.
Nice.
Moira's up on the top left.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
We stay here.
We get the contest here.
We just bunker.
We just bunker here.
I'm just standing here to contest.
Just get back.
Just be careful of the flank.
Someone has to be careful of the flankers.
We should... None of us should be able to die here.
Look at Thor.
Frozen.
Nice.
They got... Hello, Flanky.
Hello, Flanky.
Behind.
It's fine.
I got Hela.
Keep contesting.
I'm back on the point.
We let it pass.
Oh my god.
I can't sustain there.
Yeah, we let it pass.
Good kill.
Just die if you can.
Die if you can if you're still fighting.
No.
No, huge support ult advantage.
Me and Coney just call it.
We can combo with our ults.
Or...
Sherine, copy me.
Yeah.
Ults went close.
They're pushing up.
Ults close.
Is it Thor?
Hela's right there.
I'm gonna ult on first, okay?
I pulled the ult.
Okay.
I'm coming.
I'm here.
I'm healing.
I'm just gonna heal.
We gotta play around Coney.
I gotta play around Coney.
I'm back up.
We're down all our supports.
Do I actually have... I have Hella.
But Hella is so fucking... I hate it.
I'll do it.
You can go to Bucky now.
Or...
I think you might...
I definitely need to warm up after this.
They're pushing me.
We got a pick, so we should push up here.
We're up one.
I'm pushing up.
I have ult.
Just use things.
You can.
Nice, nice, nice.
I got him.
What up?
Oh, okay.
Get the Luna, Luna, Luna.
Huge ult.
Good shit.
Cloak down.
Hella down.
Good shit.
Good ult.
Great ult.
Yeah, I think Hella was a good swap.
You diffed your Hella.
You diffed your Hella and you diffed your other DPS.
Wow.
Unlucky.
Lucky, lucky.
Run the ship.
Why not?
Actually, we ban the Sue.
Yeah.
Usually the right support line would be Loki Luna.
That's gonna be tough.
Even if we just first ban Hella next game, just leave Groot.
Nope.
Do you want me on Adam or something else?
I think for now, we do need a second support ult.
Should I just go Loki then?
That's if you want.
We could run... I could put Lime on Luna and I could run Loki.
But it is a bit dangerous.
I don't know.
I think you're a much stronger Luna than I am.
Yeah, it's a bit dangerous.
It's up to you, Shota.
You can do a Loki, you can do a Namor here.
You have to get picks though.
Okay, I'll do it.
Okay, then you can run Adam.
Okay, go back to Adam.
I'm gonna drop the dopest album anytime mine has ever hurt.
On top?
Anymore?
Yeah, I'm...
Alright, yep.
No bubble.
I'm gonna do what I'm trying.
You have to put your bubble up.
I go to someone.
They're gonna look for me, by the way.
What's up top, Bianna?
I'm getting poked.
Yeah, I'm getting beaten up by the Lord up here.
Lord is frozen.
Yeah, door through.
We can't kill you guys, watch out.
Okay, now we can.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
Namor's still up here.
I need to take off angles.
Hell is walking up.
Namor is getting free picks.
Namor is getting...
Go, go.
Yeah, go Namor.
Okay.
I almost have ult though.
It's fine, it's fine.
We need to swap.
We can't...
We need to be proactive with swaps.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm going.
I'm on Namor now.
There's our helicant.
Namor, I'm on, I'm on.
I'm behind.
I can't see.
I'm healing our tanks.
Right here, right here.
On top, on top.
Behind us.
Any heal behind us.
Oh, they doubled?
They doubled, yeah.
They doubled, that's perfect.
I need a snowflake behind me.
I'm trying to keep coney up right now.
No worries.
If you peek me, I can give you a snowflake.
Are you peeking me right now?
I'm here.
Okay, I got you.
Hello, one.
He's going to buy.
I got a big pick.
We got two picks.
Push up, push up, push up.
Push up, push up.
We got two picks.
Get the Namor that's coming from the sky.
I got Namor.
I'm dead.
Get the Thor, get the Thor if you can.
Get the Thor.
Dash in one, dash up.
Yep, Thor's dead.
I'm on a point.
Oh no, he's not, he's not.
I'm going to keep the snowflake on Gomez.
Coming back.
I'm going to push cart, I'm going to push cart.
You're going to have one more, you might have a contest here.
I think he has Agamotto though.
I ult Agamotto, I ult Agamotto.
They're going to use everything for the last push.
Yep.
Off angle.
Still on off angle.
Namor no bubble, Namor no bubble.
Namor one.
Careful on top, Agamotto.
Oh god, what?
I pressed Q.
What?
Okay, it's fine.
Still linked it.
Yeah, that's good, still linked.
That was huge.
Oh my god.
Huge Agamotto, huge Agamotto.
Nice, good shit, good shit.
Oh my god.
Fuck this Thor.
He's the fucking Sorcerer.
Oh my god.
He's the Sorcerer of the big wave.
The Sorcerer Supreme.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, dude.
My fucking...
Dude.
Thank god you still linked us live.
My Q went, the aura went off.
But like, the ping, because I have a higher ping, so the ping didn't catch up with it.
I was like, are you fucking serious?
I saw that you weren't thinking, I was like, okay, solve on time.
The master of the mystic arts.
Holy shit, man.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Can I go home?
My game is super chugging, I'm gonna restart my game real quick.
Okay, okay.
So I don't die there.
Dude, that strange ult was unbelievable, good shit.
Oh, thanks.
Yeah, good job.
That was Ash, that was so fucking clutch.
Training paid off.
It did.
This is all...
So this is back to three.
Yeah, this is three, so we have one more game.
Yeah, we should keep... your strange is way better than mine.
Like, we should just keep you on that or mag if we get it.
And I'll just stay mag or thing.
I'm done.
Do we keep the ban line, or...
Yeah, we keep the ban line.
Okay.
I don't think we need to change it up at all.
Banning Sue, sorry?
Uh, yeah.
Banning Sue so Battle can have a free ult.
Super reliant on the shields.
Yeah, I'm gonna keep the snowflake on you then, Gomez, when you're on Hella.
I think the Hella swap was a good call there.
It was.
Ah, but I don't like...
Yeah, Mr. Fucking Stubborn Ass.
I'm not good at it, though.
I'm not good at it.
Me, passively aggressive, being like, maybe Bucky's not the...
I just don't... I don't like the... I don't like to play Hella.
That's always Rye that's playing it.
I want to blame it on other stuff, but it's mainly my sense.
My sense is way too high to be playing Hella.
Oh my god, I'm... Guys, I'm yelling at myself.
I am... I'm fucking... I'm making so many mistakes.
I'm so nervous.
Oh, I'm making a lot of mistakes.
I can't believe that straight... Like, my fucking aura went off, too, and like, I was so surprised.
I was like...
I react... I felt like I reacted perfectly, too.
Yeah.
I was like, why did... Why did it... That's strange.
I was like, what?
I was so surprised.
I was like, why didn't my Q go off?
The aura... The... It gave me the... It gave me the, like, the visuals for it.
Alright.
I think I just got pinged if tired there, because, like, it gave me the visual.
Because I always... I always, like, react to that shit.
Wait, what?
I just joined it.
I don't think he invited me.
I'm going to invite you guys.
Hold on.
Thank you.
So, it's one more game.
You have to move me.
I can't move.
Weird.
Yeah.
You have to move me.
I can't move it.
Yeah, I can't move myself.
Okay.
It's Domination.
I'll Groot on this map.
Yeah, we definitely need to ban him.
Yeah, Groot is always gone here.
Yeah.
We still want Thing here, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And...
I think in Domination, flankers are, like, much more...
Yeah, so that... I'll just put the snowflake on Gomez to deal with the flankers.
Yep.
Because of that...
So, they want Namor here, but I don't know if Hela is, like, ideal in this situation.
But, I mean, it's still scary, but...
Let's see what they play.
If they play Hela...
It's Hela.
Okay.
If they play Hela, then we should...
We're playing a different meta at the moment.
So, the meta that's also something that's played a shit ton is the Hela-Namor.
And you just have, like, an off-angle battle all the time.
So, usually, you would be, kind of, one-shotting them.
I'd be marking their Hela and marking whatever tank is in the front line.
Then, we have our front line, who's basically unkillable.
Since Coney takes zero damage on the thing.
Then, you have Battle doing his playmaker stuff in the mid-fights.
Because, usually, we'd be running...
Normal teams would be running Luna and Loki.
But, I'm glad we picked up the Adam-Luna.
Because that works well, too.
That works wonders.
The Thor is not that difficult to counter, too.
Because I literally just freeze him every time I see him.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
He's not...
He's not that oppressive for us.
It's literally just the Hela.
That's fucking us up at the moment.
Okay, we're ready.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Ready, yep.
Yep.
Good to go.
Okay.
So, we still keep things safe and just take the Strange, right?
Yep.
If they don't ban my Star-Lord, then yippee.
They don't ban the Star-Lord.
I see a world where they try and ban both of Battle's tanks or something like that.
But, I don't know if that's a free thing.
I was just thinking about that.
Yeah.
If they do...
Wait, what do you play?
Groot is his next best one.
And we're banning Groot.
Oh, shit.
If we do that, we can put Battle on a support.
Oh, God.
And then we run just one, one, two, three.
We'll see how it goes.
I think so, a tank, two DPS, three support.
If that happens, because I think I believe in your Star-Lord.
Yeah.
As long as we heavy pocket Gomez, if he's on Star-Lord, then it'll be fine.
Because his Star-Lord can just destroy the DPS.
Yep.
Fun.
And they're getting rid of their own Strange and Mag too, so they won't have a Strange.
Yeah, so I don't think they would do that.
Yeah.
So, do you still, do we want to try and do triple tank, triple support?
Or are we going for damage still?
Like me on Amor and Gomez on Bucky?
Probably keep the same line right now.
If you want.
I mean, we can try banning out Hala if you want.
You want to try that?
Not if it lets Groot through.
Just ban Groot, ban Groot.
Yeah, I'm banning Groot.
Banning Groot.
Groot is much more oppressive to our tanks than Hala.
Hala is oppressive to our support line.
Yeah, the thing is I'd rather deal with that because Groot separating our healing is just annoying as fuck.
Yep.
And then protect the, yeah, they're running Hala, so you just try to Hala diff them.
Protect the thing.
You know, I could run Wolf.
Could, but it's going to be more difficult.
Yeah, it's not going to make things more difficult.
It's not going to make it more difficult, unless you think it's a high-risk, high-reward.
It is a high-risk, high-reward.
Oh, no, they're going to run Thor, never mind.
Banning Sue.
Yeah, banning Sue.
Because if they run...
They're running Thor, Loki, Hala for the rez.
Yep.
Oh my gosh, but oh, we got...
Even after that?
Fuck, man.
I'm not judging.
At the game-winning fucking eye, they still want to get rid of Mag instead.
Just Coney, you do too much on things.
That's the thing.
Okay.
I don't know, after that Eye of Agamotto last game, that's...
I'd be banning Strange.
Yeah, but you may have got shit ton of space.
You existing is just crazy.
Yeah.
Metal flew up, and then did the thing.
I did fly up.
Woosh!
Oh, you did the fly thing.
You fly up and they ignore you?
Yeah, remember the first game when you just walk up to them?
I remember.
Just casually scroll up.
Hello.
Yeah, and then...
I'm on your team now.
Yeah, now you fly up.
Look at that.
Character building.
Okay, so Coney, you don't have the snowflake, okay?
So...
I'm putting the snowflake on Gomez.
The moment Gomez kill flankers, or kill their DPS, I'll swap the snowflake back to you.
Okay.
Are you all ready?
You all good?
Yeah.
I'm good, I'm good.
I'm frazzled.
They portal immediately.
Portal up.
High ground.
Don't take left side.
Take all the space on the right.
That's a bad TP.
I can't really do anything with this.
Left side.
Hello, left side.
Hello.
Hello there.
Hello and Namor.
We need a couple of points.
Yeah, I'm on the point right now.
Hello in the center.
He's on the left side too.
They're slowly getting on point.
Yeah, Namor low.
Namor's low.
Oh.
Alright, they pop shift.
Okay.
Waiting for you to get the deal.
Okay, they're spread out.
Oh, oh.
We both burrowed.
No one's in here.
What the fuck?
They're low.
Strange low.
Can't finish it though.
Don't want to die.
Okay.
Namor's low in front of me.
Yeah.
Strange is so low.
Oh no, they're all in there.
Okay.
Yeah, they're all like bunched up in there.
Yeah, it's weird.
They're like in the back though.
This is such a weird position to play.
Oh, they're going to push me.
Yeah, I need help.
I need help on the right.
On right, on right, on right, on right.
I got you.
I'm with you, I'm with you.
All doors are on here too.
Guys, point, point, point, point, point.
You're all, you're all getting on point.
You're all getting on point.
I'm on point, I'm on point, I'm on point.
But I need heals.
Strange.
Okay.
Strange one.
All dead.
That sucks.
I got all here.
Fight on point if you have to.
Yeah, if I say I need help, just support support me.
I have ult for this.
Three, two, one.
Nice.
Nice, good stall, good stall.
Keep stalling, keep stalling.
Just keep stalling, just keep stalling.
Yeah, just keep stalling.
They found me, they found me.
No, it's fine though, it's fine.
Oh my god, bro.
I tried to kill.
Yeah, he was following you the whole time.
Yeah.
Alright.
It's fine, 80%.
Can you portal on?
Can you portal our side?
Yeah, we can portal, portal, portal.
Yeah, yeah.
Same place they did?
Yup.
Yeah, high ground, high ground.
I don't know how much I'm doing, should I switch?
That's fine, keep your, keep your slow bond.
Okay.
They should have cloak ult here.
Or like, low key ult.
Watch our high, watch our high, watch our high.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
He's dead.
Good shit.
Going down, capping.
Neymar down here, Hurt.
I have to solo him.
Uh, Neymar.
I didn't see him.
Neymar dead, Neymar dead.
You only have, you only have low, uh, Adamo.
I got low key, low key dead, low key dead.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Huge, huge pit.
I did not heal the humanity, hello.
Yeah, we got point, we got point.
Pushing up on the right, chasing.
Just get point, save point.
We're good.
Going back.
Nice, good job.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah!
Oh, nice, good pick, good pick, yeah.
Oh my god, we did really well there with the retake.
Good job.
Nice, nice.
Just build ult charge.
I don't know if they're gonna touch, yeah.
They can't.
They can't, they can't.
I don't think they can.
No.
Good shit!
Nice, nice, nice.
Good shit, good shit.
Okay, we can't be as aggressive with this next one.
I think we, because we don't have anything close to an ult right now.
Yeah, they used, they used, they used strange, hella.
Did they use Neymar ult?
Yes, I used Neymar ult to kill Loki.
So they'll still, so they'll have Loki ult and Thor ult then.
Did they just use Loki ult at the end and he died?
Did they?
Yeah, they did.
They don't, they don't have Loki ult.
Okay, so the only ult they'll have is Thor and Cloak.
So they have Thor and Cloak, cool, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, so.
Thor's gonna, Thor's gonna be aggressive trying to get our backline.
Yeah, yeah.
So guys, when, when Gomez says help me, I'll, the supports will turn around.
Tanks just keep fighting.
Okay, I'll, I'll stay forward.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, we left point too many times for that.
It's fine, it's fine.
I think most of the callouts will be for the supports, like tanks just focus on, you know.
Yeah, tanks.
If we call for like, we'll call for your help for tanks if needed.
But if supports are calling for help, it's mostly for DPS to turn around.
Yeah.
Like, I'll have his back and so will the supports.
Okay, that's fine, that's fine.
They're high ground.
They're left, left.
Ooh.
This is a bad, this is a weird spot.
I think left, probably.
They're more dropped.
We can't, let's push, let's push.
Left.
Yeah, left.
They're more one.
I'm gonna be fine, but I'll be...
Oh, Neymar could die, Neymar could die.
Got it.
Yeah, Neymar dead, Neymar dead.
You guys can play around Coney's ult, play around Coney's ult.
They're low, they're low.
Oh, I got it.
Huge, huge, huge.
We have, we have...
Oh my god, we lost people, yeah.
Yeah.
I got focused by the Hella.
Wait, that's their only support ult.
That's their only support ult.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so we're fine.
They don't have support ult, they don't have support ult, but we don't have any ults to counter it.
You okay?
No, you're not.
Yeah.
No, he was trying to stagger me, but I have my rez, so I'm just gonna come over here.
Oh, okay.
They have Psylocke, Psylocke.
They have Psylocke.
I can't...
It's a weird spot.
Yeah, they have Psylocke.
Got you, I got you.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Yes, that's a pick.
Alright, pushing up.
What the fuck?
Guys, guys, two picks, two picks, two picks.
Go, go, go, go.
Push up, push up.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Got you, I got you, I got you.
Thank you.
Sorry, I tried to even have a line of sight.
Nice, nice, nice.
They're getting nervous.
Yeah, they are.
That Psylocke was fumbling against me.
I don't know what that was.
They still don't have, uh, what's it called?
Strange Portal 2, so they gotta fight for this.
Nice.
Make them walk in, make them walk in.
Because I can't do anything at this rate.
Oh, I can get Thor here.
Oh my god, he's so low.
Psylocke, Psylocke, Psylocke.
Got you, got you, got you.
Nice.
They're fucking up, they're fucking up so hard right now.
I have ult, I have ult.
We can combo, we can combo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll let you know.
I'll let you keep it, keep it for the combo.
Watch left.
I'll try and hold, I'll hold high ground.
Or try to hold high ground here.
Come on.
I need help on left.
Psylocke on right.
Psylocke here.
Oh, got her, got her, got her.
She's dead, she's dead.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Psylocke is on me, Psylocke is on me.
I need heal.
I can't, I couldn't get to you.
That's fine, that's fine.
Nice.
You guys are doing well, you guys are doing so well.
Good hold, good hold.
Alright, people on left here.
We need to push them out.
Yup.
Alright.
I'm with you.
I'm walking back.
Just know, you don't have me.
You guys are shooting from there.
He can't move.
They're down one support, down one support right now.
Let it go, let it go, let it go.
Alright, good shit.
I'm sure you're fine.
I have a Snowblade on me.
We have almost every ult.
We have every ult here.
There's no reason to lose this.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm backing up.
I'm backing up too.
I'm using it.
Let me call for it.
I'm stuck.
Oh, I got, I got, there's Psylocke.
Psylocke.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting here.
I'm ulting.
Doesn't matter.
Yeah, we got it.
We got it.
We got it, we got it, we got it.
Good shit.
Nice.
Can't move.
Yeah.
Oh my god, we did it.
Bro, why did they Psylocke into Neymar?
They got killed by my squids every single time.
Okay, battle.
Game winning kill.
Alright, battle, battle.
Last kill on you from you.
Good shit.
We figured it out.
We figured them out.
I barely healed them.
He kept us alive.
So, when I died, I was like, he kept them alive.
Hell yeah.
I fucking suck at Hella and I still did that.
It's okay.
Oh my god, to be fair, you did more healing than your Loki.
Like, that's actually impressive for...
Wait, what the fuck was their Loki doing?
Yeah, you did more healing than their fucking Loki.
That's pretty impressive.
Maybe they just weren't good at domination maps either.
I don't know.
Oh, that was...
Guys, that was a little too nerve-wracking.
We need to do that for the finals, not for this one.
I think we saved...
I think...
We don't need to save Mag anymore.
Like, if we were saving Mag for battle, but I think he's...
Yeah, I think battle...
Yeah, battle.
Battle, you've, like, improved so much on Strange.
Am I ready?
You're so ready.
You're graduated.
You're no longer a one-trick.
You're no longer a one-trick battle!
Battle, you've graduated from one-trick.
You have several tricks.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
You're now a two-trick.
It's perfect.
Isn't that great?
I think, like, if the dog's happy.
Yeah, my dog's so happy now.
And he's also like, feed me, but it's too early to feed him.
It's way too early, but he knows I'm awake.
I love that the first game, we just struggled, but then, like, after that, we just, you know, completely, like, readjusted and did a lot better.
That was still good.
That second game was kind of scary, too.
It was.
It was scary.
Dude, no, you hit the game-winning ults.
Yeah, the game-winning ults.
Yeah, and then, like, my fucking ult didn't go off during the Strange ult, too, and I was like, oh no.
I was so scared.
Yeah, I was freaking out.
I was like, oh no.
I just soul-bonded and started spamming everything on you.
I was like, live, Poki, live!
Oh, you did it.
I think, like...
When...
Yeah?
No, I was gonna say, when we all died on the last map on the first point, the Hella came chasing me down and I killed her before Strange got me.
That was my favorite part.
Nice.
I'm gonna look at the challenge.
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna...
Oh, every other team got 2-0'd.
We were the only team that was, like, 2-1.
Oh, wait, no, actually.
Wait, Mace's team is also... I think Mace's team is... not struggling, but they haven't posted their score yet.
That's interesting.
We're gonna be facing...
Yeah, I'm watching it, too.
Gomez, we're facing the team... the omnomnom team.
The one that we watch.
Omnomnom.
The one that, like...
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll be honest, I don't remember.
Okay, so it's the one with the... I wrote stuff down for us, just in case.
Oh my god, where is... where are the notes that I wrote?
Oh my god, where is it?
That's the Magic team.
Oh, the Dive team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, the Dive team.
Apparently a team got removed from the bracket, like, in our... or something.
I don't know what happened.
Wait, which team?
Which team got removed?
Someone's cheating.
In our bracket?
Oh, something... like, check the channel, the top 12.
I think they explained why.
Wait, what?
Where did they explain it?
I think they probably got disqualified or something.
Probably a disqualification.
I'm not sure.
Inappropriate comments that were made by people in the event.
A bunch of terrible teammates.
Wow.
I mean, the name... I guess the name fit the...
Yeah, I think the name fit the whole criteria.
That's the name of the team?
Wait, that was... what?
Wait, they self-reported.
What?
Maybe someone didn't approve of what was being said, and they were like, I'm gonna gather this shit.
Bro, that's... that's... that's scary.
The team removed a bunch of terrible teammates due to a document that they themselves released publicly that contained inappropriate comments that were made by people in the event.
What?
Oh my god.
Is this some VTuber drama stuff?
I don't know what this is.
I don't know.
I don't know either.
That's crazy.
The self-report was crazy.
Yeah.
What's the bracket?
Oh, is Mace's team the only one that's like...
Well, we're fighting Team OmNomNom next, so...
Did we make the lobby, or is someone casting it?
I think they will ping us.
Are we behind on the schedule, or are we ahead?
No, we're good.
Okay.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Can I stand up or something?
Yeah.
So, are you asking for mission to stand up?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dude, why don't you stand up for yourself?
Yeah, I was like, why are you asking...
We're not like, why are we in, like, school right now?
Teacher, can I please stand up?
Excuse me, Miss Doki, can I leave?
I'm leaving.
Oh, so funny.
I'm gonna use the bathroom, too.
I'll be right back.
Same, be right back.
You know what?
Hold on.
I just thought about something.
Can't we just ban Venom?
That just makes Magic really bad.
Against the next team.
Yeah, because that helps.
Because Venom and Magic together is just, like, annoying as hell.
It's terrible to deal with.
They're obviously gonna first ban my Starlight, and then we just save Hela.
Or no, we save Namor.
No, wait, they're just gonna ban Luna.
Yeah, they ban Luna there.
I mean, it's fine.
I think we can probably...
I do like the Venom ban, though, because it limits a lot of their dive stuff.
Because he's the one that initiates the dive.
Hold on.
Wait, I have my teammate that's watching.
Hogs, are you still here?
Are you here, Hogs?
Where's Hogs?
Hold on, let me go ask him.
I think Hogs was in here before, too.
I don't know where he is.
I'm gonna steal him to do some stuff.
I'm gonna join... I'll be right back.
I'm gonna join VC with him and let him help me with this stuff.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, where is he?
Alright, I'll be back.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
Oh, Hogs.
Oh, are they discussing strats?
Yeah, against the team that we'll fight.
Oh, yeah.
It's fine, he's like a diver team.
I don't remember if they... I don't remember if they fucking run what their tank lineup was.
I wrote stuff down, so I'll look up what I wrote.
Let's see.
Okay, they protect Strange.
They have a Strange.
These are the characters they protect.
They protect Strange, Black Panther, Magic, and Bucky.
And their best player is a Magic player.
They don't have a Venom.
They don't play Venom.
They don't play Venom?
No, I remember they don't play Venom.
I can watch their VODs right now.
I don't remember ever seeing them play Venom.
Okay.
Yeah, because they don't.
They play Thor with their Magic.
Because their best tank player is a Strange one trick.
So, yeah, I should message.
If Gomez is talking to Hogswell, message.
They don't have a Venom player.
They have Strange one trick.
And...
Okay.
Yeah.
And their support lineup is just Cloak and Sue.
Or Luna.
It's either Luna, Cloak, or Cloak and Sue.
Okay.
No Loki.
They don't have a player that plays Loki.
Loki is not their strongest support.
Cloak and Sue, alright.
But, yeah, let me see what else I wrote.
So, I think we should ban Magic.
Just because their best player.
Their best player, if Magic is open, they always pick Magic.
Then what do they pick after if Magic is banned?
If Magic is banned, they protect either Black Panther or Strange.
Okay.
And I rather just not have a Magic player.
Yeah.
And, yeah, so...
Thank you.
I'm checking to see if they do ever play Venom.
But from what I remember, when I was going through the list, I've never seen them play...
They play Penny.
Their other tank, that's not, like, mostly a Strange...
Like, their Strange might get flexed to Mag.
But their other tank is literally, like, whatever the fuck they play.
But I've only seen them play Thor, Mag, and Penny.
So...
Yeah, no Venom.
Oh, actually, wait.
Oh, the one time they played... Wait.
No, never mind.
They swapped off Venom.
Oh, I think they, like...
Oh, they swapped off.
Yeah, they played... No, they were just...
They were like, what if I play Venom?
And they swapped off.
So, yeah, no Venom players.
I'm looking through everything else.
I'm pretty sure, like, a lot of teams are gonna analyze our... the match that we just had.
Because they'll be like, how did that team took, like, you know, took a point off of them?
Honestly, I blame first game of the day type of thing.
Honestly, yeah, no, I was making a lot of mistakes.
I was not warm.
I was definitely not warm.
No, me too.
I think many of us were.
No.
The practice room is not quite enough.
Definitely.
I mean...
I don't even know.
Is our game casted or not?
Because do we have to wait?
I guess we're waiting for...
Are we waiting for, like...
I think we're waiting for everyone to finish or some shit.
I'm not sure.
Wait, everybody's playing different maps.
I thought everyone would play the same map.
Yeah, because, like, Maze's team is playing on...
In the...
What map is this called?
Spider Island.
Oh, is he on round two already?
I don't know.
I don't know if this is round two or three.
No, because we never played this map, though.
That's the thing.
I thought, like, they would...
Everybody would be playing the same map.
That's fucking weird.
I'm so lost.
Oh, wait.
I thought...
Unless they're on round two.
Like, but we didn't get anything to, like, move on.
So...
So, round two...
I don't know.
Um...
I guess...
Uh...
Doesn't he have to be the same map?
I don't know.
I think, like, if we're in the same bracket...
It should be the same map, just to make it fair.
Yeah.
Like, because this is the winner's bracket, and everybody should play on the same maps for winner's bracket.
Because there's no map bans.
Alright.
I have the news.
What?
So we're banning... We're banning Magic first.
Yeah.
We're gonna do that.
Oh, yeah.
Because then... Because then if they BP, all we do is...
I'm probably gonna Bucky again, or Hella.
Either one.
Uh, both are really good.
They should not be able to have an easy time.
They have a strange one trick, which I'm pretty sure they're gonna...
I don't know what they protect other than Magic.
What do they do?
They protect... I wrote it down.
They protect Strange, Black Panther, Magic, or Bucky.
Okay, depending on the matchup, I don't think they wanna go into Bucky.
Alright, no.
They'll keep Bucky open.
If we ban the Magic, I'm guessing.
But I'm better than him at Bucky, so I'll just play Bucky.
Then that means Luna ban will be open.
Because they don't have to worry about Perma diving the whole time.
Oh, wait.
This is perfect.
Yeah.
Oh, this is perfect.
Oh, no.
We got it.
Okay.
That's perfect.
Alright.
They protect BP, then they have to ban Luna anyway.
Then that leaves open Hella Bucky for us.
And then it just becomes even easier.
That's good.
Yeah.
Their best player is their Magic player, so like...
That's all they have to worry about.
Because they always try their best to protect the Magic.
Oh.
Oh, and then their support... None of their supports play Loki.
Their support is Cloak.
Their support lineup, I believe, is Cloak.
Unless they make their DPS play Loki.
But their two supports play only Cloak and... Cloak, Sue, and Luna.
This should be fine.
Are we just, like, waiting for every game to be finished?
Yeah, I have no idea.
I'm confused.
Because, like...
Did we finish, like, ahead of time?
Or, like, are they, like... Yeah, I'm wondering.
It would be weird if we had considered when we went to three games.
That was a long one, yeah.
Yeah, we went to three rounds, so I'm just, like...
That felt more stressful than anything we did yesterday.
Yeah, no.
It sure did.
I mean, it is winner's bracket, so...
That's scary.
How many games do we have today?
We're guaranteed fifth now.
We're in winner's semis.
So, if we win three more sets, it's over.
Okay.
Yeah.
But then we go to losers.
We have, like, one, two, three, four, five games.
Five matches, and we go to losers.
Oh, fuck.
But it's one elimination, though.
So we can stop.
But the loser bracket is one game.
So, like, we can't make, like...
It's like, we can't learn anything for the next game.
Wait, the loser's bracket is one game?
Yeah, one game, and you're out.
Oh, my God.
I know, right?
That's so fucked up.
Jesus.
Why?
I feel like the winner's brackets are going on at the same time.
It's not gonna hold it up.
I guess...
I don't know.
Okay.
It's just, like...
Fuck.
You guys are losers for a reason.
For a reason, maybe.
I don't fucking know.
That's crazy.
You're incapable of adapting after one game.
So we're gonna give you one game.
It's like, you didn't adapt in winner's bracket.
Why would we let you adapt now?
That's insane.
I've never heard of a format like that.
That's unbelievable.
Survival of the fittest, yeah.
No, they won both.
No, Mace's team won both their customs.
That's weird.
I don't know why.
They won both of their games, so...
I wonder why it took so long.
I guess they started late or some shit.
Okay.
Oops.
I accidentally opened Photoshop.
Uh-oh.
Okay, so...
Mace just leaked out his ban line.
So they...
On us?
So the Cobbler...
The Cobbler...
No, for his other team.
Oh, okay.
So the Cobbler...
The Cobbler, if the thing is...
Or if the...
If Groot's not open...
He goes the thing.
So what if we banned out both?
If we...
If we put out Coney.
We do that.
We can like...
Pure focus the front line guy.
If we wanted.
What?
That's up to us.
I think Coney's gonna do a better...
Wait, are we not banning Mace's stuff?
Uh...
I think Mace...
I...
Nah, I don't think Mace has to be...
I think...
If we just make one of their plays like super weak...
Then I think...
It would be a lot easier.
Kill the front liner?
Yeah.
Why not?
Alright.
Just kill him.
Is that this set or the one after?
If Mace wins against...
Rigsy's team...
Then we fight Mace's team.
Got it.
But like, we have to win this next one to be able to even have that chance.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't want to look too far forward.
Yeah, yeah.
Yep.
I'm fine with sitting out though.
If we want to sub me up.
I think your...
Your thing would be better.
Oh, it is?
I know.
You ain't gotta...
Oh, yeah.
You know now.
He knows.
That's the one character I'm good at.
That's all it is.
But...
Don't say that out loud, Coney!
You're good at so many other characters.
Don't...
Name one.
Mag.
Rocket.
No, that's true.
And Rocket.
No, wait a minute.
Wait.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
I got three.
That's true.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Uh...
Oh, we're all gonna be on the mainstream.
Okay.
Oh, my.
The big...
The big screen.
Yeah.
Big stage.
Trombotron.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
We're gonna be on a big screen, everybody.
I'm so scared.
I'm, like, quivering in my pants.
Well, people are, like, the...
People are, like, why is it what...
Yeah, a lot...
Some people are complaining about the one game.
The one and done.
I think that's crazy.
It is pretty crazy.
Because, like, it's not even like your favorite kind.
Right?
Like...
Yeah.
I think it's...
It's pretty crazy.
I'm just, like, damn.
Because if you're doing it at the same time as the winner's bracket, it doesn't really matter.
That's something you would do on the big days.
Because, like, to keep it running, to keep the loser's sets cut down.
But we're getting down to the end of it.
Yeah.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We just gotta wait for the caster to invite us.
It is kind of crazy, especially with rivals.
Because, like, snowballing is such a thing.
Yeah.
And, like...
Based on, like, one set of picks.
And then adapting and stuff.
It's so crazy.
That's so true.
Like, you can't...
There's, like, barely any time to adapt.
It's also, like...
People are, like, too afraid.
Most sports tournaments...
Yeah, but for most sports tournaments, games last an hour.
These games are, like, 15 to 20 minutes.
We finished one in, like, six minutes at one point.
Because it was a slump.
Like, it makes sense if it's, like, an hour long.
But, like...
These games are, like, 16 minutes and everything.
Very fast.
They do feel long.
Yeah.
The competitiveness of these games makes it much more harder.
Looking at the challenge right now.
Please invite us.
I'm nervous and scared.
Yeah, that's a good point.
My chat said that's especially brutal for the people who start in losers.
So, if you came in after losing yesterday...
You wake up at 11 a.m., die, and then...
Okay.
And, like, it's the first game of the day, too.
So, it's, like...
Like, obviously, like, from us, like, our first game...
Our first couple of games are, like, rough because we're not warmed up, too.
Right.
And it starts so early in the morning.
Oh, my God.
There's no time to warm up this early.
Especially for the West Coasters.
There's no time for us to warm up this early.
I wake up this early.
Anyways, it's fine.
Oh, my God.
What's wrong with you?
I know.
You have an actual...
It's always weird when anyone's show organizes, like, a collab.
And it's at such a weird time compared to literally anybody else's.
Yeah, I love that.
That's my favorite thing he does.
That's my stream time, bro.
Oh, my God.
It's so early.
You're not even a West Coaster anymore.
Oh, we got a user ID.
Oh, we're good?
Okay.
Alright.
I'm staying in, right?
Gomez, unmute.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm here.
Is Beto staying in?
Just engage?
I think Beto will stay in for the first one.
Okay.
Team Omnomnom.
Okay, is anyone friends with the UID?
No.
It's friends only.
Oh.
Here, I'll join it.
Okay, I'm gonna add them and then un-add them.
Have you cleaned up your friends list?
Oh, it's still full.
Alright.
Oh, it's still full to the brim.
I should probably do... I don't know who to remove, though.
I'm in.
Yay!
Thank you.
I'm in.
Oh, we're missing Beto.
Oh, you got Beto.
Okay.
Let me increase the friend limit.
I need more friends.
Please.
It says no one.
Why do you... Wait, what's the limit again?
It's 150.
Why the fuck do you have 150 people on your friends list?
He's popular.
Well, there's a lot of people that I know from Overwatch.
A lot of them are pro players.
It's time to cut them out.
A lot of them are...
Overwatch is saying it's time to cut them out.
It's like from an Xbox game.
The what?
I've never seen that before.
The what have you seen?
Kony?
Oh, sorry.
I was talking to my chat.
I thought it was me.
I was looking at the Lucasboy icon.
It looks like a PS2 game model.
You see that there?
Oh, yeah.
Doesn't it look weird?
It's one of the special ones.
I don't remember where you got it.
Oh, it's the Marvel Cards game.
The Marvel Snap stuff.
Oh, yeah.
I remember.
Yeah, that's why it looks, like, bad.
Is it possible to tell them to wait five minutes?
It looks like a MOBA model.
Okay.
Oh, and they'll ask us if we're ready.
So, I hope.
I don't know.
They did it the first time.
The first time.
Yeah, but this is a mainstream.
There's no way the mainstream wouldn't.
I'm gonna get some water.
I'll be back.
Just go.
We'll let them know.
Okay.
I'll be back.
I need to get water anyway.
Oh, I'm back.
Oh, they're waiting a few minutes anyway.
Nice.
Pretty sure they're just waiting for the casters, because I'm pretty sure it's not just one caster.
Alright.
Oh, my voice.
My voice is not okay anymore.
Is there a bracket?
I don't know if the bracket's public knowledge at all.
I don't... Does anyone know if the bracket's supposed to be public knowledge?
Because if it is, I can just link you guys the bracket.
Um...
Yeah, I definitely need some rest.
Uh, it's supposed to be?
Okay.
Here's the bracket.
Um, yeah, it's public?
Okay.
Cody already showed it.
Alright, I'll show you.
I'll pin the bracket.
I'll just pin it then.
Uh, I'll pin it for everybody.
I think it's also, like, really fucked, because we played ranked together with the team last night.
And, like, we got to, like, as you can see, like, the entire team's Celestial now.
So we won, like, every game except for, like, we lost...
Well, I... They lost one... They were four-stacking, and then they lost one game.
And I joined in, because Shoto wanted to join.
So then, obviously, you can't five-stack.
So I hopped on, so we could do a six-stack for everybody.
Um...
And then we, like... I didn't lose a game during the ranked cry with them, but...
But, yeah.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
It's scary.
Please try not to strain it.
Yeah, I'm trying my best, guys.
So, like, I talked a lot after the tournament, too.
Hello.
Hey.
I'm ready.
Oh, yeah.
Ready to go.
I don't think they are, though.
Did we say where we are?
Or, like, is the casters not ready?
No, they're waiting for us.
No.
Oh, they are?
Yeah, we are ready.
Oh.
We're all here?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
That was cute.
Oh, I thought that was... I thought that was Gumball making that noise.
No, it was, like, the cat.
The cat.
He's just really good at it.
Cat meow back.
Oh, my God.
I was going to grab him, but he went under my bed.
Oh, it's domination first.
Domination.
Oh, my.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Man, get rid of... get rid of that magic.
We don't like magic.
Yeah, we don't like magic in this house.
I shine in darkness.
No, we hate magic.
Yeah, we hate mutants.
That's right.
I thought we hate... I thought we hate Rocket.
I can hate two things.
You do hate Rocket, too?
Yeah.
My hate is not... my hate is unlimited.
Oh, I get the Star Lord!
Oh, you get the Star Lord.
We protect Star Lord.
Yeah, you get the Star Lord.
That's fine.
Get rid of... wait.
You can imagine.
What if we actually leave the Star Lord open?
What if we do?
And protect something else?
No, just protect Star Lord.
I think Star Lord is fine.
Yeah, just protect Star Lord.
Because we have strain.
We do have strain.
Oh my god, I get the Star Lord!
Yeah, that's fine.
If you have strain, just mag.
We'll make it work.
That's fine.
What if they ban mag?
If they ban mag, I'm on Venom or something.
Yeah.
You'll probably be on Venom or another support.
And then protect Star Lord.
Yeah.
I'll play Rocket.
I mean, fucking...
Bring it back.
Bring back the Rocket.
If I have to.
Protect Black Panther.
Okay.
Yeah, see, like I said, that's their protect lineup.
What's their second ban again?
We don't know yet.
Probably... I feel like they might ban Luna or Namor if they don't ban mag.
Did they do the research?
Are they gonna ban Battle?
Let's see.
Oh, interesting.
We've lessened strain to Venom.
So now who do we ban after that?
If we want.
Have I seen... Wait.
Oh, nevermind.
I've seen Kony's captain.
No, it's not Kony.
I'm hovering Groot right now, but what do you guys think?
Two?
Groot?
Get rid of Bucky.
Get rid of that character.
Oh.
Just type it.
Ban Bucky.
Yeah.
I'm down four.
I could do Rocket, Fantastic, or Venom.
What do you think?
Fantastic will die against a Panther.
That's the only thing.
Probably.
Yeah.
I'm gonna keep the orb on Gomez.
Yes.
We have combo.
I get free roam the whole map.
Kony, you just...
Remember not to engage with your slam.
I guess we'll honor it.
Okay, thanks.
That's... Like, what?
I guess... Like, people do it in pro play.
Huh?
They do do it in pro play.
Like...
Like, we instant said it, too.
We didn't click it.
So generous of them to honor it.
Oh, my God.
I didn't like that.
I didn't like that at all.
Bad vibes.
That did leave a bad taste in my mouth, but...
I guess we'll honor it.
Alright, let's do it.
Alright.
Alright, so I should free roam or free roam the backline?
Yes, sir.
I'm splitting from you guys.
Shit.
Wait.
Wait, we... Do we restart?
What?
Hold on, hold on.
Wait.
I think we should.
I think we probably should.
Yeah, if nobody dies...
Somebody... Like, we need someone to message.
Oh, there's no pauses.
Uh...
No one died yet.
We can restart.
No one died.
They're not restarting.
We all leave.
We just leave.
Oh, we have to leave.
Yeah, we leave.
Shrug.
Shrug?
What is with this guy?
What the fuck is wrong with this team?
Wait, hold on a second.
Hold on.
Bro, what is that?
What the fuck?
Bro.
Wait.
What is wrong with them?
Wait, we just... We don't even know these guys.
Hold on.
Vibe's rancid.
We don't even know them.
Oh.
Is he just like a... Is he the doomer of the team?
I don't know.
He probably sounds like... I don't know, man.
It's just...
Yeah, I mean...
I'm stunlocked.
To be fair, the I guess and also the...
Oh, shit.
I accidentally ignored.
Whoops.
I restarted my game, so it didn't crash.
One sec.
I don't know.
Yeah, Lymo just like DC'd.
Like, all of a sudden.
Lymo's gone.
If it happens before first kill, we're good.
Yeah, there's no fear.
Imagine if I got it killed in the beginning.
Dude.
Can we... Can you swap... Can I get benched in between games or do you keep the same thing for the whole set?
We have to keep the same thing in the first... Because then that's... Yeah.
Sure.
That's fine.
Hey, y'all DC from the lobby, right?
Yeah.
Like, Lymo crashed.
Okay, just add the same person again.
Sorry?
Lymo crashed, so we had to.
Okay, that's fine.
Yeah, we can reset them.
Alright, thank you.
Alright, I'm inviting all of you.
Alright, I'm back.
What if we like keep the same bad line?
Yeah.
Okay, boom.
And then we're one for Lymo.
Yeah, that was weird.
That was.
Hmm.
We will keep the same.
Hello?
Hello.
That was awful.
My graphics card driver hitched and then it just went...
And just that was the only noise I could hear.
It was great.
Coming back.
Yeah, that's the noise.
That was the noise.
Oh, that was my cat.
I know.
You're like PTSD.
It's like, oh my god, my graphics card.
Yeah, alright, let me put him down.
Alright, let me know when you're...
No, I'm not going to kill him.
No, put him on the floor.
Whoa, I'm going to put him down.
Overreaction much?
Christ.
Did you see that same person got kind of funny about the fact that we needed to remake?
Yeah, the fact that he said shrug at us.
We were like, the fuck?
Dude, I don't know.
Clearly, tournaments should be decided over who's NVIDIA drivers decide to shit themselves.
That's right.
Alright, I'm back if I can grab an invite.
I got it.
There you go.
Thank you.
I'll join the spectators so they can swap you over.
Wait, why am I joining?
Because they took the spot.
Oh wait, no, never mind.
Oh wait, we swapped teams.
Oops, sorry.
I thought I was on team B for some reason.
Alright, so they TP at the very beginning.
Do we keep the same or do we just TP straight away?
Up to you guys.
Does it matter?
Okay.
For throne room, you have to get that room first.
It's so hard to push out of.
Oh wait, stop.
Not ready.
Not armed.
Oh, Lime crashed again.
Okay, Lime is gone.
What the fuck?
Bro.
What is wrong?
Why are they so passive aggressive to us?
It's not our fault.
What's the bro period for?
Come on.
Dude, we're having issues.
Chill.
Yeah, this is...
Why are they trying to antagonize us?
What do they not like about us?
I don't know.
What do we do?
It's me guys, sorry.
Bro, what did you do?
It's me.
It's just me.
I don't know.
I want to talk so much shit right now.
Oh.
I have my chat open and I'm just looking at the blinking line, but I'm abstaining.
I'm stopping.
Oh man.
Hope our PC is okay.
We might need to put Jay in and put me on support.
No, no, no.
We might need to.
I mean, I could support like me and Doki.
You forgot bro.
What the fuck?
What happened?
He forgot.
I was flexed.
Yes, but then we have to play.
Then like, that's the thing.
What do we play though?
Three tank, three tank, one DPS.
Okay, three tank, one DPS.
Okay.
Three tank, one DPS, two support.
And I mean, we just... I'm really solid on...
The audio is just buzzing.
Even with reboot.
Uh oh.
Oh no.
That's not good.
She needs the audio.
Is this true?
I got this in my chat.
Coney is a human Torx level shit talker.
Is this true?
Oh yeah.
We don't do it like publicly.
Yeah, I have a rule.
Because I played League for ten years.
I have a rule though.
I don't... Only if the other person flames first.
Right?
You never throw the fucking punch.
The moral code.
Yes.
You're giving us some time.
That's what you get really mean.
You're giving us some time to reboot or handle it.
I'm going to use the bathroom then.
Okay, bye.
Wasn't that something?
That's tough.
Worst case, since the set hasn't started, J will be allowed to sub in as well.
Okay.
Yeah, hopefully Lime can fix it.
That's weird.
A little unfortunate.
But I mean, hopefully it doesn't affect her other games too.
It's just her... Just Marvel Rivals maybe.
Alright, I'm back.
I wonder what happened when Lime's PC...
I don't know how much time though we're allowed to have.
I don't know.
We're allowed to put J in.
We're allowed to put J in, but what do we play with J in?
Just Triple Tank.
Yeah, but...
Triple Tank, one DPS...
I mean, if we get the full swap, I can swap the DPS.
Not that it's good, but I can, you know...
The Coney DPS, it's time.
Yeah.
I'm just saying, because if my...
If my tanks are banned...
And J just plays tank, and then Shoto goes healer...
I could play a DPS.
I don't know if it's going to happen again.
Okay, so does it start when the game starts or...
No, the second time it started in the lobby.
Like, it was fucking weird.
How about we like try... Wait for...
Yeah, go to practice.
Good idea.
Yeah.
I'm going to start on a practice mode for a second.
Before we do anything.
Is it also possible to go into a quick play and then just leave the game too?
Um, I'm in practice and it's not doing it yet.
Okay.
Okay, that's...
It just scared me that it did it twice in a row.
Yeah, that was scary.
And like, it was like back to back too.
Yeah.
Literally, it just like...
It was just robotic distortion and the driver was just fucked.
Surely your computer's not breaking, right?
Surely.
Windows 11 is a robust operating system and all drivers are dead.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, well, I'm in the practice round and nothing's happened.
Okay.
Did it happen?
No, no, we're good.
Oh, I heard the... Oh, and I was like...
No, nothing's happening right now.
Okay.
Do we risk it?
We risk one map, I guess.
I mean, if it all goes horribly wrong, you can just sub Jay in for the rest of it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't think they'll allow that because they said it's since the set hasn't started.
No, no, but like, we can sub in between matches.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It'd be crazy to have a sub if you couldn't sub him in.
Yeah.
We can sub in between matches.
Okay, got it.
Because that's what we've done.
So we're good, we're good.
As long as the match is over, yeah.
And then...
I'm here.
If they're going to do that ban line, we just sub Kony out for Jay in the next game.
Yeah.
Works for me.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Yep, I'm ready too.
Woo, okay.
I'm just going to do literally nothing else with my computer.
Just going to sit here and stare at the match screen.
We're going to keep the same bans, right?
Yeah, keep keeping the same bans.
So no advantage here.
I'm not tired.
If it does go, if it does happen, I will let you guys know in chat and just do my best.
Yeah.
If you have to, just get on your phone to just at least listen to our comms.
Yeah, to comm.
Yeah, right.
Yeah, that's fair.
We'll just try to communicate more.
Yeah.
To compensate.
I mean, you should be able to hear me on my phone.
I'll just sound like shit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's fine.
Alright, we're just going to wait for them to start the game.
Wow.
Oh, no.
Wait, we said.
What?
I spread the yawn.
Oh, I was going to be like, oh, no.
What do you mean, oh, no?
Cody's yawning now.
It's over.
They're asking if we're ready.
Yeah, we already said it.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Alrighty.
Alright.
So, what am I doing with TP here?
Oh, gosh.
Oh, God, it hit me.
Lock in, Gomez.
What's wrong with you?
I don't like that.
I'm tired.
You have another tournament after this.
What do you mean you're tired?
Oh, God.
But it's at four.
Oh, okay.
So, we're keeping the same band line.
So, you want to TP onto their side.
Like, towards...
So, if it's...
Whatever map we'll get.
I'll tell you where to put it.
Would it be the opposite high ground?
Yeah.
From where we spawn?
Okay.
Not the stairs, not the center.
The balcony kind of thing.
Yep.
Got it.
I switched out the bands.
Get rid of the Bucky.
So, if it's Throne Palace, you want to put it on...
No, it'll make sense.
So, if it's Garden...
If it's Garden...
Yeah.
Then you want to put it on their side of the statue.
Or our side of the statue.
It depends on how they do it.
I think we want to put it on our side of the statue.
Like, you know what I mean by statue?
Like, the big one?
The center...
No, no.
The big open area with the huge statue on the right.
Or left.
It's on the right.
Yeah.
Is it up top on it?
Like, right next to it.
Like, next to the statue.
Not all the way at the top of it.
Like, you know, on top of that big platform.
With the statue.
So, this time, just DPS.
DPS and just put us on their side.
Opposite balcony.
Oh, not on this one.
Not on this map.
This is the throne room.
This is the big-ass chair.
This is the big-ass throne room.
Yeah.
At the top of the stairs.
Okay, okay.
On their side.
I'm just letting you know I'm still here.
Actually, you know what?
Hold on.
Actually, genius idea.
Take their TP.
Us to their TP.
Okay.
At the very end.
On the other side.
All the way onto their side.
Their spawn.
Go to their spawn.
Use the TP and go to their spawn.
Use the TP.
Go to their spawn.
Take their TP and then just...
Full throw.
Full going.
With this much kind of nonsense that we hear...
Go to their spawn.
Their spawn.
Okay.
No!
There's nothing!
Okay, you know what?
It's fine.
I'm lost.
Okay, it's fine.
Storm should be an easy kill for me.
If we can.
Storm is split.
I'm going with you.
Walking.
Storm's low.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm on their supports right now.
Their supports are low.
Are they?
Come to me again.
Come to me.
Oh, they flashed me now.
Stab me again.
Oh my god, I got caught off.
Okay.
Dwarf's out.
Or Hulk's out, sorry.
We have Strange on us.
I mean, I got full coverage behind them.
Yeah, I'm trying to...
Oh my gosh.
Go for their...
Go for their Storm.
Never mind, that character's broken.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, don't kill me!
Yeah, I couldn't.
I couldn't heal you.
Wait, is he stupid?
Wait, what is he doing?
He doesn't know you have Rez.
Strange, Strange, Strange, Strange, Strange, Strange!
Stick to the moves.
We have Luna ult, we have Luna copy.
We can do the Luna ult.
Oh, I'm not using it yet.
I'm using it now?
Alright, yeah, we're on.
Walking hard, walking hard.
Let me know when damage boost, if you need it.
Damage boost?
I'm ulting, I'm ulting here.
No more ults, no more ults, no more ults.
I'm killing Storm.
Storm's down.
Hulk, Hulk on me!
Yeah, Hulk.
Nice.
Nice, I gotta lower my sens.
Oh, we have to, we have to stagger him next time.
Because we capped it.
I'm giving the orb to Gomez.
Do they have Luna ult?
They have Luna ult, yeah.
They do, they do.
We use cloaked only.
Alright.
So, we can either...
We use either Gomez ult or your ult to drag a Luna ult up.
Which ult first?
Who ults first?
I can ult first.
Actually, no, Coney, you ult first to force out their Luna ult.
Yeah, okay.
Oh my god, I'm getting...
Actually, do it around this corner if you can.
Oh, never mind, never mind.
That's alright, that's good, that's good, that's good.
You can save it for yourself.
Hulk is on me, Hulk is on me.
I'm backing up.
Don't do anything, just contest.
You have res, you do.
I do, I'm already dead, but I'm gonna...
It's fine, they all focus me.
It's winnable, it's winnable, winnable.
It's winnable, winnable.
Point, fight on point if you have to.
I'm one, I'm one.
Very good, very good.
I'm reviving, I'm reviving.
Yep.
Good shit.
No, don't kill him, don't kill him, don't kill him, don't kill him.
Stagger, stagger, don't kill him, don't kill him, don't kill him, don't kill him.
Yeah, jump off the map, bitch.
Okay, so now we have...
We have Luna ult coming up, then we can combo that maybe.
Yeah, wait for me, wait for me, wait for me.
Or actually, Han, you and Kony can do a combo.
Kony, just, whenever you slam into them, ult, don't press the left click and just slow them and let Shadow get a free...
Got it, so just slam Q.
Got it, yep.
I'm gonna wait for them to walk in.
And then time the slam, time your ult with his slam, okay?
Got it, alright.
Before it lands, before the wave lands, okay?
Hold on, I'm waiting for them to walk in.
Go here, yeah, go here.
Got it, going.
Okay, look at the backline, and hit.
I got their Luna.
Luna dead, Luna dead, Luna dead.
I need heals, I need heals here.
I got your back, I got your back.
Straight kill me, I'm already dead.
We have Luna ult, we have Luna ult.
I'm dead.
It's fine, it's fine, we can toss this.
We can win this, actually, hold on, wait.
Oh, I don't have ice, I don't have ice.
Wait, get the stream, stream, stream, stream.
Change, change, change, change.
You're alive, you're alive.
3, 2, 1.
I have both, I have Exhaust.
Need more up.
There's a Luna behind you guys.
Oh, he's got the full heal.
I got him.
We can win this, we can win this.
Nice.
I'm exiled.
I got rolled by turrets, unlucky.
Alright, we can still win this, we can still win this.
I misplayed my ult, I didn't know how it worked.
It was bad.
It's fine.
We can win this next.
I'm low, I'm low, I'm low.
No heals, no heals.
Sorry, sorry.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
He's dead.
He can die here.
I got him, got him, got him.
Got him.
Shit.
I'm hiding, I'm hiding.
I'm hiding, I'm hiding too.
He has snap, he has snap.
Use it, use it.
Cap it, cap it.
I couldn't, I couldn't.
I got it.
Do you want me to rez?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm on Luna, I'm on Luna.
No, no, no.
Okay.
As soon as the tank dies, you rez.
I'll go get Luna ulted.
Okay.
Looking for me.
It's fine.
Okay, we have Namorul coming in.
I have ult here, I have ult here.
I'll heal a little bit.
Low.
Luna should be next kill.
Nevermind, looking frontline.
She's one, killer's one.
Hulk on me.
She's one, she's one.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
I'm low, I'm low, I'm low.
Oh my god, I'm onto Namor.
Namor can die here.
I got him, got him.
Oh my god.
Woo!
Nice.
I get to play Starlord, oh my god.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
It better be the open map.
Okay, so Kony, you're ult.
Whenever you're in the floor, you slow them, right?
So you funnel really long slow.
And your ult is based off percentage of their health.
So if you ult before the whale lands, you basically get rid of half their HP, or over half their HP.
And as soon as the whale lands, you one shot them.
No, I fucked it up because I didn't realize.
I tried to slam ult, and I did Q.
Like, Q interrupts the slam.
You know what I'm saying?
So it was like, I was in midair, and I did Q, and then he popped Q.
Okay, real quick.
Yeah, wait for my whale.
Wait for my whale.
How am I doing TP here?
So TP...
Okay, do the same thing.
Except this time, go all the way into their spawn.
Like, all the way into their spawn.
Like, where they're portaling.
Where they're portaling.
Like, the other side of where they're living.
All the way to their spawn.
Like, leave some gaps so we don't do it.
I don't understand.
All the way.
All the way at their spawn.
Where they're portaling.
Their spawn room.
They're not portaling?
Oh.
Okay, go back.
I'm spawning on point.
I don't know.
Okay.
Wait, you're fine.
Oh, they're on Wolverine.
Okay.
I don't know what Wolverine's gonna do against us.
I don't know either.
He's gonna have to throw.
He's throwing.
He's planning on throwing it.
I'm bored.
I'm ulting.
He's throwing.
I'm...
Hulk can die.
Hulk is dead.
Wolf hurt.
Wolf what?
Hulk is dead.
I'm on.
It's fine.
Strange, strange, strange one.
Strange one.
Strange one, strange one.
Yup.
Yup, nice.
Cloak one.
I got Luna here.
Cloak.
Okay.
Just one.
Namor, Namor, Namor.
Namor's in our spawn.
Nice.
Good shit.
Okay, I have my ult.
I'm chilling up here when they walk out.
I have ult too.
If they pop out...
I have another ult.
Wait for Namor.
Wait for our Shoda ult.
Wait for Shoda ult.
Okay.
Shoda has his soon.
Alright, I'm gonna wait for them to walk through.
Hulk's below.
They're below, okay.
I'm holding.
Okay, we have our Shoda ult.
Yeah, I'm waiting.
Okay.
I'm on point.
I'm on point with you guys.
Going.
I got one.
It's fine, it's fine.
I have my ult.
You just need to combo mine.
Yeah, I'm waiting for yours.
I'm waiting for yours.
I was gonna die.
I need to shit.
I used mine.
I misplayed it.
Ready?
We can rez.
Okay, I'm ulting.
I'm ulting.
Right here.
Nice.
Huge.
Good shit.
That's fine.
You only got Venom.
We got him.
I got Wolf.
It's fine.
No need for...
Do you want me to ult or are we good?
No, we're good.
We're good.
It's just Wolverine and Hulk.
Got him.
No need to use it.
No more on point.
What the?
Oh, he's dead.
He was fighting me and losing, so he jumped down and died.
I'm sorry.
I could not ult because I had to shift to get healed.
I was so low.
Dude, I fucked up my Venom ult again, so it's fine.
Portal on the right.
The portal one.
Yeah.
We're on point.
We're getting point.
Why did we get point?
Oh, shit.
We may have C9.
Okay, we got him.
I'm on there, Luna.
On their heals.
Their heals are so low.
Their heals are so low back here.
I'm on them.
String dead.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Just focus ult.
He's getting solid.
Watch this.
Oh, shit.
Put your fingers in his ass.
What?
He's like, fuck you in particular.
They have no portal.
Yeah, we can push up.
Yup, push it up.
I'm about to have ult up again.
Okay.
We have shuttle ult here.
Wolf behind you.
I see that.
Wait for shuttle ult.
Wait for shuttle ult, Ken.
I think we just save point.
I have ult.
Stay on point.
I have ult too.
Stranger's here.
Stranger's here by himself.
What the fuck?
What the hell?
I'm ulting to get lineup.
There.
Oh, fuck.
I hit them.
I died.
Do we rez him or no?
Rez him, rez him, rez him.
This is the last fight.
I need heal.
Oh my gosh.
What?
I'm one.
Shooting their Luna.
I don't care about waiting.
I got all here.
Oh, I got picked up.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Wolverine one.
I'm damage boosting you.
I got froze.
I got frozen.
You're okay, you're okay.
Damage boost.
Unleash the Vishanti's power.
Nice.
I love that.
Good shit.
Good shit, guys.
That's what they get for giving us Starlord.
Yay.
And I'm never gonna be able to play.
I was gonna say, my Venom is ass, but the Starlord is picking it up.
Yeah, I was gonna say, they're not gonna let that happen again.
Holy shit, I just have this low-level anxiety that any moment now, my audio is gonna go up.
Just don't think about it.
It was like double nerves.
Do we bench Coney, though?
After that bandwagon, should we keep it in case they do Starlord?
I mean, I'm pretty...
I felt like I was ass, but the stats are okay.
You did okay.
You did good.
I just fucked up my combos, so I didn't get the shit with Shoto, but that's my fault.
I'm down to be benched if you guys wanna put Jay in.
Your guy's call.
Gomez.
Your call.
You're the main IGL.
If we think we're fine, keep me in.
They're gonna ban Starlord, so we get Thing.
They can't get both.
They can't get both, yeah.
I mean, they could.
They could if they want to, but...
I get Meg, he gets Strange.
I'm comfortable on Meg.
I'm fine with either.
I'm fine on Meg, I'm just not...
I don't know.
Just keep me in.
I'm either gonna get Thing or Meg.
They're gonna kill Starlord.
I get Thing or Meg.
It's fine.
Okay, sounds good.
The reason they picked me out is because I can't play... I play Thing, Meg, Strange.
But we're gonna get one of them.
Alright.
Or we get Starlord and that happens again.
It's fine.
Okay, I'm ready.
Alright, let's go.
I had my fun one game for the tournament.
The one tournament you actually get to play Starlord.
The one time.
I'm back to jail.
Also, I thought we couldn't change during the set.
Like, once the set starts.
Well, we were able... It says we can if... I read the thing and they said you can change it.
As not, like, in between matches and stuff.
I don't think that would even work, would it?
Yeah, it wouldn't work.
Yeah, how would you even do that?
We did that during, like, casted things too.
We did that during casted matches as well.
Hello?
Hi.
Okay, Discord says I have 600 ping.
What?
I don't know what's happening.
Go to practice range.
I can't believe they're sending viruses to our computers in real time.
They don't want us to win.
No chat, no internet, no vision.
Is it okay now?
Is your Discord okay?
Uh, nope, still at 600 for some reason.
Restart Discord.
Well, you're responding in good time and if your ping is okay in game, it should be fine.
Is your ping in game okay?
Yeah.
Restart your Discord.
Yeah, let me do that.
Did you check your ping?
I didn't even check his ping on practice range before.
I mean, you can actually, if you click the servers, it'll tell you on the top, right?
It'll tell you your ping to each one.
That's true.
It's at 31.
Oh, okay.
We just have to restart Discord.
Let me restart Discord.
Okay, I'll get you in.
One more game and we're in finals.
We're in semis.
I almost got excited there.
Like, this is it?
One more to top three.
Okay, okay.
No, no, we need two to top three.
Really?
Yeah, because if we lose semis, we go to loser bracket and then we have to fight loser bracket.
They get to...
Is it?
I can't tell.
Yeah, yeah, we have to fight for third.
I think it's third place, yeah.
No, we're guaranteed fifth now.
Yeah, it's fifth.
I've done enough Smash tournaments to know we're top eight.
So, it's winners bracket, our side, we're guaranteed fifth.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, out of 100 plus teams, that's pretty good.
128 teams, I think, yeah.
It's not bad.
Why?
This might have broken things for Gomez.
What?
He's probably stuck connecting, you know, when you try and join.
He sits on yellow and it's like...
Maybe...
Oh, we actually, we can't switch out.
He's like, remember to have the team, you start the set with the same each game, so no switches can happen until the new set.
So...
Yeah, that's...
Yeah, that's what I was saying.
That's what I was saying.
They let us do it yesterday.
It matches that we're casted.
Oh, Gomez should be able to join now.
It says he was at max.
Hello?
Hey, what's up?
Is it still 600?
Bro, who are these government agents?
Yeah.
They ruined the audio of all of our members.
Wait, hold on.
Let me rejoin them back.
Hold on.
Are you at 600 ping?
It's at 120.
I think it's the servers in the Discord.
Oh, Discord servers.
Maybe they can swap.
Yeah, it'd be like, can you swap the region of the server?
Or RVC.
I think RVC.
Are we like robots for you?
No.
Wait, just to make sure.
Can you hover over the...
I mean, I'm green.
I'm frightened to fucking tap out of this game.
I'm at 14 MS.
So we're in Europe.
Oh, we're in Europe.
That's an okay ping.
So I think you're fine.
Okay.
Wait, did you put Europe in RVC?
Yeah.
I don't think it really matters.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
That's crazy.
I didn't even realize that.
I didn't check my...
Yeah, I'm at 140 MS.
The fuck?
Yeah, you guys have been at that all the time.
Why the fuck are we in Europe for RVC?
What are they asking me?
Wait, wait.
Who are you, if you don't mind asking?
He's Vgarbisbibis.
Do they think I'm a random?
Like question mark?
What?
They don't know who this person is that's on our team.
Bro, what?
The Vgarbisbibis.
That's all you need to know.
Dude, I've flown off the radar today.
No one knows who you are, Battle.
What happened?
Wait, do you think that happened the entire tourney?
I don't know.
Did people think you were Vgarbisbibis?
Are we ready?
Oh, wait.
We're ready.
Let me fix this.
Wait, are we not?
We're not ready, apparently.
Okay, let me know when you're ready.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Yeah.
I can't believe you just got hoomegalo'd.
It's a stream war.
That was the server changing.
They swapped it.
I will enjoy my 100 MS ping.
That shit was scary.
Dang.
Alright, one more.
One more.
Use Discord on NA servers.
I may as well be American.
Big game.
Oh my god, I'm 66 MS.
I have my ping.
Oh god.
Are we ready?
Yep.
That was a new rule change.
Because, like, before they were saying we can't do that.
They didn't stop us yesterday.
Like...
No.
I think we swapped it.
Oh, no, you're right.
Yeah, they didn't stop us.
And we were on official, like, we were streaming.
We did it in games.
You're right.
Yeah.
We were just waiting for them to start.
Yep.
Oh, wait.
I thought we said we were ready.
Yeah.
Wait, we did.
We just... I said...
Yeah, I'll just say it again.
They don't want to hear it from anyone other than Shoto.
Yeah, they're just like...
Shoto does the bad lines, so like...
Shush.
Captain Shoto.
Oh, hell no.
Maybe if we win this, I can get ducked today.
Alright, we gotta lock in.
That would be a reward for winning the whole tournament, is duck.
Okay, we're in Tokyo, 29... The Spider Islands.
Or this one.
Is that the one with the dojo?
Is this the one where we capture the point first?
Or...
No, no, that's the one where we put...
This is the...
Is it dojo or thing?
It's dojo.
Oh, I like this one.
It's where we push.
Yeah.
This is gonna be fun for Black Panther, though, I think.
There's a lot of high ground here.
Are Black Panther and Magic...
Yeah, we always ban Magic, though.
So we'll probably have to deal with Black Panther in this map.
They say Panther, they didn't play it last time.
Yeah, they didn't play him.
I'm gonna go Wolf again, but that did nothing.
Yeah, that was weird.
I was like, why would...
I mean, they got three of us in that one fight, but it didn't matter because they lost their...
Yeah.
Yeah, we had, like, heals.
I lost to a turret.
Yeah.
Are we ready?
They said ready, like, two times.
So I think you're setting up the casting.
Okay.
Coney, can you do a good toad voice?
It's easy to do a toad voice!
The new one, that's easy!
Oh, well, y'all just did it.
It's really simple.
Or you could do the one from the movie.
With the Keegan-Michael Keys, like that.
Do you know how to sing with a toad voice, too?
Yeah, can you sing with a toad voice?
No, I don't.
Not for free.
Oh, does that mean...
Hey, guys, in Coney's chat, they'll do a full sub.
Five?
You think I'm sticking for five?
How many gifted?
How many?
I mean, I'm in a bit of a decay right now.
Can we get...
400 subs, I think.
400?!
I think 400 is clear.
I better be getting, like, a fucking musical if I'm here.
You guys are VTubers.
You got it, bro.
Look at the audience.
Hey, you know how the rich say rich?
Let's give this Fleshtuber five subs.
Okay, man.
Awesome.
It's gotta be Starlord, though.
It's gotta be Starlord.
There's no way.
You literally got 40.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Hilarious.
Keep thing.
Magic.
Save me from Venom jail.
Protect the thing.
Yeah, protect the thing.
Thank you.
Hilarious.
They learned their lesson.
Yeah, I'm not worried about VP with this.
That's so funny.
I don't get to play my character.
You literally got 40 kills in two rounds.
That's ass, though.
If we have thing...
Okay, not thing.
Yeah, you're fine against Wolverine.
Even if you're better against Wolverine.
What was our second battle?
I forgot.
Bucky.
It's Bucky here, so we leave VP open, right?
That's fine.
Oh, wait.
Actually...
No, I know.
They told me to counter.
No, do Bucky.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Yeah, we're fine.
We'll be okay.
Should've just typed it again so we could get passive aggressive in chat.
I still don't get that.
It was so weird.
I don't know what that was about.
That's crazy that they like...
That's so funny.
They're like, we cannot let Gomez play Starlord again.
They got the treatment once and then they said, nope.
It's like that one time.
Do you remember that scrim where they like, one time let Bettle play Mech and we full-held the team?
And they said, no more for Bettle.
No more Mech for Bettle.
You know, it's great though.
You know, Bettle's not a one-trick anymore.
Yeah, it forced him to learn.
I can't wait to see it, Bettle.
Real talk though, I still see a Neymar here, right?
For now, yeah.
I should be on Hella right now, but I'm gonna do this for now.
Yeah, and then if it doesn't work, you swap to Hella.
Yeah, no being like, but I'm doing so...
Look, he told me to swap when I had 30 kills and I was like, are you sure?
Yeah, and then you swapped and we fucking demolished them.
I'll never go against your word.
I wonder, they don't see me on this balcony outright, right?
Like, if I sit behind this sign.
Where?
Oh, there.
Yeah, they can see you.
You can do like a surprise attack.
Hawkeye, Hawkeye.
Hawkeye, always.
I'll play a little casually here.
I got their support!
I got their Hawkeye!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Fuck him up!
Get the Wolverine!
Oh my god, I'm fucking them up!
We can't dash, we can't dash!
Strange low, strange low!
Oh my god!
Back up, back up, back up!
Gordie, Gordie, Gordie, Gordie!
Oh my god!
You were just fisting the spine of Gord!
I saw that!
I was trying to get that Wolverine, bro!
Get what he needs!
Where's my D?
There's no way, they don't expect it again?
Wait, wait, they don't know!
They don't know, behind you, look!
Look up there, look up there!
Do they know?
They don't know!
Oh shit, shit, shit!
I'm hiding, I'm hiding, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Careful, careful, careful, you guys have me.
You'll need heal, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
Linking.
He can't dash out.
No heals?
I got the Hawkeye, I think.
Nemo, Nemo, Nemo, Nemo, Nemo one, Nemo one, Nemo one.
Oh, he's frozen, he's frozen.
I have ult, I have ult.
I have ult, popping it!
They got it.
I'm frozen, I'm frozen.
I'm coming back, you guys can stay alive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can.
Coney, Coney, help, help, help, help, help, help, help.
I'm good, yeah, I'm going in, I'm going in.
Sorry, I shouldn't have ulted, I shouldn't have ulted.
My bad.
Yeah, communicate, say stuff.
Yeah, yeah, if you're ulting, just tell us if you're ulting.
I, I, I just picked Coney.
I made Coney turn around.
On me, on me.
Someone just fucking beaten me.
What the fuck?
I don't know what that was.
Okay, we're fine, we have no soulbind.
We have four ult, we're good, we're good.
Yeah, they have, they're gonna strange ult.
I ult strange ult, I ult strange ult.
Okay, okay.
They have, they have all their ults, they use nothing.
Just hold this corner, hold this corner.
They use nothing, just remember.
They have everything too.
I'm holding this corner.
I broke up for you, I broke up for you.
Okay.
Oh my god, oh my god.
He can't dash out, he can't dash out.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
If I shift, you stop.
They're getting fucked back here, they're getting fucked back here.
Hawkeye on the left, Hawkeye on the left.
Hawkeye left, yeah.
I'm backing up, backing up for a kill, backing up for a kill.
I'm killing him.
It's all ulted.
Oh, I fucking, I can't move, I can't move.
I killed a fucking, I don't even know how I killed that guy.
I was just trying to kill Coney and I got a headshot.
No trouble supports us.
That's, I mean, that's not going to do anything.
They don't know I'm here, don't worry.
They don't know I'm here.
If I say Feng can't move, just target him because he can't dash or shit.
Feng's coming up, Feng's coming up to you.
Yeah, yeah, I'm going to heal up here.
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
Thank you.
I got him good.
It's big, it's big, it's big.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
It's huge.
Nice.
Last fight.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we have one fight left, one fight left, one fight left.
Okay, okay, let's chill, let's chill.
Yeah, let's chill, let's chill.
They still have Shingo.
You said last fight, I thought...
No, no, I said the next fight is last fight.
I'm dead.
It's fine.
I get that shit fast.
I'm going to stop Feng from moving.
They forgot about it.
They're BP, they're BP.
Watch out.
I'm back, I'm back.
I have ult, I have ult.
Oh, I need heal, I need heal, I need heal.
I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't.
They got me.
It's fine.
They're BP now, yeah.
I'm frozen.
Lime, get ready for a rez, get ready for a rez.
Just don't play me, don't play me.
I'm looking over here, right here.
Thing dead, BP dead, BP dead.
Get ready for a rez, get ready for a rez here.
They doubled, okay, nice.
Yeah, yeah, here you go.
Rez here.
I'm up.
Nice.
I'm back up.
Okay, we'll go back.
Yeah, just back it up, back it up.
I have ult up, I'm gonna hit backline.
Getting body blocked.
Oh, shit.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Alright.
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude.
Oh, big slam.
Big slam, big slam.
I'm alive.
Adam in the back.
I do see the Adam.
Adam, Adam, Adam.
Dead.
Got it.
Rez, rez, rez, rez, rez.
Again?
Cloak, cloak, cloak.
Again.
We need heals.
We only have lime heals.
I'm rezzing.
Careful.
Stay alive for a second.
Yeah, she's rezzing, she's rezzing.
Yeah, no heals yet.
I can...
Fuck me.
I can't move.
That's big, that's big.
I can TP.
TP, TP, TP, TP.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
Jayce, that was bad.
Save her!
Whole team is here, whole team is here.
I'm waiting, I'll wait, I'll wait.
If you can stay...
Okay, we're here, we're here now.
Dude.
Oh my god.
Wait, I have no game sound.
Where's my game sound?
I have ult right after this.
I have ult too.
Okay, 3, 4, 3, 2, 1.
They all tp'd, they all tp'd.
Back up.
Okay, I'm not doing it yet.
Oh, Christ.
I'm doing it.
That's why I have two people on me.
I have two.
I have two on me and two on you.
Oh, I love that.
I love the eye of Morgan Moto.
Get that.
Oh, no, Panther.
Oh my god.
Do you want me on Su?
Yes.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's unlucky.
Holy shit.
My game sound, there's no game sound for me.
Oh god, what is this audio shit right now?
I can hear music, but the game sound bugged out.
It's okay, I can still play without it.
Let me know if they all, I just can't play with sound cues.
Okay.
I need heal, need heal, need heal, need heal.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Where is this Adam?
When my shield goes down, I won't have anything for you because the line of sight is really fucky up there.
I hear like the sound of me fucking hitting people, but other than that, I have nothing.
Strangest...
I'm 1-HP.
Yeah.
Try, I got you, I got you.
Oh, huge slam.
Froze Venom, Froze Venom.
Venom on me, Venom on me.
Venom and Panther on me.
I got him, I got him.
Don't worry.
Couldn't do it.
Oh no.
Oh fuck, I couldn't jump.
It's fine, it's fine.
Okay.
Alright.
I got like ulted somehow and then my game sound broke in that ult.
Like the strange ult broke my game sound.
I wonder if that's what happens or like, you know, there's something weird going on with the game and it just breaks to varying degrees.
Panther, Panther.
I got you.
Look at me, look at me.
And Venom.
I see my kill.
Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom.
I'm just trying to kill these guys.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Venom has no Q, Venom has no Q.
Okay.
Panther on us.
Panther's still on the healers, yep.
I'm ulting this.
Sorry, I did it as you did it.
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
I'm damaging, I'm damaging, I'm damaging.
Oh!
He's got both of them up.
I'm gonna look to ult after this.
Got Adam.
If I don't die here.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Thank you.
Stop Panther.
I got you too.
Thank you.
I can play without sound.
Good shit.
I have no sound Q for a strange ult.
Yeah, sorry Doki.
I was hitting Q as you said, I'm ulting this.
Hey, okay.
But they'll have...
This is last fight, they have strange ult.
We have no support ults.
Just remember that.
They don't support ults.
Portal, portal, portal, portal.
I don't know where the portal's gonna come, okay?
I don't know where it's gonna come.
I don't have audio.
Almost got him.
I'm looking.
Back here, back here.
Okay.
I see him, I see him right up there.
It's so bad when I don't have audios for it.
Thank you for the push.
I'm ulting.
Oh, I knew he was gonna do it.
That's fine, Q me up if you can.
Nice, I got you.
They just ignored the cart.
Wait, I just sat on the fucking...
Good shit.
So, I want you guys to hold top.
I might be focusing their Adam a bit.
Okay.
Holy...
Is that the one with the 15 deaths?
Uh, yeah.
Oh my god.
15, good god.
I literally...
I'm playing with the fucking biggest handicap right now.
It's so...
I can hear my shots hitting.
I can hear music.
I hear no other audio other than that.
Wait, genius idea.
What if one of us screenshots and then you use that as the audio?
That's so fucky.
That's so fucky because it's...
Because then, like, I would think it's...
Yeah, yeah.
And all the...
Wait, wait, can you guys, like, shoot your guns?
Can you guys shoot your guns?
Okay, it's back.
The audio is back.
It's back?
Okay, nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Do you still want me on Sue or should I go Adam for the push?
I can switch if we need more heals, I guess.
I think Sue was good when they...
Wait, did that Black Panther say Sue?
Sue was really good against the Black Panther.
Yeah.
I'll, um...
I'll try to run back for Panther a few times.
Like, I didn't do it as much as I should have.
I'm gonna be playing with a squid in the back too for you guys.
We were doing a pretty good job at peeling for each other too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we were.
Yeah, we trusted each other.
Are they on Penny?
I thought I heard that too.
Do you want me to swap up?
Are you gonna say Psylocke?
Watch Molly.
Oh, yeah.
Penny doesn't do anything with Psylocke.
Did I just hear a sword?
No, no, that's the spider.
Penny.
Oh, okay.
I was so confused.
Yeah, the spider sounds like sword footsteps.
No one's taking damage, so I can't heal you.
But Panther?
Panther on me.
Got him.
Got it.
Panther's done.
We can push up a little bit.
Change is low.
Change is still low.
Change is one.
I got him.
Oh, the mines.
I'll trade out.
It's fine.
I have to eat the mines.
Penny could die here.
Nice.
Good shit.
I'm fine with eating the mines if it gets us through.
It's fine.
I got you an orb.
But nobody is seeing that.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
They portaled, bro.
That means they don't want to portal next fight.
Just get it for us.
Oh, I'm dead.
I couldn't get to you up there, sorry.
I can break their mine.
They can put their mine back here.
Panther's stuck.
He's behind.
Can't kill Strange.
No way.
Oh, just play safe.
Yeah.
Penny, play safe if you can.
Fuck, I tried to back up.
I'm behind them right now.
I think I got mixed.
I thought that was our sual.
That was stupid.
Sorry.
It's fine, I need to heal back here.
It's fine.
On the way.
Push up for Gomez.
I got one.
Hey, they ulted.
Mirrored.
Ult this.
Sorry, I didn't hear you.
You know what?
Oh no, I'm not going to swap now.
I got ult right after this.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
In the box.
No, no.
Okay, they got...
I have, I have...
Strange is half.
Give me up, give me up.
I'm looking at Strange right now.
Oh my god, my Q didn't go off.
My Q didn't go off.
I'm on Black Panther.
He's dead, he's dead.
Black Panther's dead.
Just need more, just need more.
I'm good, I'm good.
Coming over.
I kept my Q for their Strange then.
I got ult ready for the next push.
Good shit.
Okay.
Good job.
He also got the ult.
He's on Namor now.
Yeah, he went Namor as well.
You didn't know?
Oh, they don't have Eos.
Oh, this is great.
Maybe they have my bug.
Wouldn't that be great?
They have no...
Wait, behind you, behind you.
There's a Panther up top.
Panther up top.
Okay.
Just keep the push.
Keep the push for the Panther.
He's going behind right now.
Oh, they're low.
They're getting low.
They're getting low, bro.
Oh my.
He's dead.
Nice.
Alright, my turn.
I'm doing it.
Do it.
Unleash the Ashe.
Oh my god.
Play of the game.
He can't move.
Ah, he got ult.
Okay.
Good shit.
Alright.
Good job.
Let me give you a snowflake.
They wouldn't have a portal, right?
No, they don't.
Okay, he's ulting.
Never mind.
I might just be ganked.
Yeah.
Good shit.
Nice.
Good job, guys.
Well done, guys.
Nice.
Kilo.
Shrug.
With everything against us two.
Wait.
But who contributed the most, I wonder.
The question everybody is asking.
Wait.
Cody, look at him.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
They were right in it.
51 kills.
How does that happen?
I swear that thing is like super weak.
I have no MVP or some shit.
No MVP.
Nah, he farmed the 19 death guy.
Oh, come on.
Yeah, come on.
He farmed him.
Come on.
He has 19 deaths.
Oh my god.
I can't believe.
We were able to do so well despite getting like...
Dude, there were so many weird issues.
Everything was against us.
The enemy team hated us for some reason.
Audio hates us.
The ping hates us.
None of us wants us to win.
Now it's the hard team that's coming in.
I need to check Mace's stream.
Oh, true.
Yeah.
We don't know.
Is Mace winning or Rixie's team winning?
It's got to be over by now, right?
What is my...
Can the chat help?
They're watching our match.
I'm not doing anything on my computer.
I'm just gonna like...
Wait, Rixie's team is demolishing them.
Oh!
Wait, if you look at statline.
We know how to...
But we scrimmed them.
Unless they figure out how to counter it.
But I don't know any team that's fucking running the shit we're running.
I think we'll be fine.
I can't believe how long it took for us and yet we're still...
Because we had so many technical difficulties there.
Mace ult!
You have such a big ult angle.
What is he doing?
I'm like backseating Mace.
And he's dead.
The thing is, they won the first round.
But they're getting full...
Wait, actually.
No, no.
Wait, no.
They lost the first round.
Around 99 to 99.
So they lose this one.
We're fighting Rixi's team.
And that's the team we scrimmed against the most.
They scrimmed us too.
So they know our chats as well.
Right.
They were the one we expected to fight.
Is that the second to last team for us?
No, that's the third to last team.
Wait, no.
Why?
He got pushed away.
That's too shit.
What was our ban line for them again?
For Rixi's team.
Well, Bucky.
We banned Bucky and something else.
It was Bucky and something else, but I forgot.
Was it Sue?
Bucky Luna.
Was it Luna?
Oh, no.
Bucky Sue.
It was Bucky Sue.
Okay, Bucky Sue.
Was it Sue?
I can't look back to our history because we played so many custom games.
Mace off, Wolverine.
I found it.
You found it?
Wait, I think I have it too.
Wait, I have it.
We did...
Okay, wait.
Actually, is it this one?
Aha!
Wait, no, never mind.
Yeah, we played too many games.
I can't go back.
I found it.
I found ours.
Oh, perfect.
It was...
Our ban line was...
Oh, we forgot to ban the third.
I don't remember what we said.
We did Bucky, Protect Luna, and then I forgot what our third ban was because we had to tell them what it was.
And after that, it was Bucky, Mag, Hella.
Yeah, because they're Hella.
Their Hella was really good.
Briggsie's Hella was good.
And then our third ban line was...
Because they protected Hella.
It was Bucky, Thing, Sue.
So, we went...
Yeah.
Their Bucky was oppressive though, wasn't it?
Yeah, their Bucky was very oppressive.
Because they had two DPS.
That's super oppressive.
Their Bucky is a Bucky one trick.
Yeah, I remember just feeling impossible until we got Bucky out.
Yeah.
So, we first banned Bucky, Protect the Thing, and then either banned Hella or Sue.
Because their Hella was oppressive too.
Hella is MVP right now.
Yeah, because Hella is Riggsie.
And Riggsie is like...
Riggsie is really good.
Like, the thing is, Riggsie is a Starlord one trick, but they have to give Gomez Starlord if like...
If they want Riggsie to play his best character.
Did they lose?
Oh, did they lost?
They lost.
I can't tell.
No, they didn't.
That was the last game.
Yeah.
They just finished.
Okay.
So, we're playing this team next.
I'm ready.
Okay, so Bucky...
Are we banning Hella or Sue for a second ban?
Oh, I think they're regretting not banning Bucky or something.
Yeah, they are.
Mace is just talking about it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Are we fighting the one we scrimmed against?
Yeah, the one we scrimmed against the most.
Mostly, yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
This is the game.
I'm kind of excited because that was like a lot of learning experience from them.
Yeah.
Those were good games, yeah.
We ended up strong at the end, right?
Yeah, yeah.
We're warmed up too.
Woah!
Alright, so they're banning Mag 100% then.
I'm not sure.
We don't know.
I mean, they might try to ban him.
If they haven't been keeping up.
If they haven't been keeping up, then they will.
I think they've researched it.
The thing is...
They might try and...
Because they know what comp we did that fucked them over the most.
Right, yeah.
So, like...
They might...
But the thing is, if they try to ban our tanks...
Gomez gets...
Gets Starlord.
Yeah, he gets Starlord.
Because they have to either ban Strange Mag or Thing.
They can't get all three.
Oh, we have 40 minutes to an hour downtime?
What?
The fuck do I do?
What the fuck do we do?
Guys, it's time to run a comp game.
Let's just zigzag.
Let's just go.
Should I get on my ult?
It's time, y'all.
It's time to zigzag.
Alright, I'll get on the ult.
Okay, I'll get...
Wait, you guys are...
Oh, you guys are Celeste!
I can get on my other...
I can get on the Celeste account.
You can!
Yeah, yeah, okay.
It's time.
It's time, guys.
Let me put the...
Let's see...
Yeah, I gotta keep the muscle memory.
Yeah, let's stay warm here.
I'd like to stay warm, yeah.
I'll be like, sorry, Jay.
Oh, wait, are we in the...
This is the finals?
I haven't even gone on my ult, and I'm already getting requests to play Iron Fist.
Yeah.
How are we gonna play Iron Fist?
So, we're in winner's finals, which means that we're guaranteed top three.
Yeah.
If we lose twice, we get third.
If we win, we go on to Grands.
Yeah.
Okay.
But if we lose once, we get one more chance.
Because I sure...
I have not been keeping track.
Okay.
Let's see.
I generally do not remember their other DPS.
I'm just saying, sorry, Jay.
Okay, waiting for grand finals.
40 minutes.
What is it, 40 minutes?
40 minute downtime.
Bro.
I'll put this here.
Fucking, I don't know.
Put it here.
You guys don't have to see the objective.
Fuck you.
Alright, let me swap accounts.
We're playing with the guys.
I'm unmuted.
I'm fucking stupid.
The guys.
Is he gonna ditch us?
Bro, what are you trying to say?
Yeah, he's trying to ditch us.
I'm playing with y'all.
I'm playing with you guys.
Are you a content?
Are you a clip farmer?
What am I hearing right now?
No, no, no.
Okay, sometimes when I press the mute button, sometimes it doesn't mute me.
And I get pissed at it.
I don't know why it doesn't mute me.
Am I content farming for no reason?
Am I doing that right now?
Yeah, you're doing great.
You're doing great though.
Is this intentional?
It just feels like...
No, it's not.
No, I'm just wondering.
Ask my teammates.
I always yap in their ears on accident.
Oh, did he just disappear?
My Discord just locked.
Me too.
What happened?
I thought it was Jomez and I was losing my mind.
I was laughing.
Wait, what did I do?
I just crashed in the middle of you saying colluge.
Yeah, you went colluge.
Guys, I have to be a PNG for the rank because I have to swap Steam accounts.
Alright guys, let me grab a PNG real quick.
I'm gonna make the room.
I can start.
I've got most people on my list.
Yeah, good.
Get rid of it.
Mute, swap.
I'm so used to... even though I've been streaming for a bit, I'm still not used to the streamer mode where I can't hear the...
I'm not used to it.
That's weird.
Yeah, it's weird.
Yeah, you guys have been doing this for so long.
I know you guys are so used to it.
I can't tell if this is like you're just young or old.
No, he's young.
I'm 21.
Okay.
Okay, I'll be respectful.
I won't ask how old you guys are.
Yeah, the thing is his information is public.
Like you can literally look him up.
Oh, the opposite of VTubing.
Yeah, the opposite.
The gamer life.
I put out my whole name.
I put my birth date.
He has a wicked Wikipedia.
I do have a Wikipedia.
I do.
Nice.
And then, meanwhile, Connie has...
Oh my God, it even has your full... Oh my God, it's fully docked.
It has your first and last name.
It doesn't have my middle name.
It doesn't have my middle name though.
Oh my God, guys, you can dox him right now if you want to.
Okay.
Let's dox this dude.
He's gonna steal my identity.
Please help me.
Guys, we have so many options.
Okay, let me put myself up here.
I'm just a face right now.
Just a giant face.
The street you were born on.
Your mother's maiden name.
All that.
Using PNG.
I'm okay talking about my family's names.
My dad's name is just like...
You're doxing your family?
Okay.
It's my family though.
It's my family.
Like, what are you gonna do?
Find them?
Is that what you're gonna do?
Dude, there's a rainbolt out there that can do it.
Oh my God.
That's crazy.
You're like, if my information is out in public, my entire family's gonna be out in public.
Are you sure you're not a clip farmer?
I'm not.
No, I'm not.
I'm just doing what I do.
It just seems like intentionally unintentional, you know?
I'm not trying to do anything.
I promise.
I'm sure you are.
I'm sure.
I've only been a streamer for like two months.
I don't know how to clip farm properly.
I don't know how to do that.
Wait, oh my God.
I can use my new Chibi... I got like a Chibi model soon.
They sent me a PNG of it.
I'm gonna use that.
Bro, everyone be getting Chibi models.
Wait, is it bad to be a clip farmer?
Is that bad?
Is it bad?
He's still doing it.
He just doesn't stop, bro.
No, it's about me.
We're gonna teach him wrong.
It's a joke.
I understand, man.
I get it.
You wanna play it out.
Like, I'll play along with it too, dude.
It's all good.
I got your back.
Alright,
I'm ready.
Gomez, when do you think I started streaming?
You're not allowed to do any googling.
I was about to do that.
Like, three years, I'd say.
I began streaming in 2011.
What?
I didn't even know that.
The internet was around then?
I know, right?
Yeah, we hopped on our dial-up when we got streaming.
It was.
I assume that's you, Doki.
Alright, that's me.
That's me.
It's Mi-Dok.
Yeah, I'm Mi-Dok.
Oh god, I just realized how old you were when I started streaming.
Wait, how old was he?
Wait,
how old was he?
Actual child.
How old was he when you started streaming?
I can't math.
Like, eight.
Oh my god, he was eight years old!
Dude was sipping juice boxes while you were streaming.
What the hell am I doing right now?
I do sound older than I sound.
I mean, a lot younger than I sound.
I was gonna say, I didn't think you were 21.
No, I'm older than 21.
No, I didn't think so either.
No, I thought he was like 30.
Why does everyone think I'm old?
Why?
You have that old energy on you.
I just think like, I don't know, you said you played Overwatch Pro 2.
And I was like, oh, wait, maybe he's been like a long time guy.
He's been around for a while, yeah.
No, I haven't.
Like, Flats and Boger and all those dudes, right?
I don't know.
He has an old spirit inside him.
I do.
Are you all ready to rank?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Alright.
Let's go.
We got this.
Yeah, we're in some, ooh, we're in Celeste 2 lobbies now.
This is where we lose in solo queue and get horribly demoralized.
Oh, no!
Don't say that.
We have to practice our comps.
Cause like, we know what comps is good.
I privated my profile so they don't check it.
So they don't check it.
Yeah, we know like...
What if they watch us?
We all know like, what comps does best against them.
So we all have to practice it.
Bro, the estimated time is 5 minutes?
Oh, my God.
Dead game.
Dude, yesterday was like, instant.
Yes, it was.
Wait, but it's a Sunday.
People should be playing.
People are at church, right?
Oh, wait.
Discord crashed again.
I don't know.
Wait, did Discord crash?
Nobody said anything there for a second.
Okay.
I'm...
Sorry.
So, yeah.
If you guys didn't know, because I'm an alt account, I don't want to buy VTube Studio.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, Discord is crashing.
Come on, you guys.
Hey, welcome back, everybody.
Welcome back.
I just got...
I'm not gonna lie, I thought I got Donald for a solid 5 seconds.
Me too, I thought so too.
But there it is.
Fuck that Shoto guy, I don't care.
My bad.
I looked over at my OBS, like panicking.
It's been less stable since we switched servers.
Maybe we should switch back.
Yeah, like, can we go back to EU?
EU!
Can we go back to EU?
Should we?
Do you want to?
I mean, we could test it out.
To EU.
Yeah, we could us.
Can we just keep it here for competitive or whatever?
It's fine.
Can we go back to EU?
VC?
The East Coast one keeps crashing.
No, it's still gone.
Yeah.
Oh, what?
What the fuck is...
Why?
Why us?
What did we do to deserve?
Like, why us?
They're trying to contain our power.
I have to play with no audio.
That's actually fucking crazy.
Trying to play with no audio.
I never expected...
Lime was about to deal with that, which would have been insane.
Yeah, no.
She was going to do something worse than that.
She would have like zero audio overall.
Yeah, that would have been very distracting.
Yeah, at least I had the music to keep me company.
Like, I had the game music to keep me company.
You're just like hyping out to the end of point music where you get your tense and everything and nothing else.
Yeah, while everyone was dying around me.
But that portal was so scary because it was like next to me and I had no audio cue for that.
Yeah.
I like the idea of the screen share because all of the directional audio would have been wrong.
That would have been really funny.
Oh, Betel.
We were talking about the spawn portal, right?
So basically, I think what Gomez was trying to tell you to do was like...
Oh.
Okay, that's great.
That's awesome.
Dude, I'm about to crash out.
Yo, I'm not going to lie.
Let me repeat myself.
Sorry, my bad.
Yeah, hit me.
So, about the portal thing, I think what Gomez was trying to explain was that we portal to where their...
Oh, shit.
My bad.
We portal...
That was my chat.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, we portal to where their spawn room is.
So, we just go to where they're about to enter their portal, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
So, we could enter through their portal.
I'm going to get the map.
What's the...
Oh, wait.
So, you were blocking their portal from where they're portaling from spawn?
No, we're not trying to block it.
We're surprising them.
Yeah, we're surprising them as they're trying to portal at their spawn area.
Like, directly in where they leave spawn area.
You know?
Their door, where they leave from spawn.
That spot.
So, do you not understand still?
I still don't get it.
Wait, there's no way.
It's in the map.
Okay, so you know how when we get out of our spawn...
Okay, Beto, do you know how when we get out of our spawn, we just walk out of our spawn and we make a portal?
Yes.
So, the enemy team also does that, right?
So, the portal is supposed to be there, where they're at, at their spawn when they walk out the door.
So...
And then we go through our portal and then walk into their portal.
Because it's like, what the fuck?
Because we show up in their portal.
I'm literally going to pull out MS Paint right now.
That might actually help.
My auditory learning is really bad.
Like, grab a PNG of a Marvel Rivals map right now.
Like, puppet show that shit.
Can we go into custom game?
Can we just do that?
Okay, look at this.
No, I'm going to draw it out for him.
Why don't we just go to a custom lobby?
So, what does... I'm going to do the Bifrost Garden, yeah?
Okay, so this is where we enter, right?
I don't see it, but yeah.
This is the enemy spawn room.
This is their spawn area.
That's where we start the game, right?
Okay.
And then this is where we exit out of.
There's all the trees and shit like that, right?
It's all green and beautiful.
Did you draw those?
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, I got you.
I got you.
And then there's all those pillars around.
Can we use the bathroom while you explain this?
The main spawn area is this huge circle, remember?
If you put down the HP packs, I don't know where we are without the health packs.
Okay, okay.
I don't remember.
Oh, there's a health pack.
There's one right here.
Okay, yeah.
There's probably one right here.
Oh, now I remember.
Right here, right here, right here.
There's one right here.
Right, yeah.
This is off the map.
This is where you die, right?
Yeah.
Jeff loves this area, remember?
Yep.
Okay, this is where the statue is.
Remember that big statue?
And then this is like the wall that separates both sides.
This is like a big tree.
There's a big tree in the middle.
It kind of looks like a face.
Yeah, it does kind of look like a face.
No, don't say that.
All I see is a face now.
No, it looks like you.
It's an emoji.
I think there's like another separator here.
I don't remember exactly.
Those are stairs.
Okay, those are stairs.
Whatever.
Fine.
Okay, let me just...
There's stairs here.
Whatever.
That's like...
Not the point.
That's not the point.
Okay, there's like some stairs here.
And then there's some stairs here.
He's drawing Heihachi!
Oh, nevermind.
And there's some stairs here too.
And then there's some stairs here too, right?
So this is basically what I'm trying to say.
This is their enemy spawn.
And pretend like this spot right over here, right?
That's us?
This is us.
Yeah, this is our spawn.
I'm going to make this blue, alright?
Just so you know.
Oh, thank you.
Color coordinated.
Spawn.
Good, good, good.
What happens next?
Okay, okay.
Us.
US, whatever.
It's us, okay?
Okay.
Their strange...
Let's say there's two strangers on the enemy team.
He's over here.
This is Dr. Strange, right?
That's him.
Yeah, that's him.
He's going to make a portal right here.
That's his portal, right?
Okay.
I'll make it a little bit orange so you know...
I think we're just going through again.
No, it's okay.
I'm going to keep going.
Strangers make you a portal.
This is Enemy Strange Portal, right?
Yep.
Yes, for short.
That's an acronym.
Enemy Strange Portal.
The Spanish portal.
This is us.
This is you, Betel.
That's you, Betel.
I'll make you purple.
That's me?
Yeah, that's you.
And you're making a strange portal over here.
Okay?
This is your strange portal.
You're going to make your strange portal go over to theirs right over here.
Oh, to the side of it.
To their spawn.
So we surprise them.
We jump out.
So we're going to attack them while they're going in their portal.
Yes.
No, no, no, no.
Hold on.
Wait, no, no, hold on.
Betel needs to be explained properly.
So they're going to put a portal down while we go over, right?
And you put our portal onto their portal and their spawn.
And then we take their portal to surprise them when they jump onto their portal.
Okay, I'll rewind.
It's changing.
That's not what the diagram shows.
Okay, draw a portal on the middle point.
On the middle point.
Oh, so we go out of our portal into their portal.
Yes, fucking trolling my ass.
I know it.
Wait, did you send a visual?
Look at the drawing.
Wait, where is the drawing?
Look in Discord.
I'm looking at the drawing, dude.
I still don't get it.
Where's the drawing?
I don't see it.
Shadow hasn't put a portal on the point yet.
Oh, we don't go in the portal.
Yes.
This is the enemy portal right here.
This is their portal, right?
Because they want a portal there.
We, from our spawn, we make the portal from our side.
What the fuck am I looking at?
This is the most complicated shit you've ever drawn.
How is this even possible?
How could anyone figure this out?
Well, I see the map.
I just don't understand what...
Okay, we go into a custom lobby.
Okay, we're going into a custom lobby.
Oh my god, bro.
There's just no way.
I was on board, and then Gomez said no, and then it changed.
Gomez said no, and then you were not on board anymore.
Like, what am I looking at?
Can someone take a screenshot of the drawing?
Yeah, I took a screenshot of it.
I'm like, what am I looking at?
Bro, why are you roasting the drawings?
I'm trying to help.
Wait, wait, wait.
We might just start.
I'm still in the spawn.
They're not even gonna portal.
Like, they're not gonna portal at the start.
Oh my god, he actually blocked it.
I freeze.
Goodbye, Spider-Man.
Oh my god, I can't kill this anymore.
We'll just do that.
My chat's like, wait, I can sword and see it.
What the fuck do you mean, I'll be back?
No, no, no, stay, stay.
I got requested to play Iron Fist.
What do you mean, requested?
Just don't turn it when you die.
I request you don't.
Oh my god.
I got requested.
I gotta listen to the sound.
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
Iron Fist, save us!
Where's our Iron Fist?
Oh, and then he went back to spawn and stayed on Starlord?
Oh my god, he's still on Starlord.
He left us to stay on Starlord.
I was so excited for an Iron Fist.
Well...
I'm thinking about that portal.
No, he's gotta think about the portal.
We might have locked him for the rest of the tournament.
He's just not gonna be able to...
Look what you did, you broke him.
You may have brain broke me until I figured this out.
I'm not kidding, I still don't get...
Well, we're going to Custom Lobby after this.
We're going to... we'll visually show you.
I'm not a troll.
It's not like... a bit.
He's just... we broke him.
What do we do?
We broke him before the files.
There's a Namor on us.
Behind us.
Thank you.
There's a Spider-Man on me.
Spider... oh, we...
Okay, after... after you...
Oh!
Go soon, so you push the Spider-Man away.
Oh, that's you.
Oh, ow.
I'm good now, it's a...
Pro so much as like, pro does not have imagination.
Should I run back to spawn while we're...
No, no, no, no.
Don't do what Gomez did.
Should we run back to spawn?
What is happening to me?
I can't... I can't even think.
Oh, no, we fucking lost two players.
The fucking riddle thing has just broken the team.
That entire drawing has fucked us up.
I'm still thinking about it.
Oh, no.
No, they have Spider-Man all.
I'm scared.
I don't have Soul Link.
It's fine.
I can't believe this is...
Dude, it was a good drawing.
It's... it's on me.
Like, it literally...
It's a good drawing, bro.
It wasn't a good drawing.
It's not your fault.
Like, I got it.
He said he was a bad auditory learner.
Like, what do we need to do?
What's the play?
Well, I need to see the game now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now we gotta see that.
Yeah, we're gonna go to a custom lobby just to...
You think doing it in slides is going to make it any easier for us?
And then we give them, like, a fucking lecture?
I'll make you a video essay.
The power of the double portal.
The power of the...
This portal changed everything.
Oh my god, they have snitches.
Whoa, I made it just in time.
Oh, I never mind.
Jesus Christ.
I did not make it.
Yeah, yeah, Kony, upload a video tutorial.
Every exchange player needs to know 101.
Oh, okay.
Do not do it to their spawn.
Just...
Okay,
we have to go.
Go, go, Kony, go.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm getting it, I'm getting it.
I'm on point, I'm on point, I'm on point.
Now I'm on point.
No!
I got separated, I got separated.
Oh no, not the door.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Oh no, this broke our entire team.
We're not ready for the finals.
The morale is in totters right now.
Why did they give us a 40 minute downtime?
That really is so long.
Yeah.
Alright bro, I'm gonna run behind and ult.
Okay.
I'm watching.
I'm going back there, I'm going back there.
Oh.
Thank you.
I got you, I got you.
I'm here.
It is clobbering time too.
He's so right when he says that.
Oh, he's so dead.
Sorry, we were dealing with fighter's mech.
Nice.
Oh, you got one?
Nice mirror.
That's fine, we got one.
I have my ult for this angel.
Yeah, he just fucking ran at me.
That was crazy.
I like how Gomez is so locked in, he's not even saying anything anymore.
Oh, oh god.
I'm off.
I forgot.
You forgot we existed?
That's cool.
No.
No, no, I'm just like, I forgot to talk.
He's so disassociated.
My energy's got drained.
My energy's got drained from now on.
Oh, that's fine.
Oh my god!
I've frozen my frozen.
Beat him up, please.
Beat him up.
Try.
He ran away.
I'm looking to ult.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going to heal, I'm going to heal.
It's fine, it's fine.
He thought he went for the thing.
Bro, bro, what the fuck?
It's fine, you're all fine.
We're doing so good right now.
Yeah, we're so healthy right now.
Against this team of random people who probably aren't on this course.
Just like three stack.
Yeah, we had like, we just played four games of the fucking most competitive shit ever.
It's okay, we're just getting the int on our system.
And we're here just sitting here trying to figure out how to get Betel to...
I don't think we're ever going to need to use that, like.
Because the drawing's good.
I'm telling you, it's good.
I'm going to do this.
Spider-Man's awesome.
Okay, we made it work.
We made it work, we made it work.
Oh no, somebody messed with the amazing Spider-Man.
No!
He tells you not to do that.
I did and I walked away.
I thought Spider-Man doesn't kill.
You messed with him too much.
It only takes one bad day.
Takes one bad day.
What the fuck is...
Where are you?
I got you.
Oh my god, guys, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
Celestial lobbies.
Wouldn't it be fucking crazy if everybody just ranks up?
Spider-Man down here.
They're portaling.
Where are they portaling?
Where the hell is Spider-Man?
Spider-Man's, like, below us.
He's, like, in this cavern.
Oh, they're on us.
Oh, Spider-Man on me?
How the fuck?
I think he tried to hit you and got me.
Yeah, because I walked to the side there.
My last minute walked to the side.
When they drop, I'm going to ult.
Hey, I just accidentally got me.
Do you want me to ult here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, oh, not there, though.
It's okay.
No, it's fine.
Just help save our tanks.
I'm waiting for... I'm waiting for Thanos.
Oh, that was a sick flip.
I saw that.
I saw the flip.
Yeah, I saw that.
I dodged it.
I saw the flip.
Oh, that hook was so low.
Fuck.
I died with ults up.
I'll be back.
Okay, I have ults, too.
I'm coming back.
Okay, we run in and ult.
I have to...
Whoa!
Oh, I don't like that noise.
I'm just contesting point.
I'm also.
I'm just kind of spinning.
All right, three, two, one.
Oh, big slam.
Fuck, he was Spider-Man.
That's right.
Oh, match with Luna Snow.
Spider -Man can't kill no more.
Okay, we got it.
Yeah, we got it.
We got it.
We did it.
I've always believed in us.
Yay.
We did it.
All right, I'm ready.
I'm so fucking ready for finals.
I hate this map, dude.
Yeah, this map fucking sucks.
Yeah.
I'll just keep it there.
Without context, that looks like a submarine.
That's true.
I thought the trees were supposed to be beautiful.
Okay, okay, listen.
You're asking too much out of me.
When we were like 30 seconds into that ban phase.
That whole like...
What's that?
I just don't understand how you don't get that part.
Like, I'm...
That's fine, that's fine.
My bad, my bad.
Okay, with custom games, we gotta do a custom game afterward.
The custom game just to...
I'm literally gonna pull up your stream and tell you where to go to.
Oh, no.
The wires have not connected, bro.
No, we have the enemy.
Okay, so this is how it...
Okay, we're gonna put Gomez on the enemy team and he'll play strange.
And he'll place a portal.
And then Beto, you place a portal in his spawn.
That's how we're gonna do it in the custom lobby.
And then he'll understand.
I have another idea too.
I have another idea after too.
Or Coney, Coney goes strange and then Beto watch our two strangers.
No, I have to do it.
I have to do it.
I play this character!
Okay, show me, bro, show me.
You don't have to do it if you can't watch.
And we're too busy talking about a portal.
No more behind, no more behind.
Okay, I'm...
Oh, dead.
I couldn't look behind in time.
You see, we died because...
It's tearing us apart.
No, we're killing their backline.
Guys, guys, but who's gonna help me?
I am, I am killing their backline.
Who's gonna help me though?
Guys, why is this so...
There we go.
I still died.
I wanted him to die in there.
Don't you pay for heals?
Oh yeah, heal, heal, heal.
Where's my team?
Where's the heals at?
MiDoc needs heals.
Where is MiDoc heals?
Sorry MiDoc, I got killed by a fish.
Damn, MiDoc's sad.
I will save you.
What the fuck is going on in here?
I'm good, I'm good.
What the fuck?
I left you the moment you were like, I will save you.
Shift it out.
Alright, man.
We'll do it again here, hold on.
Alright bro, I got E ready.
No more on the back side.
No more, no more, no more.
Let's keep going.
I don't care about no more.
We care!
You're a surprise kill!
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, see Coney left.
Guess who can't heal because you didn't care about him.
My team sucked.
Got it.
Alright.
Alright, I just changed out.
I just changed out.
You did everything else.
The true rank experience.
Eww.
Thing that charges into six people.
Big push.
Sorry!
I've had that happen before too.
Hilarious, he pushed it right in.
Oh wait, that wasn't your ult.
I thought that was Sona.
I thought it was Sona.
I damage boosted the enemies.
No, no, definitely not.
I just go into spectate to see Bettle like running into a wall.
Where did he go?
No, Bettle, Gomez.
Oh, Gomez.
I was like, what?
Sorry, I didn't mean to call you out, Bettle.
He still haven't used portal.
I don't know.
After all those diagrams, no portal?
Yeah, after all those diagrams.
He's going to start portaling in front of the enemy team.
There's so much Loki up there.
I don't like that.
Oh, wait, I think you got the Loki clone.
Let's go!
Good job, Loki clone.
He's not going to TP.
That sucked.
I don't think so.
I'm walking.
See, this is why we're going to ban Suu.
So you'll have all those strange elves you want.
There's like a Namor above us, by the way.
Alright.
I'm causing so much pressure.
And?
Oh, I got one.
You stole it, though.
I got the kill.
Well, I did not steal it.
I literally worked hard.
I stole it.
I like how he's like, I got the kill.
Armed and dead!
Oh my god!
Again?
Again!
Do you guys want a portal?
Yeah, portal us.
Yes, please.
Yes, we do.
I'm not doing that.
I'm not doing that shit anymore.
Where will this portal go?
Where will this portal go, Bell?
I don't know.
Where is it going to go?
Is it going to be a good portal?
Or is it going to kill us all?
I don't like this.
Into no more turrets.
I don't like that portal.
There's a Loki on me!
There's an Iron Fist on... oh, wait, no more on you.
What the fuck?
I'm already dead.
I'm done.
He threw a whale on a dead body.
Wait, StrangerOne.
StrangerOne, punch him.
Oh, nice.
He had no supports.
I will.
Alright, we're coming over.
He stranged all to me and then I died.
And stay out!
What?
Did you lock it?
Did you lock the game, Kevin?
Oh my god!
That's like crazy!
And this shot got pulled in.
Alright, she's dead.
Kill her.
I left her for you.
You guys aren't killing her!
Hello?
What do you mean?
All I can do is clap.
That's still killing her.
That's all I can do is clap.
Just a fucking K-pop song.
What do you want to do?
Nobody's going that straight!
Again?
What the fuck is this?
What?
You guys see what I'm...
Oh, he's on the thing.
There's a clone here!
Do it again!
You missed a clone.
There's a Namor up here.
He might Agamotto up here.
Behind us.
Stop.
Bubble.
Guys, there's a turret just shooting you guys in the back.
I'm going to ult right here.
Damage boost.
I got you.
No way I got you.
I knew you were the right guy this time.
Nice.
Oh, we did it!
Good job.
Nice.
This needs to be put to rest.
I got more visuals for you, actually.
No, I got...
No, just get us into custom lobby!
No, no, no, no.
It'll work.
So this time, I added something that will give you more...
more of a visual, okay?
You see this?
Ah, shit.
So you see this, right?
So I got an icon for you.
So you see it, Bubble?
So this is you, okay?
It's Gomez's screen sharing.
Yeah, my screen sharing, okay?
This is what Gomez added, chat.
So basically...
So this guy is going to portal over here, right?
And his team is going to be like, oh, wow, over here, right?
They're all going to be walking the point and going out, right?
They're going to be holding our spawn, right?
But instead, this is you now, right?
This is you.
So then, we're going to TP over here, right?
And then we take their portal.
That's what I said!
You guys said no!
I literally said that!
Wait, I thought the way you were explaining it...
Oh, okay.
I made it seem like...
Oh, did you?
Oh, I didn't know that either.
Wait.
So my drunk was good.
My drunk was good, right?
You made me feel like a big fucking idiot!
You made me feel inept at art, bro.
You didn't get it, you know?
I said your drug was good!
No, you didn't get it.
He didn't get it.
He gets it now, though.
He gets it now.
You're the strange icon that actually helped a lot.
That added quite a bit.
Why didn't you do that in the beginning?
I'm resigning.
I didn't think of that.
Because we were about to get into a game.
We were literally about to get into a game.
When you were explaining it, and then Betel said, Oh, so we portal to their portal, then take their portal.
And you said no.
I was like, oh my god, that's what I thought too.
Am I stupid as well?
No, I thought he was saying we portal to their portal that's already on the site, and we take their portal and go to their spawn or something.
No, that's not what he meant.
No, I did get it.
No, shut the fuck up.
I do understand it.
Dude, I'm trying to explain your explanation.
I just might...
Oh my god, bro, shut up.
I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
Dude, I like your drawing.
It looks like the map.
I'm glad.
I'm glad I didn't add enough greenery.
I'm putting it on my stream for the first time, and I'm looking at it.
He said I didn't add enough trees.
No, you said the trees were beautiful.
I don't see it.
It's the green, bro.
You know what would have sealed the deal?
If you drew an arrow from my portal going into their portal, that would have...
There is arrows.
What do you mean?
There are arrows.
No, another arrow.
We come out of my portal going into their portal.
You know what I mean?
No, you didn't draw the last arrow.
You know, the portal to their portal.
You forgot to draw an arrow there.
So it's like, what do you do after we got out of his portal?
There's a visual clarity issue on my part.
Yeah, yeah, it's alright.
Everybody makes mistakes, you know.
I failed as a teacher, I guess.
It's okay, it's okay.
I think the map was good and the understanding was good.
It was just the conveying the understanding was apparently not a successful maneuver, so...
It's okay, we fixed them.
We fixed Beto.
I think that was good team building exercise.
Yeah.
How much more time until the next game?
I think we have enough for one game.
Do we?
I think.
Are you sure?
Yeah, we have 20 minutes.
Let's check, let's check.
Do we have 20 minutes?
Yeah, we should have 20 minutes.
They have to...
Play...
I think they're streaming the other loser, right?
The last loser match.
That sounded really bad.
The last loser bracket.
Yeah, they have to play three.
They have to play three games.
Okay, yeah, we can run one.
Okay.
Actually, wait, wait.
I have to walk my dog.
So...
We got seven minutes in queue.
Let's get Jay in here.
Alright, yeah, get Jay in here.
I'll be right back.
Hold on, let me get him in here.
I'll be right...
Wait, should I leave...
Oh, wait, but I want them...
I don't want to leave my chat, like, without anybody talking.
Like, let's just be like...
How about...
Can they, like, drag...
Open it for now?
One more slot for now.
Hang out before our tournament game.
I mean, I could also just dip if Jay's not here.
Some guy wants a VOD review.
Jay...
Someone in my chat wants a VOD review.
One...
We have one more slot for rank.
Get in here.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see if Jay is alive.
Oh, he's streaming.
Where's Jay?
Where is he?
Jay just got out of...
Jay just got out of a rank game.
Oh, he is playing rank, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just invite Jay into the...
Okay, let me leave the thing.
MeeDoc leaves.
MeeDoc gone.
Yeah, MeeDoc gone.
Alright, I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go walk my dog.
I'll be right back, guys.
Okay.
Alright, let me...
Who is the one that...
Yuva...
Yuva seemed...
active.
The...
admin above the...
picture post also says...
if you have any issues, give them a ping.
Which one?
Oh, real...
Kamana?
No.
Whitey.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Whitey?
So we're 2 for 2!
We're 2 for 2!
It's their name!
It's their fucking name!
That's insane!
He does it again!
He does it again, guys.
No, it's alright.
Guys, look.
It's their name in Discord.
Oh.
Okay, I see.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god.
Lime has changed.
This game.
This tournament has changed her.
This is, yeah.
Playing competitive games, it changes a person.
I was just trying to be helpful.
Next time, I'll let you struggle and ping admins that aren't replying.
Okay, they're adding another slot.
Okay, now you can get in here.
Alright.
Jay, get in here.
Start it up.
Yeah, NVC.
Oh, that was fast.
It said 7 minutes estimated...
and then just went instant.
What?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Hello.
I'm going to support.
I'm going to lowkey duty.
You are, apparently.
Which means I'll probably need to be on Zoom.
Yeah, Jay, you missed out on probably the most brain-rotted fest of all time.
You missed out.
I saw the portal drawing.
Oh, you saw the portal drawing?
Okay, good.
Just don't question how we got to that point.
No, I was watching the whole game.
Battle got so stressed when you guys said portal to the enemy spawn.
It was so funny.
Do I portal in their portal?
Oh, she whoops.
Oh, no.
Wait, what happened?
I want to get the rocket van out of here.
Oh, no.
I thought we're not betting anything.
Cody, am I allowed to iron fist now?
Am I allowed, Cody?
Because Cody doesn't want me on the fists.
Oh, sorry, I was muted.
I don't know, bro.
You got me killed a lot.
Very selfish.
No, what do you mean selfish?
Well, you would go in and I would E to you and then you would go out because you were scared.
You baited me quite a bit.
No, that's what you're supposed to do.
That's what you're supposed to do, though.
All right, man.
Sure.
Go for it, I guess.
Whatever.
Okay, all right.
Yeah, we could do a triple and then you do...
How about this?
You throw me in and we stick together the entire time.
Let's go!
Yeah, there we go.
We feed together.
You better not.
You better not throw me off the map or into the spawn.
I mean, it depends on how good you're doing.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh, yeah.
Trust me, trust me.
I would always throw you in somebody's face if I get the opportunity.
That's way...
Okay, the map just blew up my computer.
Hello?
Oh, wait.
Are you gone?
No, no.
I had the thing where it was loading up the map and it got all bright.
Now you're talking into a game.
Now you're talking into a game, bro.
That was crazy.
Bro, your game blew up and my ears blew up.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
I'll show you the clip later.
It's like I went to heaven.
I would love to see that.
I've never seen that before.
I've heard stories, though.
I got raptured.
All right, bro, hop on.
All right, I'm locking in.
Lock in.
We're going deep here.
I think someone's at the top left.
Careful.
Fire!
Yeah, Spidey, Spidey, Spidey.
Spidey on the top left.
Oh shit, nice.
Oh my god, I'm so low, though.
Oh no, I'm so healthy.
No, you're healthy, you're healthy, you're healthy.
So healthy, bro.
I got the thing.
Isolated.
Yeah, Spidey better be careful.
Oh, I'm not healthy anymore.
You're healthy, bro.
I guess I should be playing Luna here.
Adapt him!
Take him away!
Wait, throw me in.
Never mind, wait.
Come here!
I was playing with him?
Oh shit.
Ow!
Why did we bubble the Wolverine, bro?
I need you with me at all times.
Otherwise, I'm going to die to Spider-Man 100% of the time.
Speaking of Spider-Man, here he is.
I didn't know they had a Spider-Man.
My bad.
Yeah, I did not know they had a Spider-Man.
Yeah, this guy's been looking for me the entire time.
Okay, okay, okay.
So I need you to stay with me.
I'm here.
What are we going to do?
I don't know.
Oh my god, wait, you're right.
I'm just dead.
I'm coming for you, shut up.
Wait, bro!
You threw me to my death!
He just killed you anyway.
You hit the Z button.
No, you can hold me on your shoulder.
We can just hang around.
Like a parrot?
Yeah, I can be your...
Okay, this Spider-Man is a fucking homing missile.
I'm trying to heal everybody, holy shit.
I'm okay.
They ultied, just let them ult, just let them ult.
Damn unfortunate.
Bruh.
I couldn't hear it.
Don't worry, I'm alive.
We got five ults coming up.
We might need some more help with the Piety Man.
Y'all chill back a little bit.
I didn't kill him.
Oh god, the moon!
Oh, big slam!
Oh, right here, right here, right here.
Yeah, Moon Knight's in the front lines.
Oh, they're gonna die.
Oh god.
Oh no.
I fucked it up.
Genuinely, Spider-Man is fucking executing me, I don't know what to do.
I'll do it.
Okay, we're getting faults right now.
I'll kill the Wolverine.
I got terrained.
I'll shoot him.
Blast him!
I'll blast him.
We're on triple.
I can try to go on DPS.
No, no, no, no.
I'll do it, I'll be our lord and savior.
I can DPS as well, but I need somebody...
Who here knows how to support solid?
Spider-Man here.
Doki doesn't like my healer.
But I can show my healer.
Also, I just got salted.
I can show it.
Spider-Man's gonna come behind us right now, watch out.
He's dead.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god.
Am I dead?
I can block for you.
I have no shields anymore, no shields anymore.
Oh my god.
Moon spear!
We're getting absolutely...
I need to...
I feel like we're not doing enough damage.
And I feel like I want to go onto a damage dealer right now.
Yeah, go for it, go for it, go for it.
I have ult.
I'll do the support.
I'll do the support, I know how to play.
I'm going at him.
I have ult now.
We need a touch, we need a touch, we need a touch.
Yeah, we can touch.
I'm on it, I'm on it, I'm on it.
I'm on, I'm on, yeah.
Yeah, I'm going on as well.
Got the backline?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, we're all here.
That's massive, I think.
Oh, nevermind.
It looked like it.
They are all backing up.
Okay, well we got this corner.
I have the link.
We're good.
Oh no!
Oh my goodness.
Good God.
I'm bugging, I'm bugging, I'm bugging.
Wait, that's good, that's good.
Yeah, we're still healthy.
Sorry, I only just got it.
Yeah, I don't pick to work.
Fuck.
That's a decent pull.
Oh, Spider-Man!
I'm still touching, I'm still touching.
I'm rezzing.
Yep.
And then I have an idea.
Waiting for an idea.
I'm going to die here.
Nice.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh my God.
Heal each other, heal each other, heal each other.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
Spider -Man down.
I'm just touching the button, okay?
I'm not getting off.
Crystal One's up top.
She's pocketing this.
Oh, that's strange.
I'm one, I'm one.
Okay, Limu's alive.
Oh my fucking God.
I'm getting out of the fucking...
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Star-Lord?
Okay, we got it, we got it.
Sit on it, sit on it, sit on it.
We're just practicing triple tank.
It's all right.
Got this, got this, got this.
Spider -Man on healers.
Uh -oh.
I'm alive.
What is Mr. Spider-Man supposed to do against us?
Die.
Exactly.
Okay, all right.
Well, we did that.
We're back, we're back.
We're on board.
We're just gaming today.
Yes, sir.
Oh, I have ult?
Fuck, I'm...
I see a bunch...
I'm back.
Are you guys winning?
If we can't get strange, that's good, that's good, that's good.
I'm still on the point.
They all immediately...
I'm going for a big ult here.
I have ult in five, okay?
Are you guys winning?
No, no, no.
Kind of.
I don't remember.
Kind of, kind of.
Kind of, kind of, kind of.
Yeah.
So I might be doing some inspirational Adam gameplay at the moment.
You're letting him hold your SR hostage?
For content?
He is content.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm with you, I'm with you.
Oh, shit.
I'm one, I'm one, I'm one.
Okay, nevermind.
Gotcha, gotcha.
Yeah, that's...
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Nice.
Wait, what the hell?
We're fine.
Careful, the moon.
Oh my god.
I'm so nervous, guys.
I can't believe we made it to the finals.
In America?
I got the whole front line, but...
Okay, thank you.
We'll get finals, like, grand...
It's not grand finals, but it's like finals, and then we get grand finals.
Oh, Sambo!
I'm so nervous.
Oh my god, bro, he's just...
I went deaf in real quick so I could talk to you guys.
Yeah, we got some...
The first game...
Those first games of the day was very, very scary.
It was definitely very, very, very scary.
So, I am glad that, you know...
We made it past that.
Yeah, I made mistakes, but I also did some cool plays, I think.
Yeah, the first game was really rough.
We were just...
We had to figure out, like, what to play.
It's always, like, such a learning experience, like, when we can't play what we're used to.
And we had to, like, figure out, like, what would be best.
And then, I had to be more proactive in calling for swaps, you know.
Like, I'd be like, guys, we need to swap.
This isn't working.
We have to swap.
We have to swap this, etc., etc.
I'm glad that we did end up swapping the hell out.
And, like, I managed to, like, get past, you know, the pro player ego.
You know, like, the DPS ego, where they're like, I'm not the issue.
I have more kills.
I have 30 kills.
And I was like, no, Gomis, we need you.
You could have 50 kills right now.
I'm like, Gomis, you don't understand.
You might have 30 kills now, but you could have had 50 kills.
So that hell of a swap really, like, fucking clutched it for us.
Yeah, so I'm glad, like, people listened and we managed to get past that first.
And then I feel like because they saw, they're like, they can bleed.
They got them to, like, they got them to overtime.
Oh my God, Doki's team can bleed.
You know, the other teams are, like, super confident and stuff.
And it's just, oh my gosh, a lot of teams definitely did research on us, but we did research too.
Well, I did a lot of research last night because I went to bed.
I think I went to bed.
I couldn't sleep again.
You know how, like, I was, like, so, I don't know.
I think it's because it's the first real tournament.
So I always get super nervous when it's, like, the first real tournament.
But I think, like, if I do another Marble Rivals tournament, I'll definitely be, like, a lot less nervous.
Because, like, this is my first real tournament where I can, like, actually, like, show my skill and my abilities and stuff like that.
So that's why I'm like, ah, you know, that's why I'm like, oh my God, what am I doing?
Yeah, um, and I just hope, like, after this tournament, I definitely relax a lot more.
But yeah, I had trouble sleeping last night too.
I hit my third win last night.
Like, I, somehow, I managed to hit my third win.
So I, like, was not tired at all.
And so I was like, oh no.
So I had to try to force myself.
I had to force myself to, like, sleep last night.
So I think I went to bed at 11.
I also coughed a lot too.
Oh, I'm back, by the way.
I'm not walking the dog.
I was, I, like, coughed myself awake, like, I think, like, two times last night.
So, like, I think it was, like, once at, like, midnight.
Again, at, like, two, like, three in the morning.
So I'm like, oh no, I'm, oh no.
I think, like, since, like, I'm taking two days off, I might actually go to the hospital to get something, get, like, antibiotics or something.
Because, like, I don't care about the wait, four hours at the hospital.
Like, I need this gone.
And I, just because I'm taking two days off, I'm taking two days off starting tomorrow.
So, like, I won't be streaming on Monday, Tuesday.
So I have the time to actually go to the hospital.
Because, like, if you guys didn't know, like, in Canada, it's really hard to see a family doctor.
Because, like, they don't, they're not taking new patients.
And that's why I haven't gone to a family, like, I haven't gone to the doctors in a long time.
So I might just go to the hospital and just wait and be like, uh, hello, can I please, you know, uh, can I please, you know, get a, get a, uh, antibiotics please and thank you.
Yeah, yeah, I haven't had antibiotics.
And I've been just taking over, like, over the counter, uh, over the counter, like, meds and stuff.
Um, yeah.
So, like, for once, maybe I'll be able to.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Are they doing okay?
Uh, wait, uh, I'm wondering if I should, do I need to go on my main now?
I guess, like, I think after this, then it should be us, right?
I'm going to look at the challenge.
After they finish their ranked game, it should be us, right, guys?
I don't know.
I'm not paying that much attention, to be fair.
They're playing a game right now.
They're playing, oh, they're playing their one game at the moment.
Are they attacking?
They are.
Okay, I just wanted to know if we are, if we are, uh, who are they fighting?
Oh, they're fighting, oh, okay, I know who they're fighting.
They're fighting the team we knocked out.
Alright, uh, my screen is zoomed in, so we can't, oh.
We can't see the bars?
Wait, what do you mean, bars?
What do you mean?
What do you mean by bars?
I can't wait to, like, sleep after this tournament.
I can't, I can't wait.
I can't, I can't wait to sleep after this tournament.
I'm so tired.
I'm so very tired.
I'm, like, so tired now.
I'm, like, looking forward to it.
Oh, I just, I'm just happy, you know, whatever.
I'm happy with our current placement, you know.
Whatever happens, like, we made it really far.
It was, like, a hundred and twenty teams.
And, like, and, like, Naimu had to learn, like, several supports right off the, like, you know.
She had to learn new supports going into this tournament.
And then, uh, same with, like, Coney and Beto and everything.
So, like, I'm, I'm really proud of everybody for doing so well.
For making it, um, like, so far and everything.
Uh, yeah, um, no matter what happens from these games on, um, I'm happy with how far we went.
Yeah, we're all doing so well.
And, like, we don't, we're not, like, super passive aggressive.
Well, I am a little, maybe.
But I, I, I, that's, like, my weakness.
I get, like, a little passive aggressive.
Um, because, like, the competitiveness, fucking, the competitiveness of me just fucking does that to me.
Um, but, like, uh, um, I'm trying not to be, I'm trying to be more, you know, less.
I, I, I know I am really competitive and I get a little, a little passive aggressive sometimes.
But I'm glad we have, like, people in our team that ups the morale for everybody, too.
Um, and, like, to make sure, like, we're all, like, you know, even if things are bad, we still, we're not, at least we're not yelling at each other.
Um, or, like, shouting at each other and stuff like that.
Because I was watching, I was watching VOD POVs of other, the other, the people we fought against.
And, like, some of them, like, were actually yelling at each other and was, like, so, like, mean to their own teammates.
And I'm like, oh, thank God we don't do that to ourselves.
I was just like, oh, thank God we are not like that.
Because that's a heavy mood killer right there.
Yeah, yeah, that's definitely, um, I mean, yeah, one fucking team, like, self-reported their own teammate.
And got their team, like, kicked out, which was fucking great.
I was like, holy shit, what the f- they were in winner's bracket too.
I was so surprised, like, I was like, they're in winner's bracket.
It's not like they fucked up or anything.
They literally were, like, one of the better performing teams.
Because it's not like they, like, reportedly, like, reported somebody else.
I thought it was, like, another team reported them, but it was literally just a self-report.
And their team, the fact that their team name was terrible teammates was pretty funny.
Like, okay, like, the situation is funny, but, like, overall it's not that funny for the team itself.
But, like, it's a little funny when you think their team name is terrible teammates.
And, oh, they're getting diffed by Groot.
We definitely need to ban Groot.
I'm watching their- I'm watching their gameplay.
I'm watching their rank session right now.
They- we have- for some reason, we just have a Groot problem.
That's why, like, when we were playing rank, we were just banning Groot all the- we were just banning Rocket and Groot when we were doing rank last night.
We just- for some reason, we just have, like, a Groot debuff.
That's brief.
Oh, yeah, that's self-fulfilling prophecy.
Yeah.
I hope you guys are enjoying the Rivals tournament.
I hope you guys are enjoying the gameplay.
Because it is different from, you know, like, you know, we've done- we stream a lot of Apex tournaments, but Rivals is definitely- Marble Rivals as a tournament is definitely a lot different.
And I hope you guys have been enjoying it.
There's a lot more- obviously, there's a lot more people participating.
And it's a lot more coordination compared to Apex and stuff.
So, a lot more, like, talking and IGL-ing and comms and everything.
It's definitely very stressful, for sure.
But, like, I think, like, as a support player, it's less stressful for me versus, like, a DPS or tank, I feel like.
Because as a support player, I have much more- I have much more, like, safety, I guess?
To, like, not- Like, basically, my game-changing moves are things I can- are, like, my freezes and- But, like, nobody expects me to land these freezes and stuff like that.
So, like, if I- when I do land freezes, it's like, oh my god, that's, like, a bonus.
And then, like, obviously, like, ults and stuff.
It is, like- I think, like, the scariest has been...
I think, like, I don't know why, but- I don't know why, but for some reason, my ping for these games has been, like, wonky.
Like, weird.
I don't know why.
Like, I don't know if you guys know, like, I usually time my ult- Like, I see my ult going off, but, like, nothing happens.
And it's, like- like, I get, like- what's the word?
I get...
Like, I see the visual of it going off, but then it, like, interrupts and it's just- it's weird.
I don't know.
I've never had that happen.
And it happened to me, like, twice today.
We're playing- we should be playing East Coast.
But the fact that it happened to me twice was what's, like, really fucking weird.
Yeah.
It's a- like, I usually never have that problem, too.
The- yeah.
It happened, like, two times that- during the tournament.
Like, just today.
Like, yesterday was fine.
I don't know if I just have to time- like, I just have to be- I don't- I shouldn't time it, like, to the dot.
I should just- I should just, like, ult it the moment, like, I just do it more reactionary.
Because I don't- I do- I do it- I do do reactionary, but, like, I'm, like, a .1 second off of reactionary.
I still have my ult- no, I keep my ult because it wasn't an interruption.
It's weird, because it wasn't even- it's not even an interruption, because I still keep my- keep my ult.
Oh, they ran 3-3.
Coney stole my MVP last second again.
Oh my god, you guys did it!
That's true.
He did win the game for his team.
Oh my god, you guys- you guys did it!
You- you didn't see me at the end, bro.
I went foolish.
I got three solo kills.
I already did.
I don't know if they're ready or not.
This has been more than 40 minutes.
Yeah, this has been- let's- before you guys queue, let's check out- because, like, Maze's team is fighting...
Oh, the Maze's team has to- Yeah, they have to defend now, I think.
Yeah.
Because they're doing that- that game first, before they go to- like, they're finishing that game before they go to us.
So, they're- I believe they're- Oh, we're fighting Maze's team?
No, no, no, we're fighting Riggzy's team.
But- Oh, then why are they- I think because they want to spectate all the games.
That's why.
So, like, they're just- we're just spectating all the games and stuff.
I mean, we can double check.
I'll double check with them.
I'll be like, which- who do we add?
Do we add Whitey?
That's- that's his Discord username, by the way.
I got it to my chat.
Yeah, yeah, don't- don't trust- They've already yelled at me about it!
Little dokey!
Do we add- do we add- Michael called- called- said that to me, and I was like, wait, what?
Okay, I'm gonna add the user whose name is Whitey, by the way.
I'm not- I'm not pulling a lie move right now.
Hey!
Oh, no!
Uh-oh.
How- are we waiting for the loser bracket match to finish for our game?
Alright.
And then we'll know.
Or- or add any of the staff that's free.
Yeah, none of the staff are- I'll just add another staff member.
Do I have a second?
I just need to step away for a minute.
Yeah, yeah, we should have.
Alright, I added another staff member just to see if they say anything.
I wish we could add roles.
I'll be right back as well.
Alright.
Okay.
I think maybe- I don't know.
I think Mesa's team might defend as well.
I feel like if we just ban Groot, it'll be fine.
I don't understand why the enemy team doesn't ban Groot.
Oh, Whitey's typing a message.
Oh, yeah, we're waiting for Mesa's game to end before our game.
But they're- I mean, I don't think we can have time to queue another game because they're defending right now and they're doing pretty well defending.
Alright, I'm gonna swap my- I'm gonna swap my account.
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm gonna swap back to my main and then exist as a person again.
I'm gone.
I got a quick question.
My left ear has been blocked and it's not- like, I can tell it's just- I can't hear shit on my left ear.
How the hell do I fix this?
Wait, that- what?
Yeah, I can't- I've been- I've been having to deal with this for, like, the beginning of the tournament.
What?
I thought it'd go- I thought it'd go away by now.
Yeah, I don't know what it is.
I don't know what it is, actually.
Like, can you not hear anything at all?
Oh, no, I can still hear.
It's just really- Oh, okay, okay.
I was gonna say- On my left ear.
Have you cleaned your ears?
I did.
Oh.
So, I'm like- I'm like, uh, and I don't know what's happening.
Oh, blowing your nose.
I'm gonna do that.
Hold on.
What if he just, like, bursts his eardrums by doing that?
Oh.
Oh, God.
Oh, now I'm giving you that fear.
I'm doing it anyway.
She's in your head, dude.
Nope, that didn't do shit.
All right, let me clean my ear again.
Okay, we're having a lot of, like, hearing problems.
We're having a lot of, like, yeah, like, in the audio, for some reason, like, people just don't want us to listen to anything.
Like...
Okay, I'm gonna swap my account.
This is weird.
Goodbye, Medoc.
Oh, how are they doing?
It seems like they're doing pretty well against Riggzy's team.
Um, no, no, this is- they got- they got knocked out by Riggzy's team.
So, they're fighting somebody else now.
They're doing- they're in loser's bracket because of it.
They can come back to winner's bracket, right?
Yeah, they can.
If we get- it's whoever- it's either Riggzy or us that fight Maze.
So, if we fight- if we win Riggzy- the game against Riggzy, Riggzy's just gonna knock them out.
And then, we fight Riggzy's team again.
Or, I don't know, Maze's team might figure out how to fucking kill them.
Um, but, what- no matter what, we- I- but if we lose, we fight his team, and then we fight Riggzy's team again.
So, we might have a grand finals where we just fight Riggzy's team twice in a row.
Um, I think Maze is gonna defend this.
Yeah, they- they win this.
They win this game.
Let me log in.
Let me look at our bans during our scrims again.
And I'll paste the images for us.
Oh, 15 minutes.
Oh, 15 minutes till our- our game.
Fifteen!
Okay.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, I'm not nervous.
Nico, has I heard you talking about your ear?
Uh, I had my ear plugged up for, like, three months straight.
Yeah?
And, like, it was to the point where it was, like, making me dizzy and giving me a headache.
Like, and it just stopped one day.
Like, nothing fixed it.
It just...
Yeah, I'm confused about it right now.
It's- it's just- I just cleared out my ear and, like, oh, it's clean.
And then, oh, never mind.
Just, like, didn't do anything.
Were you sick recently, or?
No.
That's why I'm confused.
You might- Oh, you know what it was?
What?
Oh, I know what it is.
I think- I think, like, I plugged up my ear when I was sleeping.
And usually something like that happens.
Or, like, something related to that happens.
Ooh, I slept on my- my left side too hard.
Oh, no.
No- no air- Oh, no.
Yeah, no air flow to the ear.
Oh, boy.
I don't think- I don't think people want us to win.
Like- Wait, what?
Like, everything, like, the- everything is going against our team.
People just don't, like- even the powers beyond are, like, this team can't win.
It's not- it's not supposed to happen.
They're fighting against us.
I'm- I'm gonna grab screenshots of, like, our ban line against Rixie's team.
Okay.
So, just to remember what we did, because I don't fully remember.
I'm trying not to be too nervous.
I'm trying not to be too nervous, guys.
No, we knew, since the very beginning, Rixie's team was the strongest- was gonna be the strongest in the tournament.
Because, like, the first- the first scrim we played against- this was our very first scrim, too, as a team.
They, like- they banned Beto's Mag.
And then we got absolutely- we got, like, not destroyed- we got, like- okay, we sort of got destroyed.
Because that time, Beto could only play Mag, but now he can play other characters.
And then when we- when we- when we, um, figured out- When we figured them out, we started- we won all our scrims after that.
When we figured them out, because we scrimmed them twice.
And then the second time we scrimmed them, we beat them.
So, like, they are- they are a really good team.
They've been scrimming a lot, too.
They've been scrimming a lot, and they have a very strong team overall.
I want that OmNomNom team to lose after that- after that lobby talk.
They did.
They just lost.
They lost.
They just lost to Maze, yeah.
Oh, VTuber's a little slow, then.
The mainstream.
Yeah, they lost.
Yeah.
Which team lost?
Sorry.
OmNomNom.
This is like a weird passive aggression.
The Shrug Team.
Or Bro with a question- or a period.
The dot?
The period?
Yeah, the period.
Yeah, oh my god.
The full-settled Bro was a bit, yeah.
Yeah, he did too much.
Somebody to call for, yeah.
Like, I know, like, if, like, they had that happen, we'd say it- Like, we'll say it to our- to us, but we wouldn't say it to them.
Yeah, you don't say it in the chat.
It's like, oh, Bro, that's like, oh well.
But we wouldn't say it, so the other, like, they'll see it.
No.
There's a difference.
Yeah, there's a difference.
Like, we shit talk on stream, but we don't shit talk directly at them.
You shit talk in stream, it's not real.
Yeah, exactly, it's not real.
We're just clip farming.
Oh, we're going to lobby.
Oh, this is it?
Are we ready?
We go in the lobby, but we still have time.
I think they're going to play- they're playing this set out, and then they're going to...
They're dead, aren't they?
They won their match.
Oh, that was loser.
Yeah, that was loser.
You only get one game.
I'm trying to- I'm looking at- I'm trying to find, like, what we banned and stuff.
We went against them, and then we started doing Bucky bans here, I believe.
Yeah, this is it.
This is where we started winning.
This is the team lineup when we started winning.
I'll screenshot this.
Surely in losers finals we get best of three, right?
Losers finals is best of three.
Okay, good.
So if we lose this, it's best of three still.
Is it?
Okay.
We don't worry.
Okay, um...
Why were you on- wait, oh, because we got a mag unbanned.
I was wondering why- why did we have a Scarlet Witch in one of our games?
Why are they asking if we're appearing offline?
I have no idea.
Here, these are our ban lines.
I'm posting it for us.
Are we doing Bucky Sue, right?
And protecting Strange?
Or not protecting Strange, protecting the thing?
I believe so, yeah.
Because we always ban Bucky first.
Kill Bucky save thing.
Yeah.
Oh, it's this team, that's right.
Okay.
Alright.
There was one- we did a protect- oh, and then if they ban...
Oh, and then when they ban a thing first, we protected mag and wiped them.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's fine, because Betel can play Strange, I'll play mag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, Betel was on mag.
Doki, they think you're posting the end game screens.
I think they're freaking out.
Oh, no.
No, we are posting our scrims results.
That's gotta be very confusing.
They're like, you already fought them?
That would be like, oops.
It's like tagging the leader of the event, it's like, oh no, what are we going to do?
They already have their games!
We won!
Yeah, send them down to the loser's bracket.
Dude.
Oh, okay.
Alright, figured out our plan.
So you think running triple tank, triple support would be best against them?
Yeah, that's our... well, if they don't ban...
I think if they don't ban mag, we just...
Yeah, when they don't ban mag, we can run our double 2-2-2, because we full held them, remember?
Yeah.
We full held them when they didn't ban mag.
I remember, right, it was on...
And then they started banning mag again, and then they're like, Beto, you can't play the game anymore.
I remember.
We only went 3-3-3 when they...
I don't remember, why...
I think 3-3-3 is the strongest against them, though.
They don't know what to do when we go 3-3-3.
Unless they discovered an answer.
But here's the thing, they haven't scrimmed, though, with people that also did that.
Yeah, they don't know, yeah.
So we could go 3-3-3, because we absolutely countered them hard with 3-3-3.
But I think if mag is free, if we can play mag, I don't think we have to run 3-3-3.
Because we full held them with 2-2-2.
What were we waiting on?
Yeah, we did full hold them with 2-2-2 when we had mag.
That's if we... Oh my god, if they give us Namor and Luna and Starlord and mag...
Just everything, yeah.
If we just don't have bans, yeah.
Let's just do a competitive game where we don't even ban anything.
Let's see how it goes.
That should be the grand finals, no bans.
I wonder if we're waiting on... Are we waiting on...
Because they said add... Oh wait, you have the caster, right?
No, Gomez does.
Oh, the Ana one?
No, I don't have her.
Where's Gomez?
Is he still fixing his ear?
He might be.
Yeah, I think he's still fixing his ear.
I'm like pulled up his stream just to be sure.
Hello?
Oh hey.
You have the caster on your friends list, we have to join the lobby.
The Ana person.
Alright, hold on, I gotta swap accounts.
Oh, you're still on the other account?
Yeah, I'm bot reviewing someone.
You're bot reviewing our tournament?
We have a tournament!
Alright, let me... Oh, I thought you guys were in... Okay, those are your guys' mains.
Yeah, I'm on my main.
I'm ready, I'm ready.
Okay, so... Did you hear what we were talking about earlier?
About the ban?
I posted screenshots of our scrim bans.
What are we doing?
We're doing Bucky first, but we're talking about the comp.
Do we run 3-3?
Or if they don't ban Mag, should we run 2-2-2?
Because we full helped them with 2-2-2 when we had Mag.
And then when Mag is banned, we run 3-3.
Sorry, hold on.
I think I ate something bad because I'm feeling so nauseous right now.
What is going on?!
I don't know what's going on.
I'm feeling like trash at the moment.
Do you have any medicine?
I have Pepto.
I'll probably go drink that real quick.
Did you just start feeling sick?
It's like your stomach is not easy right now.
Yeah, it feels like I have to go to the bathroom, but not really.
But then also, if I think about food, I just...
Do you have to go to the bathroom right now?
Just don't think of food.
Think of, I don't know, portals.
Do you have Pepto?
Yeah, I can go take a quick Pepto.
What is going on?
I can't hear in my left ear.
I'm feeling nauseous.
What's going on?
I don't know.
Did you even leave the team in Africa?
Yeah.
No one wants us to win, guys.
I have some sparkling water.
I'm going to drink this a bit and see if it makes me feel better.
Apparently, the moment you rejoin the lobby, they're starting.
They're waiting for us at the moment.
Okay.
I guess not all of us join because they might start right away.
I'll just say Gomez is getting medicine right now.
We will let you know when our...
You go get your medicine.
I'll invite Choto in.
I'll be right back.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Did he use a Q-tip to clean his ears?
No way.
You're not supposed to do that.
I think he did.
Maybe that's why he had a headache, too.
Or he's feeling nauseous.
Oh, my God.
That makes sense.
I don't know.
Some of my chat said he might have used a Q-tip.
If it works, it works, I guess.
But the thing is, it didn't work, chat.
Here's the thing.
It's probably the tubes in his head, bro.
When your ear gets like that, your tubes are all fucked up.
Yeah.
It's not really a way to fix it.
Oh.
It might not be a Pepto thing, then.
You just got to like...
It's his stomach, too.
Yeah, I don't know about the stomach.
If he's getting nauseous, then that's affecting his balance.
It means he has a disease.
His ear is just congested.
I do EU, but was requested for this server.
Wait, what server are we playing on?
Does it tell us?
North Virginia?
Is the top right the server we're playing on?
Or is it for me?
Okay, thank God.
I was going to be like, what the fuck?
Like...
So, I had an ear thing a few months ago.
Like I said, it lasted really long.
And I tried to play F-Zero, and it made me sick.
Because of the balance thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've never been like that.
And I couldn't even sit up.
But it doesn't usually hit this quickly.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's actually insane.
It affects your balance, though.
Like the fluid and all the stuff.
It's like really bad.
I mean, if you get it for months, that's actually crazy that you got it for months, though.
Like, that's not...
You got that?
What did the doctor say?
Dude.
I went to the doctor, so it was plugged up for months.
But the problem is like, I go to the doctor, and they're like, yeah, it's not on the outside, so it's just your tubes.
And I'm like, alright.
What do I do about it?
They're like, well, because you would get ear infections a lot.
And they're like, well, there's just fluid in there.
Well, you do surgery.
And I'm like, I don't want to do that.
They're like, alright, well, just wait.
And then I did, and it fixed.
Just wait.
I saw the exact same thing.
Yeah, dude.
Isn't it bad?
Because I had ear tubes as a kid and got a lot of ear infections.
And then last year, I was dizzy and like bedridden for like two months due to like my equilibrium being off of my ears.
Oh, my God.
It's bad.
That sounds fucking... and it's because of the... and that's why you don't use Q-tips, guys.
That's why you don't use Q-tips.
No, it's not!
That's a different situation.
It's not bad, though.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was awful.
And like, the worst part is you can't like... like, I don't know if anyone sees this, but I went to the doctor and they were like, it looks fine to us.
And I was like, yeah.
And they were like, well, you could go see a specialist.
I saw the specialist and they were like, it looks fine to me.
I'm like, what?
Okay.
How much did you pay for it?
Dude, I paid to get an ENT.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
You didn't even like talk to the specialist doctor at that time?
No, the ENT wait was like four months.
Oh, my God.
I'm being told pickles are good with nausea.
Is that true?
I don't know.
Is it true?
Just Google it.
Don't eat food.
Just don't eat food, bro.
Just don't eat.
Yeah, just don't eat anything.
I feel like you might...
Oh, he's hungry.
I'm hungry, though.
I'm nauseous, but I'm hungry.
Wait, what did you eat for breakfast?
Just eggs.
Eggs and rice.
Oh, it may be bad eggs.
Oh, I may have just ate bad eggs.
Oh.
No.
Oh, no.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Do you like want to throw up right now?
Like, how bad is it?
No, I don't feel... I do feel like I want to throw up, but it's just like...
If I think about it, my stomach grumbles.
Okay.
Do we just want to blast through it as quickly as we can before you explode?
That would be nice.
Would you be able to aim?
Yeah, like, okay, I'll do R.
I'll do R.
Would you be able to aim, Gomez?
Yeah, I just... I don't think I can comm.
I think I just have to be silent.
Okay, I guess I'll pick up the comms then for us.
No, I'll try to, but it's like...
We only need to win two more sets.
Yeah.
I think there will be a... Wait, are they running us after?
I'm going to check the schedule.
It'll probably be a break.
Yeah, I was going to say, are we going to have a break after?
If we're going to have a break after, like, I think Gomez might need to try and get something for himself.
That was the sickness.
How did it not occur in the 40-minute break we had?
Like...
Yeah, honestly.
Like, you felt...
It just hit now.
Yeah, it hit, like, after the 40-minute break was up.
This 40-minute break actually screwed us all up.
Petal doesn't know how to portal.
I can't... We can't hear shit.
Fucking... I'm getting nauseous.
Will you be able to play the other tournament after?
I might have to tell him I can't.
Yeah, I think you might have to ask for a ringer because you're saying that you're feeling sick right now.
I have to go tell him.
Oh my god, they have winners finalists too.
That's so fucked.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
If we win this, it'll be a fucking miracle if we win past this set.
I mean...
Everything is against us.
I think it'd be an actual miracle if we get past this.
Showhole.
I mean...
Everybody's getting sick.
Everyone... Everything is not working.
I'm looking at Twitter, sorry.
Oh my god, I'll be so happy if we do get past this.
Disregard that, please.
Wait, what did you say?
I'm not saying it.
I'm not saying it again either.
I was like... I like how they added us like, are you guys okay?
But we just started.
Yeah, I was like, what?
We said we were alright.
I shine in darkness.
Alright, let's just do really well and win for Gomez.
Yes, for Gomez!
Yeah, yeah, I'm ready.
Okay, there's the magman.
Okay, Bucky, we're running 3-3.
I would like to save thing.
Yeah, oh yeah, save thing.
No, we're running 3-3.
Whenever they ban Matt...
Ban Bucky, save thing.
What if they ban out my strange?
We'll figure this out later.
We'll just save thing.
Thing is more important though.
Why is this happening now?
And then we ban Sue.
Wait, can't you play Groot?
Wait, they save Starlord.
They save Starlord.
Oh yeah, they have a Starlord player too.
And then ban Sue.
Ban Sue.
Loki.
Wait, we can still run 3-3.
Wait, I can name more Luna, right?
We could name more Luna.
Do we want to try that?
Can we ban Sue then?
Are you sure?
Okay.
Yeah, ban Sue.
We want Luna, Adam.
Luna, Adam?
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll put that Snowflake on...
On Gomez.
And then...
Yeah, we have...
We have name where...
Also, they don't know about Battle's training arc.
Yeah, they don't know.
They don't know the training weights.
Oh my god.
They're like, haha, we ban Magneto, he's got nothing now.
Oh god, that was a bad... Oh god, that felt so bad.
Oh, good.
Gomez, no!
What are you doing up there?
No, don't die!
Oh, that felt so bad.
Gomez, get like a puke-a-bowl or something.
Yeah, get like a trash can.
I don't know what that is.
Like a bowl that you can puke into without having to...
You think we could grab a sub outside of...
Like, get a DPS sub?
Because we might be able to get Ryan, right?
He's away.
Here we come once the set starts.
Yeah, but our DPS...
Our guy is fucking sick as fuck.
Yeah, I bet.
Oh, you missed a lot while you were wrapped up in that...
I can stomach throw, I can.
I can do it.
I don't know, it doesn't sound like it right now.
I'll...
I got it.
I got it, don't worry.
We might be able to get Ryan then if Gomez is like...
Yeah, but he has a... The tournament he's playing in starts in 15 minutes.
In 15 minutes?
Are you fucking... Okay.
Alright.
Yeah.
I'm lucky.
I'm a storm.
I think they're running Starlord here too.
I'm gonna really try not to stay...
Goddamn Tracer.
I don't know why I'm in... Overwatch terms are coming.
Nice.
Tracer's dead.
Strange, strange, strange.
Looking a little strange.
Strange one, strange one!
I think he's getting healed though.
Coney, back up if you have to.
I'm back, I'm back.
Where?
Where is the person?
There was a health bar through there.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I hear him.
He's by me.
There's a Mantis and a Starlord walking together.
Watch it, Strange.
Got you.
On my side, left side, left side.
They're trying to cheese.
They're trying to cheese with fucking Rigby.
Oh.
Let's kill this Mantis.
Got one.
Nice.
I'm healing, I'm healing, I'm healing.
We can walk out with Luna right after.
Yep.
Sorry, I had to.
Look down.
Nice.
Let's cook it, let's cook it.
Yeah, no mobs, no mobs, no mobs.
I love Coney, I love Coney, I love Coney.
Okay, they have Starlord ult.
Lime, you might have to get ready to...
I can hide.
Hide, yeah.
They're gonna have Starlord ult here and they have Storm ult.
Good shit.
You might save Storm ult for Lime's rez.
Did you throw up?
No, I'm good, I'm good.
You absolutely ate that egg.
Portal, portal, portal, portal, portal, portal.
I'm good, I'm good.
Where are they?
Over here, they're right behind.
They're gonna Starlord ult anyway, okay?
Oh no, we don't have an answer for that.
I got Link, I got Link.
Oh my god, that's weird.
They've used a lot, I'm gonna go hide.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, go find a rez, go find a rez spot.
They're looking, they might look for him.
They are looking, they are looking.
We might TP, oh wait, okay, I'm coming over.
I didn't get the rez, but just keep everybody up as much as you can.
Point, point, point, point, point, point, point.
I'm touching, I'm touching, I'm touching, I'm touching.
I'm on.
I'm on it too.
I died.
That's fine, I have to die here too.
Tried.
You can, you can, what should we call it?
We can get off the Atom just against that, because they're triple support.
Okay, go Cloak.
Or Suit, did we ban Suit?
Yeah, we ban Suit, we ban Suit.
We ban Suit so Beto can have, can have free...
Or Mantis, oh no, you can Mantis, you can Mantis.
Okay, okay, okay.
Just damage boost Gomez when you can.
Yep.
You have Snowflake, Gomez.
Push up if you can.
Thanks, push up.
Yeah, I'm trying.
I'm slept, I'm slept.
Nice, nice.
I'm on.
Storm's dead.
You ready?
Just make sure you damage boost Gomez on cooldown whenever he doesn't have it.
I'm doing it, yeah.
Yeah, he's got it.
I wanted more than that, take the one.
Yeah, they have to reset now.
Yeah, they have to reset, just go back to heart.
Alright.
I'll try and save.
I'm saving my ult mostly.
Okay, you might Mantis ult this if you have...
Oh wait, you don't have it, okay.
I don't have it.
Okay, they're gonna Strange Ult then after this.
They have Strange Ult.
I am ulting.
I'm boosted.
3, 2, 1.
Backing up.
I need heals.
Oh, we don't get dropped.
We have portal, just die Gomez, yeah.
Starlord's healing here.
Just die, die, die, we need to die.
Okay, nice.
I'm gonna TP behind the boxes on the point or...
Yeah.
They might Strange Ult the portal, so careful.
They have no support ult, they have no support.
We have Mantis ult.
Do we need Loki here?
They're eyeing, they're eyeing.
Loki's bad, Loki's bad.
He's on top, he's on top, he's on top.
Watch out.
We got it, we got it.
It's fine.
Okay, can we walk in with Luna?
Mantis, Mantis, Mantis ult, Mantis ult.
I got ult after this Cloaking Dagger.
Storm on, Storm on.
Storm's dead.
Okay, I'm ulting after that.
Nice, nice, nice, just wait.
Save your ult, save your ult, save your ult, save your ult.
I'm a hero.
I just had a good lineup.
I can chase him.
Gomez, peek me so I can give you Snowflake.
Okay, I think this is working pretty well.
I am also...
Do you think...
Do you think we match their trip support too or no?
We don't have Loki.
If you can go Cloak...
I mean, I see Cloaking Dagger.
Yeah, yeah, just do Cloaking, yeah.
We can do Cloaking on attack and see how it goes.
Oh, they know, they know.
Yeah, let's try it on attack, we'll try it on attack.
I got nothing.
I have it, I have it, I have one.
I have ult, I have ult.
Three, oh, eight, seven, six, five...
I'm whaling inside.
Four...
Three...
Two...
One.
You still got this?
I still have ult, I'm holding it, just one second.
He's left, strange.
He's sleep.
I'm ulting.
I got the freeze, I got the freeze!
Nice, good freeze, good freeze, good freeze.
Freeze, good freeze, good shit.
Keep them off, keep them off.
They're gonna go up top.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
I got you, I got you.
Okay, I'm looking at him.
Nice.
Good shit.
Nice!
Yeah!
Good shit.
Oh my god, that was scary.
Woo!
I don't like not having Sue for that.
Yeah, but they don't have a Sue, they can't put, they can't cancel our ult.
Yeah, that's nice.
They have a nasty Sue as well, so it's just like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we'll run trip support here.
Okay.
With Cloak, and see how it goes.
The only thing I'm worried about is like you guys not getting your ults fast enough.
It'll be fine.
We can...
What do we care about more?
Getting our support defensive ults out fast enough?
Or more heals to stay healthy throughout the fight?
I think like, we can win the Brawl fight if we have more heals.
I think.
Okay.
I think we have the stronger frontline.
Yeah, we TP, we TP in.
Okay.
Yeah, you guys all go up top.
They're gonna expect that.
So we can do...
Up top is better.
Yeah, high ground is always better.
Just bully them off of high ground.
If it doesn't work, if the triple support doesn't work, you just swap to a Namor.
And we feel like it's like a...
Yeah, if we don't have enough damage.
If we're not killing stuff, then yeah.
Skooma's alive.
Skooma, is he doing okay?
Yeah, I was gonna say, is he alive?
Yeah, he's fine.
I think he just doesn't need...
He's meditating.
Just let him chill, let him chill, let him chill.
Yeah.
When you stop moving, I'm like, is he dead?
No, I'm not vomiting yet, no.
Dead of pigs.
We're TPing.
I don't think I will vomit.
I don't think I will.
Alright, let's go on high ground.
Oh, there's Penny stuff.
There's Penny stuff?
I don't...
Okay.
They're mine.
No spider enough.
We can walk.
We got Penny underneath.
Tell me when to drop.
Drop.
Drop?
Got it.
Yep, got it, yep.
Storm low.
Storm, Storm one.
Storm got her ass.
I'm going on their backline.
I'm dropping too.
Luna one, Luna one, Luna one.
Okay.
Penny low, Penny low, Penny low.
Penny's low, Penny low, Penny low.
Yeah, yeah.
Strange, strange, strange, strange, strange.
Strange, strange, looking strange.
I'm low, I'm low, I'm low.
Yeah, yeah, Smurlur got away.
It's fine.
Smurlur here.
That's fine, that's fine.
He's zoned, he's zoned.
It's fine.
Good shit.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, good capture.
Good job.
Are you okay?
Oh, Gomez.
No, no, I wasn't good.
No, I wasn't good.
Gomez.
He like stood still for a second.
I saw that.
Is he still behind us?
He's still here, yeah.
I'm like focusing on Brigitte.
Okay.
I'm good though.
Oh, hey, I see him.
He's still behind us, yeah.
I froze Punisher.
But you can't do anything for now.
We used...
I can ult, I can ult him.
Have you...
Yeah, I'm going, I'm going.
Use it to aggress, use it to aggress.
Get the counter off of it.
They have Pun now.
I'm on their Luna.
I'm just gonna try to kill her.
Luna's dead, Luna's dead.
I'm going back.
Pun dead, Pun dead.
Okay, I died.
I got all my ulti.
Nice.
I'm damage boosting for you.
Good shit!
Nice, nice.
Just push Grag.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
We have Manta's ult for...
Okay.
Do not get Manta's ult.
Just play further away from us.
Do not get Strange ulted.
3 on point, 3 on point, 3 on point.
Yeah, 3, 3, 3, 3.
Get, get.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Use it, use it, use it.
You should live through it.
Yeah, you live through it.
Oh my god.
Strange low, Strange low, Strange low.
Nice, good ult, good ult.
Nice.
I got him.
How do you reload?
Use ult when you have it.
Keep walking to heals, bottle.
Keep walking to heals.
Oh, I forgot you can do that.
Oh, nice.
Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna.
Nice.
Woo!
Oh, good job, guys.
Alright.
Good shit!
That was tough for me, I'm not gonna lie.
Our entire team is just dying one by one.
That was like...
I feel like that was better.
Yeah.
That felt very good.
Yeah, imagine if Gomez was at 100%.
He's doing alright.
He's doing his best surviving.
I'm just gonna...
Just breathe.
That strange denial on the ult was great.
Yeah.
He was like, I got them all!
No.
It's like, surprise!
All I can think about is that if we win this next one and we have a break, you should try and see if you can throw up.
We have time.
Yeah.
If you throw up, you might be able to get the thing that's causing you nauseous out of your system.
See, that's the thing.
That I have a fear of vomiting.
So I was just like, that is impossible for me.
Gotcha, yeah.
Like, I legit have a phobia.
I see this a lot.
When I went to a trip over to Seattle, I got really sick from some food and I came back.
I had food poisoning for 12 days or around 2 weeks and I didn't throw up once because I refused to.
I just kept my stomach in the entire time.
Just got one more game, boss.
Yeah, just one more and then try and see if you can get something out.
Maybe you can try and shit, you know?
Yeah, that's true.
Just stay in the bathroom.
The other way, yeah.
When you stood still against Riggzy, you just gave up the 1v1.
Yeah, he was just still.
It was funny.
I was just feeling it.
I was like, no, I don't care.
You're like, I'm not trying.
I'm not 1v1ing you.
I'm going to reset my game since we're hitting a new thing anyway.
I'm going to hit the restroom.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, me too.
I'll take a bathroom break too.
I was going to invite everyone first.
I am here, so you can invite me.
Hey, look, my team is here.
Where's Coney?
I don't see Coney online.
He's muted.
Maybe he needs a second.
Oh, he restarted his game.
Oh, yeah, that was him.
Is Bettle okay?
He's deafened.
Oh, wait, did he go to the bathroom?
I'm looking up this history of why people say C9, because I have no idea.
Oh, so there's a team in Overwatch that played under the name Cloud9, and they kept forgetting about the point over and over and over, and it got to a point where everyone just kept typing C9.
So, the Cloud9, they forgot about point team.
I see Shur4 and Mendo in there.
Oh, yeah, if you say it in front of Shur4, he gets pissed.
He's the cause.
I only know C9's League team.
Oh, how about CS?
Not Overwatch.
Yeah, I was going to say.
It's been around for a long time.
Wrong game, wrong game.
Game, Gomez, just lock in for this game, and then you can reset yourself.
I will.
Alright, I'm back on.
Good adapting.
They tried to deny us 3-3, but they fucked up.
What the fuck?
Who's having a race right now?
Sorry, sorry, that was outside.
I live in the city now, so you're going to hear a lot of noises like that.
At least it's not police cars.
Do you have your window open and stuff?
No, not at all.
I'm just nearby, next to the balcony.
There's a big window next to me, which is pretty nice.
Good sunlight and all, but at the same time, it's a dull window.
Not the best soundproofing, so I hear a lot of shit outside.
A lot.
How are we looking, team?
Oh wait, they just sent that earlier, right?
Yeah, that was before the first game.
Are we all back?
No, I'm back.
I'm here.
Actually,
let me piss too.
Is this still 2 out of 3?
It's not 3 out of 5, right?
No, apparently it did happen in Overwatch.
It was not just CS, it happened in Overwatch too.
What?
What do you mean?
What are you guys talking about?
C9.
C9?
C9 originated in Overwatch.
I was there when it happened.
Well, I wasn't there, I was watching it live when it happened.
Yeah, it didn't happen in CS, it happened in Overwatch.
Were you spreading misinformation as an Overwatch player?
No, no.
Maimuu tried making me think it was CS.
No, you were spreading misinformation!
Sorry, someone in my chat, sorry.
Did you believe them?
I did.
I'm not supposed to believe chat, right?
He's in a vulnerable state right now.
Oh, that's so true!
That's so fucked up!
They're taking advantage of this poor man!
They can tell him anything.
He'll believe anything you say.
Oh my god, he's like, oh my god, he's vulnerable now.
Chat, get him.
Get me, get me.
Oh no, I'm cooked.
He's weak!
Whenever Shota's back, we'll be alright.
We'll also take some Alka-Seltzer after this.
Yeah, just take everything.
I think I need to take a painkiller afterwards.
We're all just falling apart.
It'll be fine, I believe.
Did you use Q-tips to clean your ears?
Gomez?
No.
Oh, okay.
Okay, what did you use to clean your ears?
I have a little syringe thing that lets you clear out your ears.
Oh, okay, okay.
I was gonna say a syringe?
No, I didn't use an actual syringe.
I have an ear cleaner.
Okay, okay, so it wasn't the Q-tips.
I'm ready!
Okay, let's R.
Ready, ready!
We R, R.
Okay.
Alright, let's get it.
Alright, come on, one game, one game.
Let's close it out here.
Go to Midtown.
Midtown.
Someone's like, you vaccinated your ear?
Okay.
Alright, same ban line.
Same ban and same line.
The Bucky main can't do too much.
Yeah, he doesn't know what to do when he can't play Bucky.
We love that for us.
Yeah.
Yay, one-tricks.
Yay!
Who would ever recruit a one-trick on your team?
That's stupid.
I know.
But if you teach the one-trick a trick, wait.
Nope, still that.
That's kinda nice.
They still don't want the mag.
Bucky.
That's crazy.
Gonna save things.
Fuck you outta here.
You know, I was kinda liking the Mantis.
Yeah, Mantis worked really well.
Mantis was good.
Yeah, if you get to play Starlord, then you play...
We play Mantis.
Oh, it protects.
They're gonna ban Starlord now.
Yes, Starlord kill.
Starlord's gone, guys.
It's over.
No!
Wait, that's fine.
That's fine.
I'll kill that.
What do we ban then?
Do we ban Cloak?
Wait.
Is this a triple tank spingle?
Yeah, we can run 3-3.
No, they ban mag.
We have strange.
We have strange thing that you can play.
Who are we banning?
Are we banning Cloak?
Or Hela?
Ban Cloak.
Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak.
Oh, ban Hela.
Oh, Hela?
Oh my god.
What do we ban?
You keep saying shit.
Ban what?
Oh, Hela?
Okay.
Hela's good.
So who do you want me on for now?
Adam?
I guess...
I say no-no.
They're probably kidding.
No respect.
I assume it's a joke.
Okay.
I think it's a joke.
I mean, maybe not.
I hope it is.
Do you want me on Adam for now?
No, no, you on Sue.
You on Sue.
Sue?
Okay.
We need to know if you were serious or not.
I can also do the Mantis if we need.
I think we should be fine on healing now.
Since they gave me Loki back.
Should we ask if they're serious or not?
Wait, we need to know...
That's serious.
If you are not respecting ban...
I still don't know what's happening.
Respecting ban, we call for restart.
Alright.
I'm done with that.
Okay.
Okay, we restart then?
No, they're not.
Okay, we restart.
Oh, okay.
All it takes is a little bit of threat.
Yeah.
Yeah, because like...
What?
I don't know.
I feel like it's not that big of a deal.
If someone forgot to ban on the other team, then I would be okay with it.
Yeah, of course.
I'm trying to make sure you guys are okay.
Strange.
I got you.
Alright.
He's got a Mantis pocket on him.
Yeah, I'm trying to keep you up.
Got it.
If we have enough heals, I can go Mantis.
But we'll see for now.
Yep.
Might yep up.
Got slept, so that's down.
I'm still bonding for our kill.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I got pulled in.
You guys are getting really low.
I don't have soul bond, so...
We have, we have, we have.
I got it, I got it.
Stay near him, stay near him.
They're gonna hide, they're gonna hide.
Yeah, I don't have soul bond yet, I don't have soul bond.
Backing out a little.
Only got me.
Nice, we're fine.
That's fine, you're fine, you're fine, you're alive.
Coney, you're really far from us.
Yeah, I know, I'm trying to come back.
Oh no.
I had the full lineup on me.
Oh, they stopped, they stopped.
I'm soul bonding, I'm soul bonding, I'm soul bonding for you.
I got left ult right after this.
Okay.
They trolled!
Oh my god, they trolled!
Wait, did I hit him?
Yes, you hit him when he broke the...
I'm one, I'm one, I'm one.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
We have, we have rez if you die.
I have claw bolt.
The string is low, the string is low.
The string is back and the string is at full HP now.
I got the full back one.
String, string, string, string, string, string, string, string, string, nice.
Nice.
Very good.
I can run her down.
Get the mantis again, get the mantis, she's one.
Got it.
Nice.
What did they use?
They have storm ult, so we'll have to...
Lime, get the storm ult.
Yeah, you react first, you react first.
Did they change ult?
I know.
Yeah, they did.
They did, they did.
They're gonna have their support cycle soon.
Okay, run for Lime.
Okay, I'll keep you up, I'll keep you up.
Okay.
I can't keep him, I can't.
Okay, okay, they pulled out their support ult.
They pulled two support ults here.
Thank you!
Nice, good job, good job.
Oh, I pushed them!
I pushed them into your thing, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Okay, I got back.
We have portal, we have portal.
Oh no, I actually pressed left click, that's my bad.
I killed one while I did it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got there.
Oh, he's portaling, he's portaling, he's trying to portal block.
Just get out, get out as fast as you can, get out as fast as you can.
We have portal.
He got me, but I just went through the portal because I'm invisible.
I'm just standing here.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm on it, I'm on it.
I didn't know you guys were there fast enough, sorry.
Fuck.
Nice, good job.
I soulbonded like I said.
I have a snap though.
That's okay, that's okay.
I got a snap again.
Storm's low.
I'm here, I'm here.
Yeah, I see her, I see her.
Nice.
Mantis, mantis, I got mantis.
Mantis, yeah, I see mantis.
Nice.
Gotcha.
Holy, bro.
What a hold.
Good shit, great hold.
We got it back, yeah.
Oh,
come on.
That battle clutch was so good.
That was a good clutch, yeah.
I think we're good.
It's kicking in.
Hell yeah.
Alright, coach.
I'm good, I'm good.
Alright.
Dude, the play where I pushed them into Coney's ult, it looked like it was going to be something massive, but then it just didn't end up that massive.
Fuck, man.
You're just like, no!
I was so scared because I was like, oh, that's five.
And I died for it, so I was like, alright, my team cleans this.
And then...
Yeah, we didn't get too much of it.
It felt so good though.
That's alright, we didn't lose.
If we lost, I'd be flaming you guys.
I had some really bad shit that game.
It was like a .20 seconds left when we stepped on from the point.
Yeah, that was crazy.
And you were so lucky.
Shota and I were alive, so we kept you up with like, Solvan and Emo.
Yeah, dude, I jumped on their Eisa.
Yeah, yeah, we like, kept them alive through everything.
It was so fucking scary.
And we have the DPS too.
It was really .20?
It was really low.
It was real low.
Alright, let's do it.
Free ult charge here.
We got them on this map.
Yeah.
We just need one point.
Damn.
Oh, I got absolutely shredded there.
Still top.
That's alright, we're still pushing.
That's fine.
I just don't have rez though.
I'm keeping you up with my...
...snaps if I can.
And I get it.
Can someone heal Gomez real quick?
Mhm.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I got him.
I soulbonded, I soulbonded, I soulbonded.
I like that shit.
I got you.
Tracer, Tracer, Tracer!
Nice!
Yo, okay, we go.
I don't have anything.
I got all three backline.
Coming back, coming back.
I have no soulbond, I have no soulbond.
Look at that, look at that, look at that.
All dead.
I need a heal back here.
Got her?
I win it, yeah.
We had no support ults there.
You only have low heals, you only have low heals.
Yeah, we just build ults.
I have ults up.
It's fine.
Or, I will soon.
Okay, of course they're all up.
Yeah, got them.
We have one of the ults first off.
Pop it when this is over?
Yeah, pop it when it's over so we can get another support ult off.
I got the whole backline!
All of them!
Nice, nice, nice!
Oh, he's right.
I went to the one person that was inside the ult.
I still bonded us.
Reset, reset.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get out.
Alright, resetting.
I'm just dying, I'm just dying.
Okay.
Yeah.
We can TP.
Just die, just die, just die.
We TP, we TP.
Die and TP.
Yeah, that's okay.
I have rez too.
You guys use TP, I walk over because I have rez.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
We also have lime ult.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
TP, TP, TP, TP.
I rez, I rez.
We should TP behind them, right?
Yeah.
I'm gonna ult you too, okay?
Do you want me to ult or just let people die for the rez?
I'll die for the rez.
Yeah, die for the rez.
Okay.
Where the fuck am I?
Oh my god, I got...
I got Agamotto'd.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
I still bonded, I still bonded us.
Good, good, good.
I'm ulting.
Nice, nice, nice!
Oh my god!
They didn't expect that shit!
It's the big episode!
Three, three, three, three, three, three!
Holy moly!
Oh, we died, we died.
Okay.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay, our Dr. Strange one trick has this.
Push up, push up, push up, push up.
The invisible woman ult into the surprise Dr. Strange ult.
Did you walk up and ult it or did you fly up?
I flew.
Oh my god, look at that, the trading!
Oh, Mr. Dootrick did it!
Oh my god, the Dootrick!
Holy shit!
His second trick is even better than the first!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it paid off.
Two weeks!
All it took you was two weeks to learn that.
That's crazy.
Good shit.
Put in the work.
Finals!
Let's get it!
The finals, the grand finals!
We made it!
We did it!
Yay, we did it!
We might actually play RIGC again, too.
I'm so dead right now.
Okay, go fix yourself.
Go do something.
Yeah, something, something that works.
We'll win this finals.
Yeah.
Is finals after the losers finals?
Yeah, it should be.
I can confirm.
Well, it has to be because we can't play at the same time.
Yeah, they have to.
Yeah, obviously.
So they have one match, though, right?
Or...
We have at least one.
More drugs, I'll be back.
Alright, let me look at it.
Yeah, I'm gonna be right back as well.
I'm gonna stand up and walk around.
You gotta cool down after that.
I'll allow it.
It says the winner's final is first.
Yeah, losers semi-final.
Oh, the grand finals.
That's winners finals, I promise.
Yeah, we were winners finals.
So they're doing losers semi-final.
Wait, what's losers finale?
What the fuck is that?
That's losers finals, probably.
Wait, let me look at the chat.
It's winners finals, then losers finals, then grand finals.
The fuck?
That's so confusing.
You guys don't know tournament, bro.
Okay, so what it is, is both the teams that won every set play.
That's what we just did.
Then the loser of that goes into losers.
And then the winner of the whole losers bracket faces us again.
Yeah.
And then we have to lose two sets.
Ah, I see.
We play them, but we haven't lost yet, so we get two sets.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So now we just wait a while.
Why does it say losers finale twice?
I don't know.
Then they messed up the schedule.
They messed it up.
It should be flipped.
Oh, wait.
Let me look at the schedule.
Yeah, look.
It says grand finale at the end.
But then there's losers of the grand finale that plays after for third place.
No, that makes sense.
Oh.
Yeah, no, because the two losers will play each other.
The winner will play us.
And then it'll be one, two, three.
Sorry, I'm a little special today.
We play the king of the losers.
No, you're good.
Yeah, the king of the losers.
Oh, we're playing the king of the losers.
Okay.
Guys, I don't get it.
Can you draw it and paint?
I thought for a second you were going to say guys.
It was that kind of voice.
I got really scared.
I was like, Bettle, what happened, Bettle?
Dude, we are so far behind schedule.
Look at the time.
Oh, my God.
We're in grand finale.
Grand finals.
I was like, yo, with the timings, I can probably stream afterwards.
No, unlikely.
Wait, we have a long time before our next game.
Yeah, is it ranked time again?
I mean...
I just want to chill, I'm not going to lie.
I don't really want to play anymore.
I think it's better to chill.
Give Go Gomez time to chill, too.
Yeah, Gomez needs time to chill.
Yeah, I mean...
I mean, we made it to grand finals, guys.
We made it to grand.
Yeah.
We earned it.
We earned it for a second.
The whole world is against us.
We actually practiced so well the past couple of weeks.
Because the first time we fought and scrimmed against them, it felt really tough.
Yeah, we were getting absolutely demolished.
We got mauled.
The 3-3 was kind of like a...
Maybe a crutch or just like...
Because it wasn't very flexible, since we had to stick with that to deal with them.
But now, it's like we actually managed to deal with it properly.
Yeah, yeah.
We all learned more, too.
It was like two weeks of practice.
It took us two weeks to figure everything out, which is crazy.
We nearly did like a boot camp.
Yeah.
Alright.
Let me go to the bathroom.
I'll be back.
It's funny.
The whole world is against us.
Everybody's getting sick.
PCs are breaking.
I really don't know what mine was about.
It was like twice in a row when it's never happened before.
And it's not happened again, Touchwood.
So it's just like...
Yeah, the amount of times...
We've asked for like...
Give us a sec, guys.
Something's going on.
I had to threaten...
I had to threaten that team.
Like, don't respect me, restart.
Alright, I'm here.
Are you okay?
We have a lot of time before...
How much time?
They have to run the best of three for the loser bracket.
Oh, boy.
Alright.
So it's Mace versus Riggzy's team again.
Okay, that sounds good.
Yeah.
So, are you sure you're okay now?
Do you need to...
Yeah, I'm gonna just chill and...
This guy's been asking for a VOD review for like the past few days.
Like, he's been like, make a channel point system for VOD review.
Like, please, I want it.
And it's like, okay, just ask me.
You don't need to...
I don't need to make a channel point thing.
It's like a...
I'm gonna just do that for now.
Are you sure you're gonna be okay for that?
Yeah, it's just reviewing.
Alright, don't throw up mid-review.
Oh, no, I don't feel like vomiting anymore.
I just feel like shit.
Yeah.
That's it.
Alright, you guys do that.
I'm gonna do a sponsored stream.
So, if anybody wants to come by, I get more for every viewer.
So, I'm gonna play some Mecha Break.
If anybody wants to play Mecha Break.
Alright, I have to play it for an hour.
So, I'll see you guys in an hour.
Yeah, it's a bounty.
Oh, shit.
Tell me how much...
We got an hour break.
I'll tell you later.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
I'm just gonna chit-chat for a few.
Yeah, me too.
I'm gonna chat on my stream then.
I'll be chill.
I might watch the...
The loser bracket then.
Yeah, it's Mace vs.
Riggzy's team.
Is anyone else watching it?
We can all watch together.
I'm watching it.
I'll watch it together.
Which channel is it on?
While I do the VOD review.
Which channel do we watch?
I mean, there's the Marble Rivals channel.
There's Mace is streaming it.
I believe.
I wanna watch it real time.
Yeah, I mean Mace is not...
There's no delay on Mace's side.
I feel like we're gonna fight Riggzy's team.
I feel like...
Riggzy's team 2-0'd them.
So, like...
I don't know.
Because if I'm gonna watch...
I feel like I might watch Riggzy's team just to see how they do.
Let me see.
Oh, Riggzy's streaming.
Okay.
I, like, open up Riggzy's...
I open up Riggzy's stream.
And they're like, This Adam fucked us up.
Their revives had too much value.
That's me.
Those were crazy rezzes.
Yeah, those were really good rezzes there.
Yeah, like, me just walking over.
I was just, like, strolling over with the revive.
At the end.
It was really funny.
The revive into the sualt to hide us.
And then fucking Strange just comes out like, Surprise, motherfuckers!
He just comes out of the portal and is like, Here's my ult.
They didn't...
They did not like my Adam.
That's right.
I'm not a one trick no more.
I haven't been since season 0.
Hahaha.
Let's see.
I've evolved.
That's funny though.
That's so funny.
I didn't think my...
I didn't think my Adam...
I didn't think my Adam was...
That good.
So it's funny that people think...
Like, it was scary.
Hahaha.
That's funny.
I didn't think it was...
I honestly didn't think it was...
I don't play Adam that much.
Honestly.
I only pull him out when, like, it's meta.
When it's meta and, like, we don't have an Adam player.
Like, if we have a comp that needs it.
I have a high win rate on Adam.
I do.
But they haven't started their game yet.
So, I'm just waiting for it.
I've always had a high win rate with Adam.
Since, like, I'm pretty sure.
Right?
Statistically wise.
Not...
Okay, I played, like, one game.
Look at that.
My...
Hahaha.
Look at that.
100% win rate.
Hahaha.
And I think I played more.
This one was not that great though.
This one was not.
Season...
Like, I had a high win rate on Adam.
But then I had to play him a lot at one point.
Look at that.
My 100% win rate.
Wow.
Wowee.
Hahaha.
And then my 100% win rate on Luna.
She's so cool.
Hahaha.
Wowee.
It's a sign.
And my win rate's...
I mean, my Mantis win rate was really good too.
And then...
There's a...
Hahaha.
My Rocket Raccoon win rate.
Yeah, this is the reason why I don't play these two characters very often.
Why am I low-key here?
Yeah, I mean, it's alright.
5, 6...
Cloak...
Luna...
That's a high win rate for Luna.
I'm glad.
I'm glad I started improving more and more.
From this win rate...
This is a good win rate.
To this win rate.
I mean, they banned Adam and Luna?
They're fucking stupid.
That frees up our entire team.
That frees up...
That frees up our entire team to play the best they can play.
And literally, we have Sue, Cloak, Adam...
Oh wait, not Adam.
They banned Adam.
We have Sue, Cloak, and...
Where are my other supports?
I guess Rocket.
And I can still play.
I can still play stuff.
And low-key.
And Mantis.
Yeah, we can run Mantis too.
Let's see...
I feel like they're just going to always try to give Riggzy Star-Lord.
As much as they can.
Alright, let me see.
Let me write this.
Waiting for match.
Watching the...
Watching the loser fight.
Alright, here we go.
I'll just do this.
We are in Grand Finals.
I'm watching the loser finals right now.
I think the moment we get rid of Sue, it gets even easier for us too.
Because they have a Sue one trick.
What POV?
There's Mace, Riggzy...
I'm watching Riggzy right now.
Just because...
I think we're playing against Riggzy next.
Because Riggzy 2-0ed Mace.
But if Mace wins this round, I'll swap my POV to Mace's stream.
I'm watching Riggzy's team just because...
Just because I think we're fighting them next and I just want to see how they play.
No, none of them stream on YouTube.
I think I'm the only one that streams on...
Me and Beto are the only ones that are streaming on YouTube for this tournament.
I mean, there might be others but...
From what I know, in the Grand Finals...
Or like in the Finals.
They like to TP the point for Koth.
Watching it.
That's funny.
Riggzy's like, Why is there so many people watching my stream right now?
And then it's just us analyzing their team.
HAHAHAHA We're just watching.
We're just figuring out their team.
Commentate over it.
Oh wait, Mace got a pick.
Wait, Mace, they play Thing.
They're playing Thing and...
I think Coney's a better Thing player though.
So I'm not.
Have they learned how to play against this team?
Wait, they're running Loki?
That's interesting.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
I don't know if they're bad at domination though.
They could just be like...
Cause I know their last...
Oh my god, he already has ult.
That's crazy.
He already got the Starlord ult.
I know...
I know Coney's a better Thing player.
The thing is...
Joe... I think that's Joe, right?
Joe has been only playing Groot for the majority of the game.
So if we put...
He's not gonna be like...
He's not gonna be comfortable on the character.
So I know for sure that...
Since Coney's been playing it this entire tournament, it'll be fine.
Yeah.
I'm glad my IGL has been good too.
During tournament.
Especially when I have to pick up the slack.
Now that...
Gomez is like literally dying right now.
Like...
Yeah.
Gomez is like dying so I have to pick up the IGL.
How's my voice?
Not the best right now.
It's not like painful or anything.
It's just like, you know...
It's just like...
You know, I sound like I'm about... I'm gonna die.
Like...
But like, my throat feels...
Like, I feel okay, but I know like...
My throat is not...
Not okay.
Yeah, that Stray Angel was...
Yeah.
That Stray Angel was a little special.
I don't know why they're playing Wolverine.
The Wolverine has no value.
Their Wolverine has actually no...
Wait, what were their ban lines?
I'll see their ban lines later.
I don't know what their ban line was.
So like... Cause like, Rixie has played against Mace's team twice already.
So...
They know the ban line for Mace's team.
So I'm curious...
What the ban line is.
No, I feel like...
I feel like the Wolverine has no value.
The Wolverine actually has no value for this team.
Oh...
That's a huge Stray Angel.
One of the bans was Bucky.
I mean...
This team has Bucky one trick.
Like, we knew instantly that...
The moment we got rid of their Bucky, we started winning against this team.
Yeah.
Okay, yep.
Okay.
Yeah, Rixie's team might win this.
Uh...
Mag and Groot.
I mean, that makes sense.
We were gonna ban Groot against Mace's team.
But we talked about it.
And we were just gonna ban Groot on Mace's team.
And then...
And then, like...
The second ban would be like whatever...
Would follow...
Well, Rixie is like their Gomez.
Rixie's like a one above all Star Lord player in rank.
Uh...
I wanna see what their ban line was.
What was their ban line?
What was Mace's ban line against Rixie?
Does anyone see it?
Uh...
Bucky and Cloak.
Okay.
Cloak?
That's interesting.
I would just fucking ban two.
I don't know why I would ban Cloak.
I'm also one above all.
Yeah, but I'm a support player.
My impact has less of an impact versus a DPS player.
I don't have like that big of an impact versus a DPS.
I think solo support queue is like one of the hardest queues in rank.
It's like in Marble Rivals, you can only enable your team as a support player.
Um, as like...
You know, you only enable your team like...
As much as you can with what you have.
And Mace is like, yeah.
Mace is a one above all tank player.
They're like... They have like a really strong... They have a strong DPS lineup too, like Rixie's team.
Uh...
Cause the thing is, their Eternity player...
Um, they put their weaker players on support.
So, their support line is the lower ranked players.
While it's like me and Gomez are like DPS and support.
I'm just trying to enable Gomez to do as much as he can with what I have, with like Luna.
And my position in like trying to make sure I stay alive so my team can live.
Maybe... I hope they... Maybe it'll be cool if they ban Adam.
That gives us a free ban.
Like, I'm a better Luna than an Adam player.
But if they just ban Luna and Adam, then they're just... They're actually throwing.
They're throwing if they ban Adam Luna.
Because, um...
Because that leaves our whole team to play what they're comfortable with.
Oh, they're running... Oh, they're running Thora now.
Adam needs a rework?
Adam's so strong.
Right now.
He's really strong.
I don't know if you guys know, like, Gilbert Noodle or whatever the fuck...
Gilbert Noodle.
But like, he was like the last remaining Adam player last season when Adam wasn't meta.
And then people were like, oh no, Gilbert.
We got Gilbert because he's an Adam.
But this season, he's like top 10 now.
People would avoid Gilbert because, like, we're like, why are you playing Adam last season?
And now he's top 10.
Or he... I saw him in top 10.
Because of the Adam buffs.
It's like, oh no, it's Gilbert.
And the thing is, Gilbert can play a really good Wolverine too.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I remember fucking avoiding him last season.
I would avoid him last season because I didn't want a fucking Adam player last season because it wasn't meta.
I was like, can you please at least go Cloak?
Yeah.
He was literally the last Adam one trick in the fucking game in Eternity.
And now, like, he's like, who's laughing now?
Look who's laughing now.
No, I'm a meta slave.
I've always been a meta slave.
I mean, even Kurova, who's like, quote unquote, the number one Adam in NA, didn't even fucking ditch Adam for Sue.
Like, it was like the fucking number one Adam in NA.
And even he fucking stopped playing Adam last season.
All he did was play fucking Sue.
Yeah.
I mean, I just play characters.
I don't care about like, I don't care about like, oh, I like playing this character more.
I just care about gaining points because it makes me happy.
You know, I just, I just wanna, I just wanna be high ranked.
That's it.
I just like being a meta slave.
Oh, that was a sick E to the health pack.
That is so smart.
I can never be a DPS player, like, in a hero shooter.
The E to a health pack.
Like, that is actually really smart.
I remember, like, I was watching a stream, a DPS player stream, and when you're a support, you don't explore the map, you know?
So, like, when you're, when you're, like, when you're, like, a support player, you're usually just, like, you know, with your full team.
But DPS players have to, like, have to play around the entire map to their advantage.
So, like, I remember I was just, like, I would be, like, I watched this person's stream and I was like, where the fuck is he?
I was like, this, I was like, where is this in the map?
This existed?
So, there's, like, a place on, what was it?
The low-key map.
That's the low-key map with the cart.
And, like, at the spawn area, if you go right side, there's, like, a whole new area there.
And I didn't know it existed.
I was like, where is this person?
I was like, where are they?
There's so many places in the map that I never knew existed.
Like, I didn't know it was a real thing.
Why is Gomez dying?
He ate bad eggs, we think.
We think he ate bad eggs.
You know, if the tournament didn't get pushed 30 minutes, he would have not eaten and things would have been okay.
Yeah.
So, like, we hope that, you know, he doesn't die.
It's 30 to... Okay, Grand Finals is best of 5, so we have to win 3 matches.
That's scary.
3 matches is a lot.
Wait,
did they ban Luna, right?
Did they try to ban me out?
Oh, they did!
They did.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, that's funny.
They banned me, they tried to lock me out, and then I went at them.
And they're like, just looking at them.
I don't even remember getting target banned, not gonna lie.
All these games blurred together.
Okay.
I explained all the shliz to Beto.
Thank you for the super chat, Winter.
Thank you, thank you.
I explained what?
We have an advantage?
I don't know, actually.
I don't know if they're doing, like, actual pro tournament.
I don't know if they...
Because, like, okay, if we're in the winner's bracket, we get a reset.
I can say...
Okay.
Is this, like, real tournament?
Real pro tournament format?
Where if they win three, we get a reset.
Since we are in winners.
Or is it just...
Regular.
Or is it...
Or is it just not like that?
I don't know!
I was like, I was like, or is it just not like that?
Wait, Mace's team is putting up a really good fight.
I get reset?
Is this a real tournament or do you guys suck?
No!
I didn't mean that!
Yeah, but I don't know if it is.
I don't know.
Toxic?
How is it toxic?
I'm just curious.
I mean, like, they are doing best of one for losers.
So, like, could be different.
We're definitely over time, though.
Okay, I'll add the...
Add...
Real...
I'll add the admin.
Yes, they said so on stream.
I wasn't watching stream!
I had my own stream to do!
What do you mean?
Yeah, ask better.
You want to know the format so bad, I had to put it on paint.
Winter, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yippee, grand finals.
I'm just happy we made it to grand finals.
I'm so happy.
Our practices... I'm so happy our entire team was like...
Our entire team worked really hard and scrimmed, you know?
They could have been like, no scrim, you know?
But, like, everybody was super open to scrimming and stuff.
And I feel like our... And everybody was, like, practicing and ranked together.
And, oh yeah, Rixie is looking bad for Rixie.
I might have to swap.
Sorry, Rixie.
If you lose... If they lose this round, if they lose this point, I might swap to Mace's POV.
Sorry, buddy.
Yeah, this team is great.
Yeah.
I feel bad, though, that we couldn't put Jay in for today.
Like, it just, like... It was just... Beto was just in his groove.
We just didn't want to mess up the groove.
And we couldn't sub out, like, things, too.
Alright.
Swapping POVs.
It was... It was a close game, too.
These match... Them...
We'll see how...
We'll see, like...
I don't know if it's because their team is good at domination.
That's the thing.
Their team might just be good at domination.
But, like, Mace is doing so much on Strange, though.
I'm watching Mace's POV right now, just to research.
But what ban line did they do, then?
What was Rixie's ban line against Mace?
Mace's team chat?
I'll write this down.
I'll write it down for us.
Mace ban line.
What was their ban line?
If anybody knows.
Just so I can write it down for my team.
Because we didn't research Mace's team a lot.
We didn't research it too much.
Bucky and Cloak.
No, like, when they... What did they ban against him?
They banned Groot.
Mace ban line.
Groot.
And Mag.
Okay.
People banned...
People banned Groot and Mag against Mace's team.
Okay.
I'll write that down.
We'll see how this goes.
I'm not listening to it.
I'm swapping POVs.
I'll give... If I have to, I'll give the Fleshtuber the view.
He lost my view now.
You know what?
Mace lost my view.
I'm not watching him now.
He did that to himself.
Actually...
There's like so... A lot of their teams are streaming it.
Yeah.
He lost my view.
I got filtered.
It was muted and I still got filtered.
Because he put it on the screen.
Hahaha.
He put it on his... Like he put the text on his screen and I got filtered.
I'm out.
Okay.
Yeah.
We get reset.
If we lose the best of five, we get the reset.
Because we're winners.
Okay.
That's cool.
So as long... So we have like two chances.
Okay.
That's good.
Oh my god.
This is intense though.
Wow.
Oh.
I'm just happy we got so far.
Yay.
I'm so happy.
Guys.
I took this very seriously.
Yeah.
I'm just really happy, guys, that we did really well.
Because no matter what, we're either first or second.
And I'm okay with that.
It was a very rough start.
I honestly, I was so worried in the beginning.
Because of how rough our first game was today.
But everything went okay.
Everything went okay.
I'm so happy.
I remember I was so scared.
I was so scared going in.
And everything.
Yeah.
And I love my team.
My team is so fun to play with.
That's the best part.
The fact that we all have really good synergy with each other.
We all have really good synergy with each other.
And everyone is doing really well.
Yeah.
I've been super chill.
Good energy.
And I made that team.
I made that team.
Yeah.
We're top two out of 100 plus teams.
And everything.
Yeah.
The vibes have been really good too.
Sorry.
I'm getting sentimental and mushy.
But I'm just really happy that we're doing so well amongst 100 plus teams.
Yeah.
I just hope Gomez doesn't fucking die.
Like, that's the harder part.
Like, right before the grand finals.
Like, I just hope he's alive by then.
Wait, did he throw up?
Wait, did he actually throw up?
Did he got over his phobia?
Bro, he once told me he would try and stop.
Oh, no, he didn't.
Okay.
Oh, he did?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Because he once told me the story about that thing where he had a phobia about throwing up.
And he told me, he was like, I would rather... Okay, it's so fucking disgusting.
It was he who died for our doves.
And you would like, you know, try to stop it.
And you know what it means.
Hey, chat told me you threw up.
Did you actually do it?
Oh, no.
Wait, who told you?
Wait, you didn't?
They lied?
Oh, my God.
My chat's spreading misinformation too.
Wait, are you okay?
No, I'm good.
I'm good.
I'm all good now.
Wait, what did you do?
I'm just water viewing.
Wait, so your stomach is just okay?
I took Pepto and Alka-Seltzer.
My stomach feels pretty good right now.
Okay, don't jinx yourself.
Yeah, I was surprised.
I was like, my chat was telling me you threw up.
And I was like, this man would rather swallow than throw up.
I don't think.
Yeah, I would never throw up.
Yeah, I was like, there's no way.
I was like...
You would stop and stuff.
I was so surprised.
No, if I can't hold it in, it comes out.
But you would try very hard to keep it in.
I would not.
He is not a quitter.
Go, Ms. Swallows!
Okay, I'm muting.
Oh, he muted himself.
I'm no fucking swallower.
Hello?
Like, what the fuck?
No, I refuse.
Okay, I won't do that, though.
I won't do that.
He's pulling him out of CDC.
He's not a quitter.
That's crazy.
I have his chat open.
No shame in swallowing.
Spitters are quitters.
Sometimes I love Twitch chat.
Oh my god, I hope Gomez will be okay.
We need three games.
Three games.
Three games and we'll all be free.
I'm just like, I'm still, I'm like, I don't know, like, I think, like, now, like, when I'm in the game, when I'm in the game, like, I'm in the zone.
Like, I'm not as nervous anymore, but...
I'm still like...
I'm glad.
I'm glad I made an awesome team.
I'm glad, like, everybody contributed a lot to the team going in.
And everybody had their own character arc, too.
Yeah, everyone had, like, their winning play.
Had their, like, like, moment to shine.
I think every, yeah, every member on our team had, like, a clippable moment that, like, saved the game.
And let it, like, you know, like, you know, Limu's ults and stuff, her support ults and her keeping me alive.
And then, you know, Coney's thing, all...
Bettle's fucking strange ults fucking did so much.
Gomez just doing the fuck he does as a pro player, like...
Gomez existing.
Shoto's, like, support at Namor and his gameplay as Namor and Bucky, too.
And Jay on, like, strange as well.
When we put him in on strange.
And Jay's moral support.
Yeah.
Yeah, like, Limu's link, soul link there actually saved us for that game.
I'm so glad.
Or we would have been loser bracket, too, if Limu didn't do that soul link to save me, so I could have my Q up.
The game haven't started yet, by the way.
They're still...
They're...
They're still... I think they're starting soon-ish.
I think they're about to start soon.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Yeah.
And they're all, like, you know, a lot of them were, like, Diamond players, too, because we could only have two players that were above Diamond.
And all, you know, within two weeks, they all climbed to Celestial from, like, just the coaching.
From the coaching and playing together, too.
So I'm really proud of my team.
Who's POV are you watching?
I don't know yet.
I'll watch some... I'm gonna watch someone on Mace's team, but I'm not gonna watch Mace.
He already lost me as a viewer.
He lost me as a viewer.
That's what they did.
Okay.
Okay, so they'll protect Strange.
Do we ban Strange, then?
Okay, I'll write this down.
Um...
Protect Strange, and he says Strange keeps everyone cute.
Okay.
We want to ban... We want to ban Strange.
Thanks for the intel, Mace.
Thanks, Mace, for telling us your crutch.
Unless he's lying on stream.
He literally was like, they think banning Mag is a good idea, but Strange is the thing that's keeping us all together.
I was like, write that down!
Write that down!
Okay.
Ew, okay.
Yeah.
That's fine, then.
But then the thing is...
They might try and ban... I guess they'll try and ban the thing and we'll just save Starlord.
Yeah, we'll just try and save Starlord if they try to ban the thing.
And then, we have...
We can play Venom... We can play Venom...
Venom Mag.
Um...
Because it doesn't matter.
No matter what, they are leaving themselves vulnerable to, like, our best players.
Like, they're gonna... We're gonna have, like, Gomez heavily enabled, then.
Like, heavily pocketed.
And then, we can just run Mantis, Loki... We'll just run Mantis, Loki, Luna.
Yeah, no.
That's the thing.
But they'll always try to protect one or the other.
They'll always try to protect either Mag or Strange.
So, we'll see.
I mean, it'll be interesting what they protect.
Okay.
Their DPS... I'm not as scared of their...
Our DPS can dip their DPS, 100%.
I agree with that.
They just have, like, a really...
What do you mean, look at the Storm?
The Storm is full HP.
Wait, they just...
I'm looking at Storm right now.
What the fuck is this?
I don't know what the fuck is going on in this comp.
What the fuck is going... What is going on?
They just farm ults.
That's just their strat.
They literally farm ults and then Rocket... Rocket Punisher.
Okay, they run Rocket Punisher a lot, too.
We could Rocket Punisher.
Mesa...
Protect Strange or Mag.
To protect Strange or Mag, since it's the strongest.
Okay, and then I should write down...
They also try to force...
Force Punisher, Rocket.
So, they also try to force Punisher, Rocket.
So, we have that, too.
Rixie's team heavily tries to rely on...
What I've noticed is that Rixie's team relies on...
Starlord to do something.
And Nova, they're strange to keep everyone together, which I've noticed.
So, when Rixie is out, then their team collapses.
That's what I've noticed on Rixie's team.
When we shut down Rixie, their team just collapses.
But Nova, their Starlord is...
No, their Strange player is like a strange sort of one trick.
So, like...
Their Strange is their...
Their Strange is their Eternity player.
What the fuck?
Okay, I was like, what the fuck is the Punisher doing?
I'm watching...
I'm watching one of their players.
I'll just say I'm not watching Mace.
I'm just bouncing between POVs.
Uh...
I mean, you can watch...
These people are streaming.
It's Mace, Joe, Kiryu, and...
I think their entire team...
Actually, their entire team is streaming other than IPN, I'm pretty sure.
How much time?
They're on round 2.
If Rixie's team...
If Rixie's team wins this, they have to play another game.
Goodbye, Storm.
Yeah, we just have...
We have a team that's not one tricks.
That's basically it.
We had a one trick, but they all...
We forced them off of their one trick.
No, this is...
It's 2.
Oh, we could ban 2.
Yeah, see?
The moment Rixie is out, like, their team collapses.
Their team collapses without...
Without Rixie.
It's like when...
For us, when Gomez...
When Gomez dies for us, we can still recover.
We can still recover, because we still have, like...
We still have, like...
Like...
We're not that scared.
Are they running triple support?
They are.
Okay.
Oh.
Woah.
That was a good throw.
Wait, how the fuck?
How the fuck did he get that ult off?
Yeah, we play after this match.
Yeah, if we lose our carry, we can still...
If we lose their carry, we can still get...
We can still fight.
Like, the amount of times we've lost...
The amount of times we've lost Gomez to dumb shit...
But we can still...
We can still recover.
Like...
It's not, like, the end for us.
What the fuck was that eye, bro?
That was, like, the most predictable ult ever.
I think they have best of three, right?
Is their loser bracket best of three, chat?
Is it best of three, guys?
I can't.
I don't know.
Or is it best of five?
Cause ours is best of five.
Oh, that was their last fight, too.
It's best of three?
Okay.
Okay, we might play mace team.
We might have to play...
Wow.
Okay.
Alright, so our ban line might have to be...
Ban line may be...
Um...
Strange...
Groot...
Uh...
Protect...
Alright.
Uh...
Yeah, I'd rather we get rid of Strange.
Wait, that's an exploit.
You're not allowed to do that.
I thought... I think...
He said they weren't allowed to do that.
Yeah, it's considered an exploit.
Cause you're not allowed to do that in tournament play.
So, as Penny...
As Penny...
I don't think they know.
Cause it was, like, fucking said in the...
There's so many posts, guys.
I only know because, like, sometimes I get curious.
And I look through, like, the forums.
Like, the Q...
Like, the Q&A thing.
To see if there's, like, any updates.
Cause sometimes they post updates in weird areas.
And, like, they're asking if, like...
They're, like, not allowed to do, like...
Cause, like, the Penny thing is considered an exploit.
Um...
Because you can technically throw mines as Penny.
To kill somebody from spawn.
So, like...
Um...
Yeah, obviously...
Yuki...
It's not great.
Sometimes I ask...
Yeah...
Yeah, so you can actually die in spawn.
Like, you can die...
And then die when the match...
Before the match even started.
And then...
You can't even...
You won't even be able to, like...
Get back in time.
Yeah...
But, obviously, you can't do that in tournament play.
Okay...
I think they're just limited by their Bucky player, too.
Rixi's...
Rixi's team is limited by their Bucky...
That...
Bucky player.
Cause he can only play Storm.
He can only play Storm and Bucky.
What the fuck?
Did they get anybody?
I mean, they have 4 minutes.
They have 5 minutes for this.
No,
we have a...
We have a...
And we have...
We can have Mag, too.
They're, like, asking what to do with Punisher.
We can have Mag against their Punisher.
And...
Gomez can play a DPS character that counters Punisher hard.
Okay, not gonna lie...
Rixi's Strange has been incredibly predictable...
With the Strange ult.
Like...
Not gonna lie.
He's, like...
He's sort of, like, been incredibly predictable.
Oh, they're...
Storm is, like, 1.
Do they have an ult for that?
No, they...
Okay...
Okay, it's...
Mace's team that we're playing against.
I didn't think...
I...
That's surprising.
I'm surprised.
They improved a lot.
No, like...
That...
Rixi's Strange was doing really predictable...
Strange ults there.
Like, he literally just flies in front of them.
Like, 3 times in a row.
And it didn't work, unfortunately, for them.
It didn't work.
I'm nervous.
Of course, I am.
I am nervous.
Alright.
Did you guys watch the stream?
Uh...
Kinda.
Not really.
Mace...
Kinda...
Demolished them.
The thing is...
I was watching the stream...
And Mace was literally saying that, like...
That having Strange is keeping their team together.
Alright.
So...
So, I think we need to ban Strange.
We ban Strange first.
Alright.
No banning Bucky?
Oh, no.
No, no.
They're not...
They heavy pocket their Punisher, though.
The moment, like...
They do play Bucky, though.
But I don't know if it's worth it to ban.
Cody needs 10 minutes to finish his bounty.
We need to wait.
There's a 5-minute break in between, anyway.
Okay, okay.
So, like...
What I've noticed...
Are you okay, also, Gomez?
Are you okay?
Do you feel like...
Okay.
Like, you don't have, like...
Stomach issues at the moment?
Nah.
Okay.
I'm all...
I'm all right now.
The Pepto, it saved you.
Yeah!
I wrote down the notes while I was watching.
So, I think we should do Strange.
And then...
I guess Groot.
Because we fucking hate Groot, anyway.
So...
And then...
When they do that...
They Punisher Rocket.
And they just...
Heavily pocket their Punisher the entire time.
I also noticed they like to, like...
Do...
Scarlet Witch.
If he's mag.
For a bit.
So, he gets that...
Immediate damage thing.
Yeah, but Scarlet Witch is trash.
For some reason.
So...
Yeah, it's just like...
They stay in spawn and then they swap off of it.
That thing.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I don't know why.
They think that...
Kony is actually in the bathroom.
Or I don't know.
They're playing with us.
Okay, no, no.
It's all good.
Oh, we got 15 minutes.
Yeah, we got 15 minutes.
So, I guess our ban line would be...
Strange, then...
Groot.
And what do we protect then?
I guess we protect the thing.
Right?
They ban the thing.
We protect Starlord.
Okay, I was listening.
Yeah.
We can do...
Protect the thing or Starlord.
Depending on...
Their first ban.
Whatever they think is the best first ban.
And then...
Then we'll...
The second ban will just...
Depend on what they ban.
Yeah.
If they do rely on Punisher...
Do you want to go Psylocke?
Or do you think...
Starlord will be fine?
Okay.
You'll just go Psylocke.
Cause like...
They just rely on their Punisher...
As their winning...
Their like...
Win condition.
Alright.
They have...
But they have...
He has...
He's being pocketed by three of their supports though.
So, I don't know if you can deal with that.
I think...
I think it should be fine.
Okay.
So, maybe I should say...
I think Namor...
Can also like disrupt it too, right?
Yeah.
That's why...
I should also look for that.
Yeah.
So, we'll see.
I don't know what their ban line is going to be.
But...
Bro.
I'm watching...
Wait.
But what if he said it on purpose?
What if he said it on purpose while...
No.
There's no way.
Maybe.
They're both so tired.
Oh.
That's not good.
Nope.
Just need three.
But if they win the best of three, we get best...
We get a reset.
I thought it was best of five.
Best of five.
Sorry.
I can't count.
Now, we win this.
Do they have a loser's reset?
Or no?
If they win.
Yeah, they do.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
A loser's reset?
Or if we win.
So, there's a system where...
If they lose, the bracket resets.
If they lose?
No, if we lose.
Oh, if we lose.
Oh, if we lose, we get a reset?
Yeah, because we're a winner's bracket.
We're winners.
Oh, okay.
Imagine if it worked that way.
It was just like, you got trashed again.
So, now, we're going to make you do it again.
Oh, that sounds bad.
Oh, my God.
I don't know if I want to do that again.
Yeah.
Let's just...
Listening to her comms is just so sweaty.
I'm like, oh, my God, man.
There's so much pressure.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You're right, Zeus.
Yeah, Zeus doesn't like it, too.
Too sweaty on their end.
I wonder if we could get... do 3-3 against their team.
I think we can.
We've got quite a few games to figure it out, anyway.
We're very good.
Also, like, do you think if there was a... if we need to do Hella, too?
If we need to?
Maybe.
We can do that.
I know they got fuck*d by Hella.
Yeah, they got fuck*d by Bucky and Hella.
And that's why they banned Bucky and Hella.
So, like, I'm just thinking, like...
That makes it easier on us, though.
Yeah.
And then, this time, they banned Bucky for those matches.
Yeah, they banned Bucky for those matches and won.
So, I'm just, like, wondering, like...
If that's the case, should we just run Hella?
What if we give them some PTSD?
Should we just run Hella, Bucky, then?
No, let them... they're gonna ban the Hella.
If they ban Hella against us, that's stupid.
Because you could just be on Starlord.
Yeah.
And then, if they want to do Hella Starlord, then they're really stupid.
Because that's such a waste of a ban.
I don't think they're gonna waste their bans on that.
That's way too dumb.
Like, I don't think their team made it to the Grand Finals.
I don't think they're that dumb.
Nah.
I just think that, like...
If you can absolutely destroy them on Hella, just run Hella.
Instead of Starlord.
I love Hella.
Huh?
Love it.
I'm not a good Hella.
Bro, you fucking destroy...
You can diff... I know you can diff their DPS as Hella.
I'm thinking, like, I'm playing on...
Their DPS is IPN and Kiryu.
Yeah, I'm playing on something else.
Oh.
I don't know who IPN or Kiryu was before you told me.
So...
Maybe they'll be good.
I don't know.
It'll be first impressions in the finals.
Yeah.
Are you going to go Starlord or...
Or Hella then?
I kind of want them to ban Hella and let me Starlord.
Would that just give me free roam?
Well, then you have to do...
Then go Hella first and be a really scary Hella.
Okay.
And then they'll ban Hella.
I'll do it.
If it doesn't work, then just go Starlord.
It's fine.
Alright.
Oh, are we banning out their Groot?
Yeah, we're banning out... No, we're banning out Mag first.
Not Mag, sorry.
We're banning out Strange first.
Strange, okay.
Yeah, because Maze will always protect one or the other.
Like, Maze will try to protect Mag or Strange.
Gotcha.
Sounds good.
And he also plays Groot, right?
That's why we're bringing that in.
Yeah, yeah.
And then we ban Groot because, like, we don't care about Groot players.
So we don't care about... like, you think the other players on their teams can be managed well?
He says that Strange helps him keep his team, like, together.
But if it doesn't work, we can just ban...
Yeah, but obviously if, like, it doesn't work, we can just ban Mag next time.
So they fall apart easily without Strange.
Yeah, I mean, that's their own self-report, so...
They said that.
And I think because his Mag has always been banned, like, he has been able to... he's been, like, playing Strange all the time.
And it's fine, like, Betel is stronger on Mag anyway, too.
So, it'll be fine.
Damn.
I know Betel will gap.
I meant, like... I meant, okay...
I meant more, like, his strongest character is Mag.
Oh, no, I know, he'll gap.
It's good to counter the Punisher comp, too.
Yeah.
I trust Betel.
I trust you, Betel.
As soon as he starts, like, firing, you just, like, lift up the ball and throw it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you get your balls, too.
How fast does it charge when he's just firing with it, though?
Like, really fast, right?
Yeah, it charges real fast, so you gotta be quick with it.
So you just gotta throw it down immediately?
Like, 0.5 seconds time.
Yeah.
When does our game start?
I'm nervous.
When does it start?
Who's their team?
IP, I don't want to lose against that, dude.
Are you not a fan of him?
No, no, no.
He just doesn't want to lose.
You don't want to lose in general.
Yeah, I really don't want to.
Is there bad blood between you two?
No, there's no bad blood.
It's like banter.
Okay.
Yeah, I fucking hate that guy.
Oh, okay.
I thought we were bantering.
Good banter, good banter.
No, he's trying.
He's trying his best, you know.
He's a clip farmer.
I don't, okay, look, I don't understand.
Is that a bad thing?
I don't try to do it.
Is that bad?
Guys, he's very vulnerable right now.
He's very vulnerable.
I'll ask you after.
I don't know if that's bad or not.
Oh my god.
Am I just feeding into it?
I'm going to stop.
Oh, he's so naive.
The internet hasn't ruined him yet.
You're not brain rotted enough, man.
Yeah, he's not.
I'm going to refill my water.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
Hi, everybody.
Hey.
How was your bathroom trip?
It took like an hour.
It took a long time.
It's really stuck in there.
Yeah, everyone's just having gastrointestinal issues today.
We're good now, though.
Back.
Did they invite us to lobbies yet?
No, I'm getting antsy.
Oh, please.
I'm going to fucking freak out.
I'm going to go into the practice range so I can click on things.
Are they 2 out of 3 or 3 out of 5?
They... what?
No, they won.
They won.
Oh, we have to win 3 out of 5.
Gotcha.
Best of 5, best of 5.
And if we lose all 3, we get reset, so then we get another chance.
We get a lot of time, so...
Yeah.
Cool.
Wow.
Lots of adapting.
They're asking...
Yeah.
Apparently... I hope so.
I'm doing fine.
I'll be up and ready.
No more tummy aches.
No more.
I took ibuprofen.
No, ibuprofen.
Why did I say that?
I took Pepto-Bismol and some Alka-Seltzer and I'm all good.
That's good.
I was going to say ibuprofen can just make it worse.
Yeah, I don't know why I said that.
I don't know why.
Double KO.
Put us in the lobby.
Please.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
I just want to play.
I just want to play the game.
Give me the game.
They haven't made the lobby yet.
I know.
I just want to play.
I got tired.
I can tell.
How's your team doing so far?
Gomez?
I'm questioning my team right now.
Why?
Are they not doing good?
Apparently not.
Because we always ban Groot first and they somehow decided, oh, Bucky's better first ban.
Who's subbing for you?
Oh, it's just Grimzo.
Oh.
My coach used to be a pro player and he still plays like one.
So it's fine.
How many matches do they have?
They have... I don't know.
I have to go check.
Check the bracket in our Discord.
Oh my god, what maps are we playing in?
Let's see.
I'll check.
Oh, we're playing...
Let's see.
Where is it?
Oh, wait.
What am I... My chat is so stupid.
Whoa.
That's mean.
That's fucked up.
They lied to me again.
They're about to 3-0 them.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, they're about to 3-0 them.
Wait, your team?
Oh, they're doing fine.
Yeah, my team is fucking them.
No, they just lied...
Oh, wait.
Did they actually 3-0?
They're about to.
Oh, I think they just lost.
Yeah, they just lost.
What do you mean?
Oh, never mind.
It's 2-1 right now.
It's 2-1.
I was like, what do you mean?
They just... I'm looking at it and they just lost.
That doesn't look like winning.
I just saw the defeat screen flash before my eyes.
My bad.
But I guess they're doing fine.
It's a 2-1 at the moment.
Yeah.
They're going to have to start banning Groot now, as a beginning.
I mean, that's what we do.
Well, to be fair, no, we don't ban Groot, but we still keep him out.
Where's our lobby?
I don't know.
Let me find my lobby.
Look at all these people.
I'm in.
I caught them.
Yay!
Invite us.
This is it.
I'm going to invite Mason, too.
If we win three games, the tournament is over.
Three games.
Let's just win three.
Oh, no.
Okay, well, we can't start anyway.
Shoto's not here.
Shoto's in the practice range.
Yeah.
I'm not responding.
He's off seeing his rats.
Yeah, he's with his rats right now.
Oh, Beto, remember to join our team.
Team A.
Don't leave us.
Don't leave us, Beto.
What do I do?
Do you see the top right?
Yeah, there you go.
I'm just getting pulled around.
Shoto!
Should I ping him?
Yeah, we can ping him.
I'll ping him, too.
Let's all just ping him.
All as in me and Lime, I guess.
Good job.
We're joining the room.
Sorry, I wanted to get an apple.
I was hungry.
A red or a green apple?
You're in the practice range, so we can invite you.
It's a Honeycrisp.
Can I invite a Shoto?
The color's a Honeycrisp.
It's red.
I like red apples better.
Are y'all red?
Are y'all ready?
Are y'all red apples?
Are y'all here?
I'm ready.
Three games, guys.
Three games.
Gomez is just starting a fight now.
I feel like Ellie just responded with, gotcha.
The mod is just like, cool.
Happy for you.
Good for you.
Oh, Central Park.
Central Park.
I think we're attacking first, right?
Is this your team A?
Yeah.
Oh, never mind.
We're going to Spider Islands.
Gomez, you're gonna play Hela, right?
I'll do it for the first round.
Yes, we are.
I guess I'll double confirm.
If it's not working, you just swap off to Sire or Starlord.
What if they do something really weird?
Oh, Mesa's team has to be nice.
They got yelled at once.
What?
They got yelled at.
You got a yellow card?
Let's try to piss them off.
Wait, why did he get yelled at?
We said some shit too.
Yeah, but like...
Oh, but it's Mesa.
I know, I know.
He said it on my stream.
I remember it.
Oh, boy.
Wait, remember?
Remember when he Googled translated insults?
That was so fucked up.
No, Mesa once Googled translated insults in a different language.
Oh, I remember that.
That was so awkward.
I was like, bro.
And then we left the group after that.
He voluntarily left the group after that.
So what you're saying is Mental maybe...
No, he can crash out.
There is a possibility that we could crash him out.
I mean, it's a great comp to do it.
The comp that we were running.
One in two teams that we fought in ranked was getting pissed off.
The only thing, we have to have a good ban line though to be able to run 3-3.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
I guess we're just waiting for the casters.
Yeah, both sides is ready, yeah.
Alright.
Whoa, Apple ASMR.
Damn, he's eating that shit.
Yeah, he's chomping down.
Sorry.
You also said Psylocke could be here, right?
If they're doing Punisher, we'd run Psylocke.
Alright, let's see what they first ban.
No?
Okay.
Change.
And then, protect the thing.
Wizards?
Yeah, and then we know what our second ban is.
Oh,
they're going to protect Groot.
That's interesting.
I'm not into that.
Do we get rid of Moon Knight or Namor?
They can't do the combo.
Moon Knight then, I guess, because we can run Namor.
What do you guys think?
Yeah, we can play Namor, they can't.
Get rid of Moon Knight for the combo?
Yeah, I'd like that.
Okay.
Alright, that's interesting, they protect Groot.
Ah, shit.
Yeah, I was muted, but I was like, oh, yep, they're going to ban Wolf right next to it.
Also, maybe not the Moon Knight.
I was a little bit hesitant on that.
Yeah, I was hesitant on it too.
I don't think they play Moon Knight.
Oh, okay.
Goddammit, Gomez!
I was muted.
Again, I'm new to this.
I don't know when I'm muted and when I'm unmuted.
If we seem to be ignoring you, you're probably muted.
Yeah.
Jake just put something in the Groot.
What do you guys think of that?
I mean, I guess it's for other games, but...
No, because they protect Strange.
They can protect Strange.
Do you want me on Sue or Adam?
I just realized.
Uh, Adam for now.
Yeah, and then we'll swap later.
Okay, I'm going to give Gomez the orb first.
Wait, what would you have banned instead of...
What would you have banned instead of Moon Knight?
Probably another tank that... or not another tank.
Like, Hela.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Or Bucky.
Either one.
Yeah, they're on Hela.
Yup, I see the Hela.
Coming out right now.
I see the Groot.
Luna dead.
Nice.
Oh, Mesa's low.
Mesa's low.
Yup.
I got him.
Nice!
Groot one.
Groot low too.
He's one.
I'm just farming for all of them.
I'm going to swap.
Can we guys get rid of these trees?
Get rid of these trees if we can.
I'm one.
You're fine.
Heal me up.
Thank you.
Oh, they know you're there.
They know you're there.
Yeah, I'm backing up.
Got you.
Thank you for bubble.
Yup.
I'm okay.
I have Coney.
Yeah, Coney.
Don't help me, Coney.
Got it.
Okay.
They're just going to wall you off.
Alright, coming back.
I froze him.
Low, low, low!
He died.
He's low.
Oh, lucky.
Nice.
Oh, I'm getting their noggins.
I'm moving up a little.
I might get walled off, but I'm aware.
We're looking for you.
We're trying to get rid of the trees, though.
Right here.
Oh, it's big!
It's big.
Nice.
Running in.
Anymore?
Got it.
Good shit.
Alright, I'm backing up.
I'm backing up.
They have their ults.
They have support ults and they have their tank ults.
I've got rez.
Yeah, if they're going to use support ult, you rez.
Okay, I'm not going to use my support ult.
I'm not using support ult for Gragas anymore.
And Bucky.
So we're going full wipe here.
I guess you should trigger their...
Their combo.
Okay, maybe not.
I'm dead.
They're not comboing.
Rez, rez, rez, rez, rez.
Big rez.
Yep.
Yeah, good job.
Mech's too far.
Oh, damn.
I'm running around.
He's high.
I am ready to put on a show.
I have ult for this.
I'm coming back.
Nice ult.
Bucky dead.
Sue dead.
It's fine.
I'm behind though.
Okay.
I have ult here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm keeping up.
Alright, going in.
Good shit.
I'm on Groot.
Yeah, nice.
No more ults.
Mech, mech.
Good shit.
Good job.
They used both tank ults.
They still have Bucky and Namor ult.
We don't have Namor ult here.
Support ults.
Yeah, we have no support ults.
I'm backing up.
I'm fine.
Oh, fuck.
My bad.
They're gonna have Bucky ult and Namor ult.
You're walled up.
You're walled up, Coney.
We're trying to get...
Yeah, we're fine.
We're fine.
I'm 2v1ing right now.
Believe in you.
They're frontlining.
Mag hurt.
Walled up.
Gotta get back.
Okay.
I have Whale here.
Namor dead.
Groot low.
Focus Groot.
Oh, they ulted.
Okay.
Nice.
That's big.
Bucky.
Oh, okay.
I'm looking at their backline.
I'm looking at their backline right now.
Bucky 1.
Groot.
Nice.
I've got no heals left.
Bucky down.
Everybody's down.
Good shit.
Alright, I got ult.
If they Groot ult or if they Groot ult, I will ult.
So get ready for it.
They have Groot ult soon.
If they Groot ult, I might club.
Depending on how close.
Do you want me to use mine?
Use yours if they Groot ult.
Use yours.
You have shield.
Bonding.
I'm backing up.
That's fine.
They missed.
He missed.
I'm clubbing after this.
I'm walled.
I can ult after.
Got it.
He's low.
Damage.
Mag.
Groot.
Groot on the right.
One.
Frozen.
Groot here.
It's fine.
No more.
I got him.
Luna.
What the fuck?
No way.
There you go.
Nice.
Wait a minute.
I'm building buildings.
You pushed me off the map.
What?
That's a kill there.
That's funny.
The roof fell on my head and I fell.
That's insane.
I've never seen that before.
That is...
I'll show you the clip later from my perspective.
That was unbelievable.
Did you see your PM?
Oh my god.
You killed yourself there.
It just looked bad, dude.
I don't know if it was...
It was because he wasn't shielding so much, but I was able to just fucking nuke so many full charge right clicks into Mag.
Oh my god.
By the way, I'm noticing now, I don't think they've ever played into a Psylocke.
Because they seem a bit lost.
They seem lost on that.
Yeah.
This is good.
That's good.
And then they'll just ban Psylocke and then get Starlord.
Or Hella.
I think they have to ban both probably.
Yeah.
And that's good.
It frees up tank lineup.
Yeah.
And then they have to deal with our tank lineup because our tank lineup is stronger.
Yeah, I felt like they were so busy dealing with you that the tanks were kind of left high.
Yeah, our tanks were just like...
They're just brawling it out.
We got a strong front line.
Alright, let's make this fast.
Make this fast, guys.
I believe in us.
Oh my god, the duck is in sight.
The peeking duck.
I'll take a picture.
Take a picture of the celebratory duck.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's eat it.
If you can put big rat in the background, that'd be great.
My rat?
Do you want me to bring my rat out?
I love big rat.
He loves me too, I think.
Or he wants to eat you.
Yeah, they heavy pocket their Punisher.
We're walking up.
Oh man, I'll walk right now.
Oh, we're walled?
It's okay.
Keep your shield up.
Thank you.
I've got no bombs for now.
You're walled off here.
They have infinite ammo.
Infinite ammo.
Watch out.
I froze.
I'm stuck in a fucking wall.
Go for it.
I'm gonna go for them.
I'm one, yeah.
I'm trying to keep up, but...
100 E.
Okay.
That's fine.
Wait right here.
I can't.
I couldn't.
You were in the side.
Just reset.
It's okay.
Yeah, and they have Loki clones too.
I'm reloading.
He's turning.
I pulled him.
Nice, nice.
Oh, we got rooted.
Oh, they're using everything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, yeah, this is perfect.
That went through me.
I died so fast the game didn't register that I died.
That's funny.
Oh my god, they're huge!
Pony!
Is it?
It seems small to me, but...
Oh, no, no, it's big, it's big.
Big, it's big, it's big!
Come at me.
Go, go, go!
What?
Why'd they take that?
It works, though.
It works.
Oh, actually, you are...
Hold on.
Let's do it back to them.
What are we doing?
Do it back, though.
Do what?
Wait, dude, do Punisher back.
We just push around the corner.
It's one fight.
Do we win Rocket, then?
Yeah, go Rocket.
What do we do?
Trip support?
Okay, okay, okay.
Just hold right click.
That's all you have to do.
Okay.
Just let me know when you want the ammo.
Let me know when you want the ammo, okay?
Yeah, I will.
I will.
I'll let ya.
I'll let ya know.
They're pushing far out.
Yeah, really far.
I'm putting on Coney the...
Let us know when you want the ammo.
Yeah, let me know.
I have ammo.
You have more?
He's getting shielded so hard.
I can't.
Watch out.
Just hold it.
Hold it.
Don't do anything.
Let me know when you have ammo again.
I'm 25.
I have ult now, but I'm filming.
I'm keeping...
Actually, uh...
Walk up.
I'm okay.
Do the rocket ult.
Punisher.
He's up.
Nek.
Dead.
That's you.
That's fine.
Ammo.
Stay.
Are you ready?
Ammo.
It's ammoing right now.
I'm ulting this.
Punisher.
3, 2, 2, 2, 2.
Push up, push up, push up again.
They're gonna try a strange portal.
I'm gonna check if they swapped to strange.
No, they can't.
They can't?
OK, that's good, that's good.
3, 3, 3, 3, 3, 3, 3, 3.
2 of the ta- Block me, spell can't- Nice!
Yep!
Good shit!
Yeah, they have a group.
We have a fucking... we have a big unmovable rocket.
This is way better.
Yeah.
Same badline?
Yeah, keep the same badline.
Wait, how do I do most damage?
Oh, Cody!
Obviously!
Obviously, bro!
Come on!
I went foolish.
If they're gonna run this at us again, then we should just mirror them, I guess.
Yeah, we can just mirror it.
Cody, that character was built for you, man.
He's so fun.
Dude, that ult seemed ass.
I can't believe that was good.
It was good.
Their Punisher is pocketed super hard.
That's what I'm saying.
That's their entire win condition.
They just pocket their Punisher.
Interesting.
They're a cheesy team.
Oh wait, guys, can you link me the clip?
Hold on, I'm gonna get my stream to link me this clip.
You guys gotta watch this.
This is insane.
Oh, the clip where you fell off?
Yeah, dude, hold on.
We could, like, if they protect Groot, do we just want to ban Rocket?
No, just keep the... Oh, actually, wait.
The Moon Knight.
They don't play Moon Knight.
Yeah, just ban Rocket.
Okay.
I mean, Ivern and Kiryu both can play.
They can play Moon Knight, but like, I don't know if they're good at it.
That's the thing.
Like, do you think you can counter the Moon Knight?
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Psylocke's, like, a direct counter.
Okay, then we'll just ban Rocket then.
We'll do Groot-Rocket.
Actually, you know what?
I don't want them... Rocket is a good comp then.
No, I'm more confident of us just kind of going for the Moon Knight then, because maybe they're on it.
Maybe.
Maybe they're on it.
I mean, we could try it out for this.
Oh my god!
I don't think they do Moon Knight.
Okay, then we'll just... Yeah, we'll just do Rocket.
We'll their win condition is literally pocket the Punisher.
That's it.
Yeah, I feel like if we get rid of that, it makes it a lot easier.
Yeah, because the thing is that what counters Psylocke is triple support.
And if they triple support with a Moon Knight only while they do Groot combos, it's going to be super hard.
We 3-3.
Really hard.
We 3-3 Adam.
And then I'm just holding Moon Knight.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Okay, never mind.
We're good.
We're chilling.
I thought about it.
I thought about it and then...
Yeah, you thought about it.
I was like, Coney, I saw the clip on my chat side.
Dude, if that happened and the game was on the line, I would have been furious.
That was crazy.
It's in the chat.
Look at the Iraqi Raccoon chat.
Bro, please look at that.
It's so funny.
That was insane.
Who broke that roof?
Was it our own team that broke that roof?
None of y'all killed me, bro.
That's like hilarious.
Dropped the roof on my head.
Why did the builder...
Yeah, dude, I couldn't move.
I got executed.
Hang on, I'll show you that.
We still won that.
Yeah, that was the very end.
Thank God.
Dude, if that happened in the middle of it...
It was right at the end.
Like, right as we were killing Moon, which was nice.
Like Battlefield Revolution fucking knocked you out of the map.
Everybody's against us.
I've been griefed by... I've had that happen to me before too.
A roof fell on me and I cloak and dagger ulted and I got stuck in one spot and I couldn't move anywhere.
Like, he just dropped on top of me.
Like, I don't know why that shit happens.
I've seen that at Midtown too.
That happens a lot on the Midtown map.
I hate that map.
The translation thing, yeah.
Two more games though.
Let's get it.
Was this on defense?
What?
It is on defense, yeah.
That was like, right when we killed everybody.
Oh, wait, that's... Are we all ready?
Yes, I'm ready.
Everybody here?
Okay.
Alright, I'll just do... We are...
Watching it for a third person is so good.
Dude, I was like, what?
Maybe there's something I can do here?
Like, I was like...
I don't know who broke that house.
It would be funny if you broke that house yourself.
I don't know.
Wait, do we know who broke the house?
He probably fisted the house.
Yeah.
Dude, things just break shit by accident.
Like, when I start running, everything breaks around me.
Like, I can't run on a platform because the ground breaks.
Oh my god, Luna did it on accident.
Luna was trying to heal and...
Luna was trying to heal and broke the roof.
And died.
Okay, Domination.
They're gonna...
They ran Punisher and Domination too.
They ran Punisher to win this map.
Against Riggzy's team.
Wait, sorry.
Say it again.
They ran Punisher and Rocket to win against Riggzy's team for this.
So, Strange still, right?
Yeah, Strange still.
Oh, I wonder what their first ban is gonna be.
I didn't see that one coming.
Shocker.
Oh, I love that.
You know what?
For this map, I think we do ban the Rocket.
Rocket's really fucking annoying.
And if they protect Rocket, we just ban Punisher.
Okay, that's fine.
I have Loki.
Do we ban Groot or Rocket?
I think Rocket still.
We protect the thing.
And then we ban Rocket because...
Yeah, they protected him, but...
They don't protect it anymore.
I still think we should ban Rocket because I think the Punisher Rocket is more oppressive.
That's the only reason that was creating problems for us.
That's our name.
Yeah, that's why we fucking hate you.
Ready to play.
They're thinking.
They didn't expect that one.
Oh, they're thinking hard.
Groot player can play Groot.
Yeah.
Are you gonna go Hello or...
Okay.
I don't know.
They don't know how to deal with Psylocke.
Wait, why did they protect me?
Oh, did you want the Atom?
Loki?
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I forgot.
I was trying to pick Luna, but I...
Oh, okay.
I was confused.
I was trying to pick Luna, and I picked the wrong one.
I was thinking here.
I saw...
That means they're gonna run Luna and Namor.
They protected Namor, so they can do the combo.
They wanna do double combo.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay.
But we have the Res, so...
I'll just try not to get caught in it.
Link just kinda counters that whole combo.
Yeah, I'll Link it.
If we're all there, Link should be fine, right?
Yeah, but I feel like...
Wouldn't Res be better, though?
Like, Res and then I'll...
It kinda depends on when it hits, I guess.
Yeah, that's true.
They can Luna damage boost the Namor, too.
So that's what I'm worried about.
I'll give the...
Okay, I'll give the Snowflake to Gomez.
Stop fucking swapping!
I'm just dashing.
Do they ever do anything other than Punisher?
No.
They try to do Bucky, but I...
He missed his ult, like, twice.
I love watching you guys, like, zoom ahead of me, and I'm like, I am the perfect being.
I'm so slow back here.
Magneto is actually...
It's annoying to push up with him.
Running at Mag, Namor...
I fucking hate this map.
And if I run, it will break.
I'm kinda...
Yeah, they have Hella.
They have Hella.
They're Hella, Bucky.
What?
Hella, Namor.
Walled off.
I got you.
I'm pushing up.
Pushing up.
I'm gonna get their healer.
Healer half.
She's jumping away.
Pushing Mace off.
Mace is half.
He's getting healed.
Mace is low.
He's backing up.
We got point.
We got it.
They're looking at you now.
We're pushing up.
Bucky dead.
Nice.
Your wall goes low.
Good shit.
They got Bucky.
Okay.
Oh, I got his head.
They're on triple support.
Oh, they went triple support.
I got this guy ulted up.
If need be, I can always lowkey.
I mean, that reset their ults, right?
I mean, some of them.
I kinda wanna ult.
You can do it.
Okay.
We got the Luna.
You're walled off.
That's fucking...
That's unlucky.
I have lava.
I got hit by it.
I'm backing up.
You rez under.
Rez under.
Wait.
On the point.
Oh, you don't have ult.
I thought you meant rez.
Okay, my bad.
That's fine.
I mean, we got 65.
Yeah.
They used both tank ults and aim ult.
They have both their support ults here.
I'm gonna walk up.
Really?
I'm low.
Can I get a quick heal?
Mech, mech, mech!
Okay, bubble.
Oh, I got him.
Oh my god.
I'm behind them.
Guys, we're up one.
We're up one right now.
They have no mantis ult.
Pushing, pushing.
Mantis down.
I'm on miz.
Go!
Move, move, move!
Miz, miz, miz!
Miz?
Okay.
They have gruud ult.
Make sure to rez.
We're gonna int for that gruud ult.
I'll just stay down here then.
Yeah, do that.
If you want heals, come to the window.
Maybe I'll just bounce on the bounce pad.
Don't stay near us.
Just hold, just hold.
You're walled up, you're walled up, you're walled up.
You might have to rez for this.
Nice.
Rez for this, rez for this.
Yes!
That's fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Everybody's fine.
Backline ult, waiting, waiting, waiting.
Ah, shit.
I'm on the gruud, I'm on the gruud right now.
Gruud's dead, yeah, gruud's dead.
I have ult here, I have ult here.
Support low, support low!
Mei's low, Mei's low.
Got it, nice.
Good job.
Need more, need more, need more, need more.
It's fine, it's fine, got it.
They used...
Did they use gruud ult?
I don't know.
They did.
No, I didn't see it.
No, they did not, they did not.
They have gruud ult, they used...
They used mag ult.
And they used...
They used suu ult, yeah.
So they'll have their support ult anymore.
I was trying to time my ult to stop suu ult, but it didn't work.
We got them still though, which is good.
30 seconds before you attack.
Yeah, sorry, that was a bit stuffed because mag died way before anyone else, so I just had to come out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's my bad.
Trying to get on top of it.
This wins.
No, what the...
Hello?
Why can't I put it... Wait, why?
This wins too, you're right.
They're all stronger.
Oh my...
I just want to see my spray, look at this.
The thing is stronger.
Yeah.
On my screen, yours was on top.
That's crazy.
That's funny.
Dude, I think you're right.
They don't seem to know how to deal with Psylocke.
Yeah.
Dopa's just running all over them.
I haven't seen anyone really run at him.
Oh,
nice, nice, nice.
That's huge.
Grookey died too, he was low.
Yeah, they're just walling us.
Someone cap though.
You cap, Coney, you cap.
I'm going to cap, I'm going to cap.
I'm going to point 2, yeah.
Why is it so bad now?
Why is my ult so bad?
Why?
We have to cap.
Why does it not go to her person?
We capped, we're good.
We are undefeatable!
Oh, they fucked up, they fucked up!
He fucked up, he fucked up.
Magneto on the healers.
Magneto, Magneto's on us, Magneto's on us.
You guys can touch, touch, touch.
We can, we can, Mag was on us.
They're on us hard, they're on us hard.
That's alright, I got no heals.
I'll pocket Bruin for that one.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
They wasted Groot ult on them.
I'm asleep, I'm asleep.
Do you want me to rez you?
No, no, no.
I couldn't save Gomez when he was ulting there.
Do we want to go left?
Yeah, go left, go left.
Yeah, we should have died faster there.
I have ult here.
They have low heal.
You know, whoever you ult, you can wail it.
I'm going to do that.
I'm frozen.
Okay, that's great.
I'm ulting everybody.
Use ult, use ult.
I can block it, maybe.
I blocked it.
I need a heal.
Are you?
Thank you.
I like the cold.
I leave the...
Thank you.
Walking out.
Mag, mag.
I'm just going to ult the frontline.
I got Luna.
I got point, I got point.
They have no ult.
Do you have rez?
I'm rezzing.
Fuck.
That's fine.
I'm damage boosting, I'm damage boosting.
I can save ult here.
Save ult, save ult, save ult.
Save ult, yeah.
They grew up, they moored.
And they should have mag.
They should have one support ult for this next fight.
Kony, I think I'll save it to combo my ult with yours or something.
You got it, okay.
Wait, oh my god.
They're pushing up.
I was trying to give Kony...
I was trying to give Gomez the...
Someone's over on the left here.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Alright, I have ult.
Just waiting.
He jumped in.
Mag is on us, mag is on us.
Mag is trying to kill us.
I'm slept, I'm slept, I'm slept.
Got point, point, point, point.
We're flipping point, we're flipping point.
I'm trying to get back, I'm trying to get back, I can't.
I'm back on.
I can block it, I can block it maybe.
Thank you.
We have to stop flipping point here.
We can let mag walk in, but we can't let them flip point.
That's okay.
Just run 3-3 or...
Yeah, we might need to run 3-3.
I agree, I agree.
I'll swap right now.
Wait, oh.
We're not there with you.
I tried something, it did not work.
Alright, I'm waiting for everybody, I can charge in.
You have to charge in now.
Going now, going now, going now.
Yeah, we have luna ult.
Break this, break this, break this, I can save coni!
Okay.
Nice!
Screw the Bucky.
Holy shit!
My goat!
Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot!
Groot one!
Mace, Mace, get him in!
They have one fight, they have one fight here.
They have one fight, they have Groot ult.
I'm gonna have ult soon.
They have Groot ult.
I'm gonna hang back here so I can rez behind this wall if I need to.
I wanna hide somewhere with ult, but I don't know which way they're coming.
I think Mace knows it, which is why he's pushing us so hard.
Yeah, no, he's pushing me.
He's pushing me.
They're gonna walk in with luna ult, by the way.
I'm gonna ult their backline if they walk in here.
Wait, what?
What?
No, they waited like last second.
No more on the left.
They're more looking for our ult.
He has no bubble.
I got slept, I got slept.
I messed it up for them, I messed it up.
Use it, use it, use it.
Yeah, yeah, good job, good job.
We need copy, we need copy.
Where's luna, where's luna, where's luna?
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, please.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Copy, copy me.
Behind you, behind you.
Behind you, behind you, behind you, behind you.
I'm behind you, I'm behind you.
I'm in front of you now.
Nice.
Bro, everyone was jumping all around me, man.
I'm so sorry.
Dude, there was like Bucky in front of me and shit.
Luna's dead.
I'm walking back, guys.
You got it, you got it, you can do it.
Get Mei's, Mei's, Mei's off.
Mei's one, Mei's actually one, Mei's one.
Got him.
Good job, guys.
Oh my god, I slept behind you and I went in front of you because you couldn't find me.
It was, bro, I couldn't see shit.
All I could hear was behind you, behind you, and I thought we'd been flanked as well.
No, because I got rezzed, I got rezzed.
Because I was on the point, I didn't die.
No, no, I was on point.
And then I died so I could be next to you, and then you were just turning around trying to find me.
That was so cooked, bro, I'm so sorry.
It was, we were lucky Coney lived.
I can't believe I lived, I actually can't believe it.
That's insane.
One more, one more, guys, one more.
You wanna know something, Coney?
The fact that they have such a low DPS comp, of course you're gonna live.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you're right.
They can't kill me.
The only person that can do anything is their Neymar.
One more and we're done.
One more, one more, guys, one more.
That was too intense.
That was too close.
Should we try 3-3 on our last one?
I mean, we can, I don't think they expect it to work.
I mean, we ban Rocket still, right?
If we ban Rocket, it'll be really good.
If they save Rocket, then what do we ban after that?
Punisher?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, I agree.
Dude, your Rock, like, I'm just saying.
That Rock was so clutch.
I was damage boosting, hoping for a miracle.
I was like, please slam dunk this Rock, fellow, you are damage boosted.
Dude, oh my god.
I feel like I blocked his ult twice with my bubble.
You did, that was crazy.
You blocked a one above all Mag ult.
That's crazy.
Twice.
I've never done that before.
This guy was rank one, showed up.
You were just like, I can block it, I can block it, and I'm like, you can?
Just remember, showed up.
Mace was rank one, several times, and you blocked it.
Is he crashing out?
I need you to invite me again.
I said yes, but it kicked me out of a lot.
It shows you in here, though.
Wait, really?
I'm not in it.
Alright, I'm back.
You might need to restart your game.
Okay, I'll restart it.
Yeah, I'm not in my menu.
They're both here.
No, but wait, what happens if I just play practice?
Oh, what the fuck?
I'm in a room, but I'm not.
Okay.
Solaris wants team A.
Oh.
That's interesting.
They want to defend first.
Okay, so we go B?
Wait, is that how it works?
Like, you just choose?
Yeah, wait, we can pick?
We can pick?
We're given an option to do that?
Yes, they get the first ban line.
That's why.
But, like, does it matter?
If they get the first ban line?
They also want to attack first.
Like, defend first, too.
Okay, I'm relaunching my game.
One more, one more.
So we gotta swap over to team B.
Yeah.
So, like, is it a rule that losers can choose which side they want?
I guess so.
I mean, we can just give that to them.
I don't think it matters too much, right?
No, it doesn't really matter.
It's basically morale, too.
You know, like, if they full hold us, they'll be more excited about pushing us through.
Type deal.
There's, like, a morale thing.
Okay.
Alright, invite, please.
I'm back on.
Yeah, I'm back, too.
I want to invite...
I cannot invite Cody anymore, for some reason.
I can.
Wait, I can!
Oh, wait, I can, yeah.
Nice.
That was weird.
I hit invite, and then it said, your request to join Cody's room has been received.
I was like, no, that's not what I wanted to do.
Okay, are we all ready?
Yes.
Ready to go.
Gomez, are you here?
Yeah, I'm here.
I'm here.
Oh, they want three minutes.
Okay, how about... Shredder, are you here?
I'm good, yeah.
I'm here.
Okay, so we'll just say we're ready, and then they just have three minutes anyway.
We are ready.
I'll run to the bathroom real quick.
Whenever.
Yeah, we're ready.
We know what we're banning and saving.
Just save the thing if you can.
If they end up banning the thing, we'll just save Starlord.
Yeah, we save Starlord.
Yeah.
I think Maze is definitely hard focused on me right now.
He's literally walking through everybody just to kill me.
It's fucking crazy.
He's just waiting through us.
I was like, bro, what the fuck?
Oh, chat.
One game.
One game, guys.
Just one more game.
I am nervous.
I'm very nervous.
Yeah, I don't know how to feel.
These games have been incredibly stressful, guys.
Very, very stressful.
Yeah.
Just need one more.
Just one more.
Oh.
Yeah, they kept flipping point.
That was our issue.
Like, we just keep letting them flip point.
Because I'd be like, bro, how can one guy not die?
I was just like, guys, please.
I should have just ran to the side or some shit.
Like, I just ran off.
Alright, we're ready to go.
One more and we're done.
Let's do it.
Okay, I said I.
They should be ready.
Guys, I fucked up.
What?
You know how I was having stomach problems?
Yeah.
My dad brought me sushi and instinctively I ate it.
What is wrong with you?
I think you have a tapeworm.
Are you okay?
Are you having stomach problems again?
No, no, but if it happens, I'll be proud.
Okay, one game.
Gomez, we have one game.
Lock the fuck in and then get your stomach worms later.
Just win!
Win!
Okay, I'm going to go breathe.
The band line won't last long, right?
Okay, I'll be back.
Alright, change.
Do we say band line?
Change.
Change, Rocket.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
Strange Rocket.
Are they going to protect Strange, you think?
No, we ban.
They always let the... okay.
Okay.
So now we just ban Thing and... I mean we ban Rocket.
We protect Thing and Rocket.
Only heroes will get my cosmic favor today.
Okay, get...
I wonder why they wanted to switch sides.
Um, morale.
Rocket?
Right.
Yup.
Because if they full hold us first point, then they'll be like, oh guys, just one point, you know?
Mhm.
They're thinking.
We'll win.
Alright.
A lot of thinking for the same band lines on both sides.
Yeah, I was going to say that.
I have a feeling you're going to triple support.
Yeah.
I'm going to start with a triple.
We'll start with a triple.
Oh gosh.
Sue or Adam.
You can run this first.
Oh.
Right?
Okay.
I think Adam.
Right?
Yeah.
You have enough healing.
Alright.
Should we run Hela or Bucky, Gomez?
Because Hela might be really good too.
Bucky and triple supports is way better for her.
Okay.
It's like we beat that first theme game.
We did triple support Hela last time.
I wasn't able to beat them so I'm just wondering if it'll be better.
We'll see what happens.
We'll see what they have.
Yeah.
I'm running on old low settings so this texture here looks so shitty.
Oh yeah,
that.
Okay.
I'm already feeling it.
Oh come on!
No!
That was such a mistake.
I don't know why I ate a piece of sushi.
I don't even know why.
Is it just one sushi?
Oh, they went moon.
They're running the moon?
Wait, I don't know if we should run.
Okay.
It's a little concerning for the low key.
You gotta split your clones up a little.
Nevermind, I missed.
Worst comes to worst, if this is a big problem I can go cloak dagger.
Oh wait, no wait.
I can just go Psylocke in one shot.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go Psylocke, go Psylocke.
Oh actually, well, I'm already on.
I'm already too deep in.
Yeah.
You're blocked off.
Yep.
I have ult soon.
Okay.
I'll give you orb.
Let me know when you're ulting and I'll give you orb.
Alright.
I'm pulling.
Oh my god!
Look at the group!
The mag, the mag, the mag!
I'm looking at mag, I'm looking at mag.
Wait, I wanna go ult there.
Nevermind, no I don't.
I'm doing it again.
Don't link if you can, don't link if you can!
Holy shit, thank you for the shield.
I needed to solo link there.
I don't have it, sorry.
I have ult here.
Actually, you know what?
Yeah, give me snowflake and I flank behind.
Yeah, I know.
Where are you?
Here.
Right here?
Left building.
Can I ult in first?
Yeah, just ult in first.
I'm behind you, I'm behind you.
I'm right here.
Yup, I'm ulting, I'm going in.
Look for rez, Lime, are you active?
No!
That damage boost, bro!
That damage boost!
Look for rez here, look for rez here, Lime.
I don't have one yet.
I'm back, baby!
Hey, what's up?
I got shipped, I got shipped to you.
We're caught up in that room.
Nice.
I got you, Doki.
Thank you.
We're one off, we're one off, we're one off.
We're fine, we're fine now.
Okay, we're good now, we're back.
We're in the back.
Nice.
Oh, just a minute.
Okay, he's big, he's big, he's big.
Fruit low, fruit low, fruit low!
Yeah, I'm on Groot, on Groot, on Groot right now.
He's dead.
Back one.
Got back.
Loki on the point.
Got Loki.
Dead.
Yeah.
Okay, good shit.
I love playing Hello.
Okay.
I hate it.
Playing Hello with a sushi stomach.
Yep.
Here, here, snowflake.
I'll give you snowflake.
I'll give you snowflake, yeah.
Actually, it's not that bad.
Maybe my stomach's fine.
Don't say that, don't say that.
You just need the eggs to get the fuck out of there.
I don't know.
Push down the eggs with the fish.
Hello on the left.
Oh, they have Hello too, they have Hello too.
Yeah, Hello on the left.
She's there.
We're on two to two now.
You on me, you on me?
You good?
I'm dying.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
I have ult here.
I have ult here, if I find it.
That's good.
Okay.
Walled off.
Got one.
They're gonna have Brutal, they have Brutal.
Gonna ult after.
I'm gonna ult.
I'm here, I'm going in.
Nice.
No, no burn Hella, no burn Hella.
Got it.
Got her.
I've got no soul link.
Look, he's dead, everyone's dead.
All of them are dead.
Alright, there you go.
I'm pushing for you.
Fucking building, let me go.
Don't wall, don't wall.
We got Moon, they have Moon.
Save your soul link for that.
Sorry, I used it for the Groot ult.
I got you.
I'm low, I'm low.
I gave you Snowflake, I gave you Snowflake, Gomez.
They have Moon and I ult, they have Moon and I ult.
Oh my gosh.
I froze Mace, I froze him.
That's good, that's good.
They don't have support ults now.
I'm staying way back so I can rez you if he doesn't ult.
Yes, yes, yes.
Groot, Groot, Groot, focus Groot.
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
Oh shit, shit up.
We couldn't see you, sorry.
Alright,
Gomez and I are pushed up just to make sure they don't push into us.
It's okay, that's okay.
You died right now, it's fine.
They still have Moon and I ult here.
Oh shit, door's shutting.
That's it, that's it, they wasted low heal.
That's fine, they wasted ult, they wasted ult.
Yeah, yeah, back out again, don't push into this.
I'm gonna give Snowflake to Gomez.
I have ult here, I can get onto site.
Let's pull.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
You can push in, push in.
Did they Groot?
Yeah, let's pull, let's walk in, let's walk in, let's walk in, let's walk in.
I'm healing.
There's a mag, there's a mag.
Healing, healing.
I tried to shift.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I have ult here.
They ult, they ult, they ult.
I have ult here, nice.
That's enormous, holy fuck.
Enormous, enormous, bro.
Nice.
Got it.
Okay, three cart, three cart, three cart.
Excellent res, excellent res.
That was a really good res, yeah.
We don't have anything now, we just gotta build it up now.
I have an idea.
What's the idea?
I get nervous every time you say that.
Every time he says that he fucking dies, I don't trust it anymore.
I can't.
Remember when I gave the idea for him to go, hello, and look at him now.
He said I was wrong.
Oh, oh no.
I got you.
Fear.
I fear, I fear.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
What the fuck, you threw it at me?
The fuck is your problem, man?
Ult in the backline.
It's okay, it's okay.
I'm still pushing up, I'm still pushing up.
Oh, I got revived, I got revived, I got revived.
I'm back, Hela back here.
Oh, I'm done.
Oh, right, the Lucio revived.
That's a thing.
Oh.
LeBron!
Got it!
LeBron James, bro.
Holy shit.
Mace is making eyes at Doki, I don't like it.
I know, me too, I don't like it, I feel very uncomfortable.
Hela can't move!
Hela the bird, got it!
Okay, we're good, we're good.
Crit, crit, crit, crit, crit, crit, crit!
Crit, crit!
Oh no, that's unlucky.
Me too, me too, I'm ready for it.
They have Muna on shield for everybody.
I have ult for this, I have ult after, I have ult after.
Where are you?
I don't see you.
I got hit by it.
I still get 12% to ult.
Okay.
This is our last fight.
We have Rez.
I'm low, I'm low, I'm low, I'm low.
As the moment someone dies, you have to Rez.
I'm real low!
You have to Rez, you have to Rez.
I think I made it.
Mek's coming, Mek's coming.
That's gonna suck.
Bonded, I got it.
Oh my god, nice, nice bonding, nice healing, oh my god.
Walk, walk, walk.
We walk, we walk.
Hela on the side.
Oh my god.
She's here, she's high.
She's still on the side.
Hela's inside, Hela's inside!
I'm shifting, I'm shifting.
Alright.
No fucking way.
Get walled up, get walled up.
I'm trapped in here, I'm trapped.
Hela over here.
She's, yeah, she's been over there for a bit.
Okay.
Can you get her, can you get her?
Killmiss!
Is that...
You only have...
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nothing for Coney.
Okay.
Look, you can copy.
Oh, I died, I died.
I need a Rez or something.
I can ult.
No, we're dead.
Okay.
On wait.
Wait a second, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
I was gonna say, you still dropped cart.
It didn't matter.
Yeah, it was because there was a Hela to our left, but no one could challenge that Hela.
Yeah.
I was waiting for a Snowflake.
I should have ulted earlier.
Yeah, you should have, yeah, I was in the zone there, I couldn't, I didn't know.
All we gotta do is hold, it's fine.
We almost got the point.
Sue her at him for hold.
Hmm.
I don't know, I like the Sue, but at the same time the Rez.
There's a bit of verticality, so I can get a fun Rez, I guess.
Hmm, I like the Rez.
Okay.
If it feels like we're getting steamrolled, I can switch.
Yeah, if it doesn't work, just go Sue.
Okay, no work.
I mean, suing a Hela is kinda OP, though.
But also, Rez is big.
What do you want?
Pick, pick, pick, pick, pick.
Do Sue, do Sue.
Sue?
Okay.
Yeah, it's just Snowflake.
Is there a Hela getting Snowflake or no?
I don't think so.
Okay.
I'll just keep it on you.
I would assume why they wouldn't do it, but...
I think they can put the Snowflake on Mace, because he's their strongest.
Nah, probably.
How long until detonation on my right click is like 30 seconds, right?
I have no idea, you're the pro.
Okay, I got it.
I'll shoot it.
Fuck it.
I'm getting out.
Oh, fuck, I need help, I need help, I need help.
You're fine.
I didn't even know that bridge could be broken.
Am I stupid?
Maybe, I mean, you're sick.
I guess I'm stupid.
I'm lucky.
They are so aggressive, holy shit.
They are?
Yeah.
I hear Hela.
Hela to your left, Hela here.
Gomez, Gomez, Hela here, Hela here.
I couldn't heal because of the Hela.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I know.
Ah, fuck man.
I bet he's very good distracting.
I'm low, I'm low, I'm low, I'm real low.
I'm trying, we're trying.
Shielding.
I'm having to jump.
This Mace guy is chasing me.
Oh shit, they're gonna run us over here.
Yeah.
Dude, he's hard focusing you, holy shit.
Gomez, you have to look for the Hela flank.
Our supports can't heal.
We need to deal with that.
Well, that sucks because the left side is my left ear.
So I couldn't hear it.
Are you sure Namor isn't the end?
They went off triple support.
Yeah, go for it, go for it.
But you're gonna have to go ult spawn, I think.
Yeah, that's fine, that's fine.
I have, uh...
Because they swapped off triple heal, so this might be better.
God, I fucking suck at the E kills.
They're gonna have Grill here, they're gonna have Grill here.
No, do not use, do not use your shield for, uh, for that.
Okay.
I have to.
Three, two, one.
I'm just gonna back up.
Yeah, back up.
Yeah, I can't fight their Hela, their Hela has a shield.
Nevermind, didn't matter.
Okay, walk, walk, walk.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, we got this.
Walking up, walking up.
Running up.
Your wall's up, your wall's up, get...
I'm ulting.
I don't wanna risk that.
Oh, we used too many ults.
Oh.
I'll get you.
Someone, you gotta, you gotta get rid of the walls.
I can't do much when I have walls in front of me.
Man.
Alright.
Woo!
Nice.
Ooh, nice one.
They have Moon Knight ult here.
They have Moon Knight ult and they're gonna have, uh...
They have a... oh, they went lowkey.
Got you.
One.
They're going up here.
Hela underneath you.
Oh, in there.
I see her.
She's in that window.
Walled off, Coney, walled off, Coney.
Yeah, I'm fine.
Walled off, walled off.
There's, there's nothing here.
Any heal up here?
Uh, the healer's dead.
I'm still alive, it's fine.
No, Doki's alive, Doki's alive.
Yeah.
It's fine, I have ult too.
I got two.
I got you, I got you, mate.
Uh, no, wait, sorry.
No!
What?
That fucking sucks, eh?
Do you want me to ult to match the other...
Missed ult was low.
Yeah, and Fizz got away.
Yeah.
It's okay though.
Fucks.
Use your ult, use your ult here!
Oh.
Nice.
You're going to have Moon Knight ult, okay?
Don't bunch up.
Mag.
I need y'all to take some damage.
Moon Knight dead.
I need heals.
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
Fuck, I don't have shift.
Fuck me.
Right here, right here, right here!
Groot one, Groot one!
Let's win!
Oh, the Groot's low, Groot's low, fuck!
He's still low, yeah.
I still see him.
He's still low.
I got him.
Three, two, one, at the back out.
Okay, that's fine.
I am ready to put on a show!
I could get that far to you.
I could, and you were way too far for us.
I should ult for this.
We have no support ults, we have no support ults, by the way.
Yeah, I'll come back with ults then.
Oh my god, that Hell is low, Hell is low.
Got you.
They have Moon Knight ult, they have Moon Knight ult.
Just try to back them up.
I'm ulting to survive.
I got you, Shen.
Thank you, thank you.
I got you, Doki.
My ult lasts longer than a super ult, by the way.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
Where are you, Gomez?
I got you, you have Snowflake, you have Snowflake.
You can go flank now.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh, no, no.
Never use it, never use it.
During, during grid ult.
Like, during, if we had...
Oh, they have Moon Knight ult.
Got another one.
Nice, nice, nice, we're coming back.
I'm backing up, I am low.
We're coming back, we're coming back.
Yeah, wait for us.
For heals, if we can.
I tried to jump, but I couldn't.
I held it as long as I could.
I can plant point.
Okay, okay, okay.
Rune is low.
Oh, no.
Oh, none of us have point.
Sorry, we got two minutes.
It's fine.
It's not that...
It's no time at all.
I'm backing up fully, I'm backing up fully.
No, they got me.
Okay, we know they have Moon Knight ult.
Don't, don't ult the...
Don't ult the Groot.
Okay.
Back up fully, back up fully, back up fully.
Oh, they're just gonna free push this.
Back up fully.
Beat me up, beat me up here.
They're gonna have combo again.
Yeah.
So, uh...
I'm gonna try not to bunch up with...
I give you orb, I give you orb.
Alright, I'm ready to turn.
We ready?
Yeah.
I'm ready.
Going in.
We should push up, we should push up now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yep, that's what I'm doing.
I'm all going in.
You're good.
Oh, there's a Hella on the side, Hella on the side.
We need help, we need help, Gomez.
We need to get the Hella.
I'm going for the back up.
Oh no, she went...
She's going around.
I'm going in, I'm going in with this.
You got it?
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna throw it right now.
Oh my god, we're here.
Nice, nice.
Huge!
I died.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
No, no, it's fine.
Good trade.
Fuck.
You're on, you're on, you're on.
He missed, he missed, he missed the girl.
Nice, no more health, no more.
Nothing, nothing.
Mag died!
Mag fell!
Mag fell off, oh my god.
He fell off for reset, he fell off for reset.
Yeah, he's just resetting, he's resetting.
Oh, he's just resetting?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're gonna have...
They have no Groot combo, but they have Moonlight Health, so...
Yeah, I'm gonna build my ult really quick.
He just drilled.
What?
No, nothing, nothing.
I'm gonna ult this, okay?
I didn't know that was intentional.
They have Moonlight Ult, they have Moonlight Ult.
I'm not standing near all of you guys.
I'm gonna try and get my ult as quickly as possible.
I'm gonna hide over here.
Dude, they're getting destroyed up there.
That was one.
What the fuck?
Okay.
No, I got it, I got it.
You can use your ult here, you can use your ult here.
Fine.
Thank you.
Good job, good job, good job.
I'm ulting behind them.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Big ult, big ult, big ult.
Go, go, go, go.
Walk, walk, walk, walk.
Just walk, just walk, just walk.
Mesa's one, Mesa's one, Mesa's one, Mesa's one, Mesa's one.
He's dead, he's dead, he's dead.
Lucky's dead, Lucky's dead.
Nice, nice.
No, he got him, we got him, we got him.
We got it, we got it, okay.
Oh my god, we did it!
Nice!
Come on, guys.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, first place!
We win it!
First place!
Good shit.
Oh my god.
Good job, guys.
Good job, kid.
We got it.
We got it, first place.
Oh my god, bro.
Oh my god, man.
Oh, if I had got that kill, I think we would have lost.
Yeah, that was a big kill there.
That was a huge kill there.
Yeah.
That shit was scary.
Yeah, no, when I pinged my last fight, I was so fucking scared.
I didn't realize she saw me.
Oh my god, dude.
Oh my god.
Sorry for the old goofs, but we did so good.
No, it's alright, we did it!
Yeah, we still made it work.
We made it work!
We did it!
3-0!
Dude, good job, everybody.
I'm so happy to play with all of you guys.
That's a good way, that's so cool.
We went on a training arc and we succeeded.
We did it!
I get to eat duck, oh my god, I get to eat duck.
Oh my god, you gotta tweet that picture out, dude.
I'm gonna live through you.
Winner, champion, duck.
Right there.
That was intense.
That was, yeah.
How much damage did Gomez...
42 kills!
Holy fuck.
Oh my god, Bettle almost matched Gomez's damage, look at that.
Yeah, he went crazy.
Oh my god, Bettle, you went...
Dude, Bettle was insane as well.
The Maggles were nuts.
They were so good.
He was getting two.
I'm glad we banned Strange, I'm so happy we banned him.
Yeah, I think it would've been rough with Strange.
Yeah, yeah.
Dude, good job guys, we fucking did it!
We did it, yeah!
G2s, everybody!
Our two week training art paid off, guys.
G2s, man.
Oh my god.
I'm not playing this game for like two days.
I'm taking a break.
I'm decaying in two days, I have to play one ranked match today.
Oh my god, we are the VTuber champions!
Every single one of us, a VTuber.
All of us, all of us.
I'm so tired, yay.
Oh my god, me too.
Oh, I cannot wait.
I'm not used to waking up this early.
Me too, I can't wait to sleep till 12pm, like sleep till 2pm again.
Dude, I'm getting blasted.
Drinking?
You're drinking tonight?
Drink, yeah!
Bettle, what's it like to win for the first time?
Oh, it feels good.
Got a W.
GGs, guys.
Those were some fucking insane games.
Thank you for inviting me.
Yeah, thank you for inviting me.
Thank you for inviting me as well.
Thank you for joining my team.
We got another tourney?
Fuck, I have to go to another tourney.
Wait, right away?
Is your team next?
I think so.
Don't eat any more sushi.
I won't, I won't.
You got another tournament.
I think you earned it, bro.
Maybe one more sushi, you know?
Yeah, just one more sushi.
Oh, I thought it was done.
You earned that.
Eat that sushi.
Look at our tournament.
You have like 30 minutes to an hour.
Okay, so you have 30 minutes to chill.
Our leaderboard... sorry, our match history looks really good.
Yeah, oh yeah.
It's a golden carpet.
Yeah, we fly golden carpet.
Oh my god.
Just don't drink?
Okay, I won't.
Look at that.
Oh my... just don't scroll down, guys.
Don't scroll down.
It looks a little awkward.
Yes, our games are still there.
They're still there.
Union Battles games are still there.
Late night special.
Thank you so much again, Doki.
It's not something I ever thought that I would do.
Because I get stressed about competition, even though I'm really competitive.
So it was really nice to know that I can step up and do it.
No, you did great.
You did fucking great.
You did great.
You had to save some of these games.
You literally did.
I remember you had so many good reses, too.
Yeah, good soul, good soul.
Thank you so much, everyone.
It was awesome.
All of us, and Jay, too.
Also, he shouted Jay as well.
He got locked out, so he can't join in the PC.
I feel like everyone had their game-saving moment.
Yeah, everybody contributes.
Every matchup we had, we had someone that did the winning play.
Like crazy.
Yeah, that went crazy.
We did depend on Gomez a little bit, but even when he dies, we still survive without him.
So, like, we all have, like, sustainability for ourselves.
Thanks for having me.
I know my schedule is kind of all over the place, but I'm happy to be here.
It was amazing.
The scrims were very helpful, by the way.
We would not be here without them.
Yeah, no, 100%.
I'm glad we scrimmed.
If we'd just gone in raw, that would've been disastrous, I think.
Yeah, they just insta-banned Beto's mag, and we're just like, what do we do?
Yeah, now you can play two characters!
Look at that!
It's only up now!
And if ever you guys ever want to play ranked, it was awesome playing ranked with you as well, so I'm always up for it.
Absolutely.
I'm down the game with y'all in private times.
Can we get Jay in here so we can say we love Jay?
Yeah, wait, where's Jay?
Yeah, get Jay in here!
Who was the VC people?
I forgot.
I'm not saying the name again.
Whitey?
Can we get Whitey in here to help us?
You can't call Jay that, Doki.
That's fucked up.
Do I need to dox this guy's profile to prove that he's a real person?
I don't know.
I swear to God, guys, his name is Whitey.
I swear to fucking God.
We are not...
We're not calling people out for other things.
Hello?
Oh, Jay!
What's up, man?
You all did so good, bro.
I was watching the whole time.
Oh, Jay.
I'm so stressed.
Jay, you got us there, too.
During day one, you got us there.
Yeah, you did so good, Jay.
Thank you.
Oh my God, it's an honor to be able to play with you guys.
Holy shit.
Of course, of course.
Of course, and you also helped train Betel, too.
What about you?
I'm sure you did the thing, and I didn't get stronger!
Yeah, you taught Betel how to fly up and all.
It's still Betel's hard work.
Guys, I still have the replay of our old scrims.
Betel just walking up to them and...
Let Betel celebrate.
Don't bring that up.
Yeah, but now look at you.
You fly up!
The ultimate slam dunk would be to show him walking up in MS Paint diagrams.
With the Dr. Strange PNG, and be like, this is how you used to all.
Oh, man.
I'm so proud of all of us.
I didn't know.
I felt like we could easily make it to the grand finals, but I didn't know if we were going to get first or second.
I had faith all along.
Yeah, I was like, out of 100 plus teams, we got first place, too.
As we started playing more, I felt more and more confident.
Yeah, me too.
Everybody was filling in their roles really well.
We meshed together really, really well.
Yeah, we didn't second guess each other.
Limeo and I, when we first played support together, Limeo would run away from me.
SoloQ was a different game.
It's crazy, like half the time I would be like, okay, I'm healing my co-healer.
Then the enemies would switch to me and the other person would be like, okay, have fun.
Yeah, good luck.
Oh, my God, but we did it.
Congratulations, everybody.
We did it!
We did it, first place!
First place!
GGs!
We're the champions!
We did it.
If they bring VTuber Rivals 2 again, I wonder if we can come back together as a team.
Surely they would let us.
Yeah, surely they would let us.
We're like the champions.
The run back.
The run back, I want the run back.
I'll know Dr. Doom by then.
I wonder, wait, what do we get from this?
It's just the credits, right?
No, we get actual money.
Yeah, so each of us get...
And credits.
You get $200 worth of credits.
So you can buy any skins.
You don't have to buy skins for a while.
Or if you want to rename your account like a hundred times.
Yeah, that's an option as well.
Good idea.
And also we get cash.
I think we get $300 each.
On top of it.
Yeah, but it could be more because...
Can I just buy every skin?
You can, right now.
With those credits, yeah.
I think that's more than enough to buy every skin.
Wait, what?
Really?
Yeah, $200 worth of credits is more than enough to buy every skin.
Oh, I didn't know that.
That's crazy.
Oh, wait, there's a lot more.
Is there not?
I thought it is.
No, there's way more.
Wait, really?
Oh my God, you're right.
I was going to say, there's a lot of skins in this game.
We can buy a lot of them, though.
Your favorite ones.
You can.
If you only play a few heroes, then you're good.
All the skins for your role.
Yeah, I'm waiting for them to release an Adam Warlock skin that I actually like.
Same with me, too, for Luna.
I hate the Luna ones.
I already got all the skins I want.
Yeah, but they may release new ones.
Until Doom comes out, bro.
Yeah, I want to buy the Doom skins.
Get the Robert Downey Jr. Doom.
Oh, true.
Hold on.
Guys, you know what I'm most proud of?
We beat a Groot team.
We did.
We did beat a Groot team.
Finally!
We never won against a Groot team until now.
In the tournament.
We have to face our fears.
That was like our worst matchup, too.
And we still managed to do it somehow.
Yeah, the Groot Moon Knight.
The moment we went Groot Moon Knight, we were like...
Not the combo.
The nasty combo.
GG's, guys.
Everyone did great today.
Happy to play with all of you guys.
Hope we get to do something together again in the future.
Yeah, absolutely.
I'm so down.
GG's.
We are the champions.
I'm not done yet.
Oh yeah, you guys, go to your next tournament.
You know what's crazy, dude?
This guy has to go to another tournament and then I have to scrim for another tournament next week, too.
Wait, really?
Which one?
Yeah, which tournament, huh?
I think you know.
No, it's this week.
This week?
It's this week?
No, you're lying.
It's next week.
You were like, what?
You're all warmed up, bro.
Yeah, it's true.
Wait, do you have...
Wait, really?
Wait, do you know your team yet?
Uh, I think so.
Wait, what the fuck?
I don't know my... I only know Surefour's on my team.
I think we're still trying to lock in a few more people, so I'm not 100% on that, but...
Yeah.
I just need to not touch this game for a little bit.
You need to not what?
A day.
I think that's all I get is one day and then I have to scrim.
Okay, it's fine.
That's crazy.
What the fuck?
You already know most of your team.
Yeah, I do.
I think I know four or five.
Yeah, I know your team.
Your team is the one...
Oh, really?
Yeah, because he sent me the list.
So, there's only two teams that's locked in all members and yours is one of them.
It is?
Okay, then I'm behind.
I've not looked at the DMs, obviously.
I mean, the past few days have been so long, bro.
This is so... Oh my God, it's like 4 p.m.
ETSD.
This took over my life.
This actually took over my life.
This is the whole weekend.
This is the entire weekend.
I literally did research and watched VODs and took notes of teams and everything.
I was locked in.
You guys were prepping.
The only thing that made us not as sweaty as other teams is that we didn't mute our comms during games.
When I was researching, some teams would unlist their VODs after the stream's over or they would mute their comms and not show the screen of their ban line.
So we won't know.
I did not know that was a thing.
Yeah, it's a thing in pro tournaments.
Pro players do that.
I have to do it for the next tournament.
I feel like trash doing it, but I have to do it.
Yeah, he hates it.
My team, I hate it.
We also honored when people didn't get their bans off.
You remember that?
Cody is still...
That was weird!
It was weird.
Cody is still thinking about that guy.
Because I didn't get to flame them!
I guess.
If it was one thing, it'd be okay.
But the bro after, like, come on.
He did like three things after.
It was like the double whammy.
It was like, I'm sorry.
I'll try to fix it, I guess.
Oh my god.
GGs, everyone.
I'm going to clickbait you again, okay?
Just so you know.
GGs.
Gomez,
I hope your stomach feels better.
Yeah, I feel better, Gomez.
I'll be good.
I ate that sushi.
I'm a little... I feel a little...
Eat another sushi.
I'm good.
I've never seen that at all.
It was such a fun journey.
I actually really liked this one.
It was great.
It was very fun.
I learned so much, man.
I learned so fucking much from this.
I think we all, like, got better as players, too.
Hell yeah.
Thanks, Hogs.
Yeah, shout out to Hogs coaching battle.
Goddamn.
He learned Strange in, like, two weeks.
That's crazy.
It took him his entire career to learn Mag, but two weeks to learn Strange.
Yeah.
No, you did a great battle.
You did great.
You did awesome, dude.
Seriously.
You killed it, bro.
Yo, you did some insane slam dunks there.
Yeah.
Good slam dunks, bro.
I can't get over your Strange ults.
Against, was it Riggs' team?
Twice to save it.
That was a big one, yeah.
Yeah, that was a huge one.
That was a huge one.
The one where you went through the Invisil and be like, Surprise!
What are we talking about?
Shoto blocking the ults.
Oh, yeah, twice.
That was amazing.
It was like a 3D movie.
You're like, I can block it.
And we're like, what?
I think I watched a stream where I saw Namork do that.
And I was like, you know what?
I'm going to try it.
And it does work.
You're going to try it in the tournament.
I mean, it worked, though.
It worked.
You're like, you know what?
This is it.
This is my moment to shine.
Never done it before, but let's try it.
That was such high risk, though.
High risk, high awards.
And you got it.
That was my peak, though.
I can't peak after that.
Until next week.
Until next week, Shoto.
You're going to pop off next week.
It's going to be great.
Yeah, the toast one.
Wait, that's next week?
Yeah.
Okay.
I thought it was further away.
Wait, that's what you guys were talking about?
I don't know my team in that either.
Wait, can you join my team, Coney?
You can ask.
No, request off of him.
You ask.
I already asked so much stuff.
I'll see.
I don't know.
He asked me, he was like, what rank are you?
I said, I'm GM3.
We need that.
Well, no, the next day I was like, wait, I'm Celestial now.
And I was like, I did get boosted.
Yeah, just tell him he got boosted by me.
And then he'll be like, oh, okay.
And then he'll give you a GM.
Okay, then he's not going to let me on your team if you boosted me.
Oh, can you just say you got boosted by a pro player?
And then he'll be like, oh, okay, then you're definitely GM.
We'll see that.
I'll ask him.
I'll see if I can be on the team.
I didn't know it was set teams this time.
Yeah, no, it is.
Coney, be on my team.
I'll try.
I'll get in there.
Yeah, because Wig might be on my team too.
And then you and Wig can...
I'll ask.
I don't know if I'll get it, but we'll see.
All right.
Cool.
I'm going to talk to him in my chat now, but GG's everybody.
GG's.
GG's, guys.
Remember to get your duck showed on, everybody.
Get that duck.
Get that duck showed on.
Get a picture of it.
Yes, sir.
I'm going right now.
I'm getting ready right now.
Get a picture.
Get a picture of Wig.
You best believe I will.
Power that fucker.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Take care.
GG's, everyone.
Oh, my!
We're the champions!
Thank you, everyone.
I'm so happy we won.
I'm really, really happy.
Oh, I did not expect to win.
I really didn't, but oh, my gosh!
Our training paid off, everyone!
Oh, I won my first real Marble Rivals tournament!
And I won it, the real one, not the content creator one.
This is like actual...
I mean, this is technically content creator Marble Rivals, but like, you know what I mean?
Not like randomized teammates and stuff like that.
I didn't get to do the Twitch Rivals one, but I get to do... I finally was able to do a VTuber.
I get to do like an actual Marble Rivals tournament of a set team and us scrimming and practicing.
And out of a hundred plus teams, we got number one!
Thank you, everybody, for watching!
Thank you, guys.
I really appreciate it.
The VA everyone... Oh my gosh.
I'm so happy.
I'm really, really happy.
Thank you, everyone, for watching.
Thank you, everyone, for supporting.
I really appreciate it.
We have a... We... Ah!
We did so well.
I'm really, really happy, guys.
Thank you all for the support.
I hope you guys enjoyed watching this tournament.
We didn't really stream any of the practices because like, I didn't want to stream the...
I was like tired to stream scrims and stuff, so I didn't stream any of the scrims.
So we didn't really have like a little arc going in there.
But like, technically there was an arc between day one and two.
Yeah, I'm gonna be taking two days off tomorrow and Tuesday.
So just to recover from this long stream.
Seven hours.
Oh my god, seven hours.
But yes, thank you, everybody.
I'm glad I researched teams last night and also like took notes.
I'm glad I watched the loser finals to take notes.
And I watched the exact moment Mace was telling his team that like...
Because then if I didn't, we were gonna ban Mag first.
We were gonna do a Mag ban.
So I was... I'm glad that I caught that exact moment where they were like, yeah, we need a ban.
We need a... It's better that they ban Mag.
What a coincidence, too.
The moment I turned on the stream and they said that.
Yeah.
Thank you, everybody.
As always, everyone.
I'm gonna head off now.
I'm glad...
Oh, you guys really think my IGL was that good?
Thank you, guys.
I'm not really...
You know, I had to take over the IGL role.
Like, I was co-IGL with Gomez, but like...
Why are you barking?
What are you eating?
He's being needy.
Noki!
No!
He Magged.
He had his walkies!
I walked him during the stream.
But like, it was very scary taking over IGL role when he was fucking dying.
So...
So, yeah, but I'm... Oh, man.
I'm happy everything went well in the end.
And I did really well IGLing, yeah.
And like, making sure everyone had to do macro and micromanage and stuff like that.
But thank you, everyone.
Thank you for all the superchats.
Thank you for... Wait, let me read.
I'll read a little bit.
You know what?
I feel good today.
I'm gonna read a little bit of superchats.
I know I should stop streaming, but I'll read three superchats because...
I still wanna... I wanna... I wanna, you know, read some.
Oh, there's one.
Second, thank you for the superchats.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats, team.
When's dog cam?
I'm trying to see where he is.
Soon, soon.
Whenever I'm getting... Whenever I'm better.
Whenever I'm better.
Was it a birthday superchat?
Whose birthday was it?
I'm looking.
I'm trying to see.
Thank you.
Oh, Hope, thank you for superchats!
Thank you, thank you.
If you're still here...
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday, dear Hope, happy birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, everybody.
Thank you, guys, so much.
And then...
Let me see.
Ivy, thank you for the superchats.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's go!
I really appreciate it.
Simon, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
3-0 on a team tournament with Kony.
You might be a power duo.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kony is like the vibes of the team.
Um, he's like, honestly, like, he's like either like a big brother, uh, or like an uncle.
Uh, and he's like such a huge vibe.
He's like the unc...
He, I mean, to be fair, he's more like the uncle of any team he's in.
Uh, because all of us are like young and he's like our...
He's here to give us reality.
The uncle slash big bro.
Yeah.
Yes, he has a child.
Um, but yes, thank you all.
I'm gonna rest my voice now.
Thank you, everybody, for watching.
What a fucking arc.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'm gonna rest my voice now.
I've been talking for seven hours.
As always, everybody, uh, I'll see you guys later.
Bye.